I'll send you a link for
four. Here we go. Three dos.
Uno. Yes, and we're live ladies champion.
Brandon shot with the official
Comedy Store Jersey on.
That's a real comedy store Hoodie.
That's the real shit. It's the real deal.
I'm like a doormat. I looked
like a doorman. Yeah, I wear
those shits all the time.
I love them. Yeah, me too. I know.
It's only got one mother fucking head of
security if you're working in the door.
You know what I mean? To answer.
I would do a, I'd work though.
I'd be a dorm at the comedy store.
Especially gave me spots. No,
I had 100% sure of that. Yeah.
You get those 1:00 AM spots.
You don't want them spots or
spots or confidence crushers.
He'll make you want to quit those.
Why am I doing those spots are good.
If you Dave Chappelle, they're good. If
you've been doing standup forever. Yeah,
they're good. If you're Dave Chappelle
and then you can walk into anything. Well,
the thing about that is like,
it's also good for you to be in
front of a tired small crowd.
Like a tired small crowd is good to
test out shit. You know, those are,
those are good. I did a, I did a spot, uh,
an unannounced spot the other
night at the comedy store in the,
or it was like half pack and what
time, but no, it was fairly late.
It was fairly late, but it was a, people
were beaten down. It's a different animal.
Their energies. Yeah, it's differently.
They come in after dinner
Hounsell different, you know,
you can get fucking real used to
like Louis C k you should say that.
Like he likes to just show up and
even though he was really famous and
everything like that,
when he was doing this still is right.
But when he would show up, what he liked
is that they weren't there to see him.
So then he would get a more
honest response to his material,
that fake shit
like that.
Like when you go on,
the guys that go on are the actors
that go on like Jimmy Fallon or Jimmy,
like anything they say.
They say the crowd is,
they got that applause sign ready to go.
You know what's really hilarious when
you watch those guys tried to stand up
when they get in their head that they
can't then you know like, come on,
I can't fail. I'm, everybody loves me.
I was in to go up at the store
but I'll tell you what man,
Michael Rappaport is getting
pretty fucking sporty.
I saw him do a couple of minutes the
other day and he seemed like a real comic
and I know he's only been
doing it for like a little bit.
He did it before and then he got into
acting. I think he tried it before,
but yeah, he's, he's getting,
he's getting good. He's getting,
I saw him once and it was,
he was struggling a little bit,
but it could've just been the crown. But
then I saw him recently, I'm like, damn,
he's a tall motherfucker til I never
realized that he's tall as fuck.
He was tall, pretty tall, taller than you.
So he's a little shorter than shops to
Andre Fili, Andre Fili and miles jury.
That's a good fucking fight.
Fight. So here we are folks.
This is a fight companion. This
is ESPN, its first real card,
not on ESPN plus this is on ESPN,
ESPN,
which is huge for the sport and
Cain motherfucking Velasquez.
My vote for the best heavyweight in
the UFC ever. I think that's fair.
Most accomplished is Steve Bay for sure.
So I mean it's hard for breezy over
doing what a fucking record that guys,
you get argument forever.
Minute. He's got it.
There's a good argument for a minute for
a [inaudible] being one of the greatest
of all time because or the greatest
because he tapped into Tarro tap cane
tapped, uh, tap fade or I mean, who the
fuck is tapped all those guys? Yeah.
I mean he's a motherfucker.
But as far as what I've seen from like
when he's in his prime, well, you know,
outside of all his injuries,
Kane at one point in time was just
a storm. And you know, I talked to,
it was really funny,
man.
We were backstage and I was talking
to Bob Cook and he's, and I was like,
people want to try to ride that storm out.
And they were laughing.
Bob Cuccos a storm, never hands storm,
never ends, does it with his tenacity.
Cardio was insanity.
It didn't even make sense.
Remember when he beat a jds
when it was j d 36 off of them?
I haven't been the same. He
was on the First Fox card. Yes,
it lasted 26 seconds. Yeah, Jane, yes. But
he wouldn't, he wasn't good for business.
This should not have been fighting.
You know that jds. Sure enough,
no cane had a really fucked
up knee in that fight.
First round miles, jury, Andre Fili.
And then of course Keynes fighting the
scariest motherfucker in the history of
the sport, in my opinion. And
glass. She could read your list,
your cardio machine after Steve Bay.
You know,
Steve Bay kind of exposed some
holes in his game, but you know,
the guy's only been fighting for
a few steps. He did explosive.
But the apprentice is credit that,
I mean he fucking ate some big shots
but it's steep and he took it unless all
five rounds. So he came back and had
a terrible fight with Derek Lewis.
But Derrick Lewis is a beast and
he in that, it was very nervous.
It was a bad fight. But then came back
and stop Curtis blades. Yeah. Clickers.
Curtis Curtis is a mother fucker.
He is a mother's worst fight.
Derrick Lewis Francis,
which we thought there's gonna be
fireworks or Paul Daley Mvp last night.
Um, no. Do Man Fuck you. Well Paul,
you know what I'm a wrestler now
do it was crazy. It was, it was,
it wasn't good. But it was
better than Francis versus
Derek think. Yes. Yes it was.
There was moments of action. Yeah, there
was, there was able to take down. Oh yeah.
Which is not going to be Pete. Take him
down. Yeah. But it's not as a shit show.
It's not good for MVPs. I imagine
what Tyron Woodley would do to MVP.
Imagine we don't have to worry about it.
She doesn't have to worry about it.
Cause he's employed in Mcdonald's
though his we've another way macdonald,
but a real renaissance Fitch,
Fitch.
But well John Fitch though he's
gotta be able to grab a hold of him.
The thing about Paul dailies,
he fucking threatens a shit
out of you with that power.
He's got the scariest lefthand in
the sport that's left ends. But yeah,
100% he scares the shit
out of you with that power.
You got to mind your p's and q's.
But what I like about page is that I've
always said that one day we're going to
see a guy who's a fighter who
learns how to do other shit.
Cause those guys are impossible to hit
because their whole thing is lunging in
lunging at lunch a little bit,
right? When a boy a little bit,
but he's more of a kickboxing,
a point fighter. Phenomenal.
Kickboxer I mean nominal but,
but what will you see from MVP is like
one of the best fighters that's ever even
attempted to fight and it
doesn't get touch. He's so good.
Championships with real
against Raymond Daniels.
You should see the two of them fight
like Raymond Daniels was another one who
was a legit worldclass point fighter and
MVPs undefeated in professional boxing.
Yes, but the file is he fighting?
Well, nobody's, but still the re,
the first real fight she had was last
night against daily and there was some
holes. There were some holes that were
exposed. It was way too easy for daily.
That's true. He's only certain fights
way too easy for daily to take them down.
Not that daily dozen. His next fight is
going to be tough. What was Chris? Yeah,
really tough.
But what's crazy is it daily was talking
so much shit on John Fitch after John
Fish took him down to daily's,
all he does is talk shit about guys
wrestling and then he took it down.
I was like, I literally, I was like, what
is happening right now? I was frustrated.
I was like, what is happening? Right?
We're what's happening right here. Miles.
Jury's already busted up. We're not
even paying attention. God. Well,
you got to talk about fucking Paul Daley.
It was unbelievable.
And I didn't realize how big MVP was.
I didn't know.
He's six [inaudible] so tall for this,
for that division,
and also like uses it.
Here's his reaches insane.
He does sneaky shit too.
He did this like this sneaky right hand.
Did he hit him with,
he tried to hit him with a
hook kick at one point in time.
He landed that front kick.
Yeah. He's a beast man.
If he gets his wrestling takedown
defense on point, I mean,
he's a phenomenal athlete, but the thing
he tagged gift though it is a big gift,
but the thing that he, but he goes to
London shoot fighters, great God damn gym.
The thing that he's missing, you know,
I mean, is it just the wrestling,
takedown defense just
to take down defense?
Like if you could take a page out of
style, Benders, book style, been around.
I'm not too worried about him
fighting. Grappling. Right, right. All,
he's hard to take down.
Very tough take down and you're coming in,
you're going to pay it. Yeah.
He's so God damn technical.
He might be the most technical
striker in the sport.
I watched him in glory
the other day. I was, uh,
working out watching some old
glory fights with style. Ben,
when he fought Jason Wellness,
his movement, he's in class.
I mean wellness is a world champion
dude. How about Roy Nelson and Cro?
Cop fought last night to cro. Cop look
good. God. What's he, what happened?
Cro. Cop wanted decision, right? Yeah.
When did he take Roy Jones down or,
or how Nelson Nelson.
That'd be a safe flight.
It look the same till today.
Once a Croatian with a black guy
talking about Roy Nelson was one of the
greatest boxers of all
time. The, yeah, they both,
they both look like exactly how
they look. They, it was like going,
Nelson Hits harder than
Roy Jones right now.
George has tagged Andre Fili. He just
tagged him with the left hand. Uh,
yeah. I think if you had them on
that power meter, I think, uh,
I think Roy probably hits harder,
but he also weighs 150 pounds more close.
He's probably Roy.
Roy Jones Jr is probably
about 200 pounds these days.
But when Roy was fighting shape, God, he
was fun. Well when he was at his heaviest,
he was about 200 right when he fought.
John Ruiz won the heavyweight title. Yeah,
that was a phenomenal fight. When you
watch that, I mean that was just artistry,
speed and precision versus a,
you know, a world champion.
And John Ruiz who's a real good fighter,
he's a real good heavyweight fighter.
But Roy Jones was at that time,
you know the, the big fucker, the big fuck
up. Rather it was going from that fight,
dropping down to fight Tarver at one 75
on back down 25 pounds and looking like
shit, looking like dude. And Tarver
is a monster. He's a monster.
And also Tarver and him had gone to a
decision in one fight earlier and Tarver
thought he won.
And you know,
Roy Roy apparently had something
to say about, you know,
why he didn't perform at its best.
So when they were faced off tonight and
the referee goes, any questions? He goes,
God,
he excuses tonight Roy.
And then he went and knocked him
out to have Tara. So he was so,
so good. Get back. These guys, forget
about Tom. Are you still doing it?
Man Steals it was six people. Know
what you're talking about. No,
Tara and told him the magic man.
You don't know.
Fight companion fans down now
get the fuck total car fans.
Now look at this and Roy Jones,
we get this sharp jab boxing better than
ever right now though. Cause you're,
you got fury. Then you got
wilder rematch coming up in May.
That's happening in Brooklyn. Spoiler
work in Brooklyn. Are you working on that?
Probably work in that. Am I
special? Comes out same way.
I know. Um, how did uh, do
in 12 new minutes? Go. They
don't want good last night.
Nice. Right? I'm new minutes
or scarify super scan.
Also like to when you were
talking beginning of the show,
there was in my crowd they didn't
mark and me beyond none of the,
none of those people are my people.
And wait, good man. I was so nice.
It was weird for me to drive back.
This isn't fucking good fight.
We're missing a good fight.
I know, man. I never,
I always have to watch fights
when I get back home. I recorded.
I know we talked so much shit. I know
there's just so we don't see each other,
so we got to catch up and shit.
Is Miles jury still with alliance?
Does anybody know?
I know he has his own gym and I
think in San Diego and San Diego. Oh,
he branched off I think so.
He was a dominant cruises stablemate
right. They trained together.
Oh, feely with a nice right hand
dude. Where did I thought, uh,
the Francis was going to go to a new camp
and I saw he's just training fulltime
in France. I'm like the match wrestling
and France, but we'll figure it out. Hmm.
Maybe just hitting the heavy
bag. I mean, where would he go?
Like you want them to go to two places?
In my opinion,
I'd want them to go to either
att or Aka. Right. Att a log.
They've got enough heavyweights and they
have a phenomenal coaching staff. Right.
But you want,
you want someone big to work with an AK.
They're not really gonna probably take
him or go to elevation fight team where
you got Curtis blades and Overeem who
he's fought bolts. Right, right. Yeah.
Great coaching at the altitude there.
Yep. That's pretty striking Krishna.
That altitude training is,
it's really interesting.
I was talking to Tj Dillashaw and you
know he used to think that out training
was where it's at until he started working
with cal Avida and he thinks that you,
you get more work in, I agree with him.
Yeah. Working at sea level. Yeah. Cause I,
my whole career was in Denver and then
when you come to sea level you're like
fuck, I can do work. I can put work. Yeah.
So like what they're saying is like the
amount of reps in the amount of work you
do, like what he's doing with
Colivida is fucking phenomenal.
The podcast I did with him was one of
the most informative podcasts I've ever
done with a fighter in terms of like
how technical his training routine is.
His Diet is how everything is broken down
to a science as far as like what to do
when and when to do what is at another
level than anyone else and to see,
unless unless someone's on it
and they're not talking about,
but when TJ talks about it, yeah, there's
no one more in tuned with their body.
Then Tj,
that fucking Aaron Peko and he's getting
on that same level because he trains
with them, but I asked as
teacher, I'm like, why isn't,
why didn't you just follow
you around? He's like, dude,
he has all these people kind of pulling
them every which way. I'm like, dude,
he should just do what you do. Well,
he looked phenomenal, but he got wild.
That video. Do you ever see the video of
us watching him loose? Yeah, it's crazy.
We jumped up.
We're all fulfilling challenge.
That could have been one of the
most viral videos on Instagram,
like in the in that week. A number
of probably, yeah. That was crazy.
That knockout was insane. That was the
craziest reaction. Yeah, that knock.
I was insane and Callan's given
the general view. That was a punch.
That was a punch.
He hit him with his knuckle fight.
That's a fight.
That man that was dancing cracks me up.
I was like
such a silly goose. This is
a good fucking fight, man.
These guys are so well. Well
matched. Really good fight.
I did sterling beat Jimmy Rivera.
He must have.
He was laughing on the way. There's
a motherfucker. What happened?
Jamie [inaudible] sterling. Anyone
who trains I guess in the train room.
He's a freak. Super Freak. That's just
shows you how good Mala Mariah says.
Correct. He's the motherfucker I want
to see fight for the title. He too.
He's so good, man. When he got against
the sun sound, he finished. The Sun's out.
No one finishes him. 45 35 35 antimony.
Yeah. No one finishes a Sun. Sal.
You beat him with a close
decision if you're lucky.
I asked Tj about and he's
like, yeah, I'd fine,
but the all they care about the pseudo
rematch. Yeah. Unanimous decision. Oh Wow.
That's impressive for stroke story.
Got Caught.
Andre feelies in a bit of
trouble here. Oh, she always
root for mouse jury, do you?
I always do. They're shutting guys at
us. Always root for, do you know him?
Not that well. We did one show together.
That's it. It's getting them out
that
damn
feelies and a bit of trouble
here. Interesting. He's
pushing them to the cage.
Yeah, that is interesting.
That's not a good move because
he could, he could. Yeah.
Push off off the cage with his feet.
Can cause a scramble feeling
with a nice little hip escape
there.
Get to guard.
Um, what were we just saying?
Just before that that happened.
Sterling fight. Oh ow. Oh, more eyes.
Yeah, man. He's like, he's so good.
He Kod Sterling.
I mean bad homerun did Aoj
Jimmy Rivera in 10 seconds.
Yup. Yup. And both with the left
high kick, I believe. Oh Shit.
That's spinning back fist with
their own spinning shit. Now. Hamas,
Nick Diaz, he already said, man,
he said, I want to hurt nobody.
I want to party has done really
good for him, man. He has is done.
Yeah.
Because a Anderson,
someone was talking about Anderson
versus nick and Connor said,
I'll fight Nate on the same
card. And then Nick said, yeah,
I'm not fighting anybody. I
don't want hurt nobody. He
goes, I just want to party.
That's cool, man. Yeah. He gives
her a fucking amazing career.
You gotta remember Nick Diaz fought,
he was one of the youngest
guys to ever fight in the UFC.
I believe he beat Robbie
Lawler when he was 20. Dude,
he's beats you look at his resume. It's
impressive. Yeah. The guy said he's flat.
He's been doing for a hot second. He's
deserved. Yeah. Turning to survive.
Hopefully financially.
He's good too.
What do you think of this
Anthony Smith and John Jones?
What do you think of this? What are you
looking at? Uh, I looked at this guy.
I like Anthony Smith. It's a tough
go. You like them as a human being.
I love you like a person. I don't like
him to win. Does anyone ever do that?
But that's, that's his story,
right? Biggest wins mirror.
Yeah. I was in here was a big win. John
Jones would do those to man. I, it's,
but it's, it's, this is an Anthony Smith
thing, the focus on an empty, so it's,
it's a Jon Jones thing. I
don't know anyone in light
heavyweight or heavyweight.
That would be John Jones.
Damn strong words named Sylvia
heavyweight who'd beat him strong words.
You know what I'm saying? Like name
a tough matchup for med heavyweight.
If he just, if he goes, you know what, I'm
a fucking heavyweight now. Right, right.
Good luck. It's up to like
two 40 kilo. Yeah. God,
if he gets up to like Jack modified
like he was when he was powerlifting.
Oh my God. The thing about
that is though, like, you know,
I talked to Greg Jackson about that and
Greg was saying that he didn't like him
when he was powerlifting like that.
Um,
he knocked out Mauricio Shogun Hua.
He a knocked out.
Rashad lost a Tiago Santos.
I want to say that.
Was that middleweight that wasn't his
first fight in the light heavyweight was
Rashad some good wins. He's been fine.
He's not a young kid.
He's been fighting for a hot second.
I mean he knocked out portions
of the x factor for shot 70
it's 74 years ago of Rashad. Rashad
should should've been fighting. You know,
I think we're shot. His heart wasn't in
the game anymore cause he retired now.
Shot show this job retired and now he's a,
we're commentator.
He opened up tonight on the ESPN portion,
which is amazing.
He's shots great when the best guys
in this great guy, one of the best.
Have you had him on? No,
I would love to. I left.
Let's do it again.
Let's do it together.
Let's run a train on podcasts and
Trey, we're run a train. I love that.
He's such a sweet person. I've had
some conversations with them that guys,
he's a lot smarter than you might think.
That guy, that guy is, he's very smart.
He reaches out to me out of like when
things are going bad or I'm having an
issue, they're like, it's out in
the public who reach out to me.
Then I always give me like words
of wisdom. He's that guy, great,
great guy.
And you know,
you go back to his career when he knocked
out chocolate dealt with one punch pub
blasts are doing the hard thing was like,
I will never forget that because he
knocked him out and then he beat Forrest
Griffin. Do you know what he's
dealing with? What he's doing?
What he does the hard thing.
Do you know he's doing what he's about
to have a heart attack. Sanford and son,
Fred Sanford. Oh really? Oh No,
it's fun. Funny you remember that?
Oh well no, too young. Yeah, I
know what you're talking about.
But I remember his shot knocked up for
us and he was training with us and came
back to the gym and at the time I
wasn't in the UFC and I was like, dude,
got the belt, electric lines. I
was freaking out and he was like,
I feel exactly the same Brendan.
Nothing.
I thought it would be everything in more
and I want to be exact the same dude.
He's like,
he was almost kind of like,
it's not all that it's meant to be like
you think you get to the top of the
mountain and it's everything, but
he's like, I feel like I'm back here.
Dream everyone. He coached against
rampage. I was on that season. Oh,
that's my season was shot with my coach.
How's the second pig on team Rochelle?
Rochelle clothes, clothes dude. And
when they were in front of each other,
you a bitch. You a bitch, bitch.
Bitch is back for those like this.
This kid go so intense.
That whole show was like the fucking,
everyone was going to
pop off and then he said,
was he a division one championship and
state champion and not a lot of work? No,
not at all. In the all
American, all American.
His roommate was a great
Mannion gray manner. Wow. Hmm.
Meanwhile, we're missing a really
good fight. There's still going,
is this five rounds? No, it's the third
round, Bruh. I know if he done fairly
well,
we should tell people it's at 305130413031
30 to one 31 of the third round in
the first fight.
Sorry.
It's good that we don't
give people expectations.
What we're going to do here when we do
fight companions, I zero expectations.
Zero is my favorite podcast we ever do.
I like more,
more forward to this and yeah.
I mean I love doing podcasts
with scientists and geniuses
and to work though in
in a little bit. No, no, it's a different
fee. You got to do some research too.
I liked doing that though, but
it's different feel. This is this.
This is this party. So hang out man.
This is fun. What are you smiling at?
Eddie doesn't believe in science
and he's all your bull
shit and your science.
I believe in science than I can there
you could see what your own eyes.
Yes. I believe the science of this
iPhone. That's real. It's just fear.
It's real as fuck. Dude,
I was watching this.
I was thinking about he did it cause
I don't have cable right now because I
moved. So we're Winfrey Kim. So all I have
is Netflix. I was watching this earth,
planet earth and will Smith
is the narrator on it.
It's all about earth and they're like
scanning up and it's astronauts talking
about what they saw from space the
whole time. I was thinking, God,
Eddie must watch this is some bull
shit. These liars, those, this,
watch this, watch this bull shit.
That ain't real. This moon shot.
How many hours they had in space, like 72
hours in space. Eight hours. I was like,
I bet Eddie saying fuck these. Meanwhile
we have no idea who won this fight.
Miles. Jury. You think so? Nope. I have no
idea. But that's what counts. Good for it.
Cause he will, he won't listen to us
and he'll watch it in the neck. Miles,
jury two rounds to one. You might be
right. That mother fucker's late. Yeah.
Well he beat him up. He landed late.
He's in Burbank. Elliot, I don't know.
He didn't say just sit as
flatland. The blade. Yeah man.
Then MVP fight was bullshit.
So I was so pissed and I love Scott Coco.
I was going to tweet out something like,
you know what,
I'm just gonna let them write.
Everyone's probably piling on daily.
I don't want to be that guy.
I'm just going to back out and fight.
Didn't end like two
shows in a row. Yup. Friday,
Saturday. I do that all the time.
They have one on paramount and
then they have one on zone.
I watched it on to zone in my phone.
Um,
I got one of those design
accounts and you know, I was,
I was in Vegas for this event my
daughter was doing and so I, I heard it.
I'm like, I'll be right back.
I fuck. I couldn't find it.
My daughter was done with her things.
I had to run to the top of the stairs
and watch that shit. Some bullshit.
I said,
I told my wife what I was doing.
I flew up from the commie strategy
hangout field's going to be there. We,
which was talked some business about the
show. And I literally, I was like, dude,
I have to go. He's like, why? Like dude,
MVP and daily or finding say Ku. I'm like,
I'll pay you later. Let's just talk to
mom. I fucking flew home after my set.
I get home and I'm waiting.
I'm like,
what the fuck is you have to zone
or did you watch it deserve? Yeah,
they got a lot of good
fights on that there.
I mean I didn't even know what the fuck
it was. Daaz it looks like Dayson. Right?
Terrible name, but it's
a bad name. It's, it's,
it's Dazn is to have cable
to watch the fight. No, no.
You can watch it on you.
Yeah.
I just watched,
I watched it on my phone cause paramount
network you'd have to have like you
have to have an account
with direct TV or some shit,
but to zone he covers
whatever paramount fights out.
Did that cause people don't
have TV no more so people don't,
so they got to just have it
just through your goddamn app.
I literally don't make me get it happened.
Then I got to order fucking directv zone
as they spent a shit load of money on
Canelo Alvarez. They signed him to some
multiple hundred million dollar deal.
I think it's something like it's like
$300 million and he's the highest paid
athlete in the world. 365 million. Yeah,
some insane amount of money over 10 fights
and it's going to be all subscription
based. All on does zone. You
got to all, isn't that how it's,
isn't that how it's gone?
The future is no view.
Netflix subscription one pay wall.
What's interesting is if it's no paper
view, it's actually a really good deal.
Right? Because I don't know
what does own costs a month.
I just did the double click on my phone.
I didn't pay attention to how much that
should cost. Yeah, but what does it cost?
I don't. I don't know. It's fine
out what it costs for all the bands.
If you 70 bucks a month, it's 90 99 you've
got to think that if you're watching,
if you're watching a paper view,
like a big fight like wilder fury to
how much is that going to cost? 60
bucks a month, 10 bucks a month, and
you can watch fights all the time.
It's like my, my take on fight
pass. Like if you like fights man,
like in my gym I have, I live off of
fight pass. You swatch old fights.
I watch fights all the
time while I'm working out.
It's the best thing that you watch.
Why would look at Gbi I do.
I watched the whole, uh, Gordon
Ryan series the other day,
the whole little documentary they had.
I watched that was working out combat.
Did you get to fight ninth is
Friday. Oh Shit. La La, right? It has
this Friday on you. A UFC fight
pass 7:00 PM Pacific. Who,
who did you get to fill in for a,
was it Barnett got hurt?
Barnett's out to virgin got hurt.
Verdugo doom didn't get hurt.
It was supposed to be Gordon Ryan
versus [inaudible] Gordon [inaudible],
Gordon Ramsay Manor. So we're going to do,
we're going to do for Doom Gordon Ryan,
uh, later on this year. But, um,
it's a four man combat Jujitsu,
absolute at bracket with um,
a Uri Somos,
who's a arguably one of the,
one of the best Brazilian
Jujitsu practitioners ever.
ADCC medalist, gold medalist,
monster, monster. And then the,
the second seed is at John
Thor blank who want Ebi 17.
He wanted the finish the first and
only 16 man Combat Jujitsu tournament.
He wanted all in regulation,
all every fight within two minutes.
He said he subbed everybody.
So it's Uri and John Doerr
blank are the top two seeds.
And then if they win their first fights,
then they'll fight each other.
And then same night, same
night though, I'm Kevin Casey,
his fighting John Thor blank,
Alan Kevin cases.
He jumped in and as Stephen
Martinez is a local black belt,
he's fighting a Uri somos.
So on paper it looks like it'll be Uri
and John Blank on page or
anything can happen in the finals.
Plus we got the best Jujitsu
girl that's ever lived,
only only girl ever to when Abu Dhabi,
Ibj JFG and no gay black belt
and Ebi be a trace mosquito.
She is the baddest chick ever injured.
She's fighting combat Jujitsu against
Kayla Patterson should be slapping.
Awesome. She's going to be, yeah, it's
going to be awesome. I might come nice.
I like it when someone
gets hurt and the tag me,
Brendan Schaub get in there
like you're at your God damn
you fucking crazy.
When,
when you go back and think
about that cyborg fight,
would you ever think about doing that
again now man, I'm too busy. What?
Comedy is so hard. I'm so behind
the April. All my energies on this.
What do you think about this? What do you
think about Pettis fighting Wonderboy?
Good for you. Pedes I love, I get great
fighters and it kinda crazy though.
He's to,
it goes from 45 can't make it any more.
All the way up to 70 25 precinct about
it. Fucking this. How much of a beast?
Pegasus fights Tony Ferguson. Amazing
fire, right? Tony wins that. He gets hurt.
Then fucking, he was like, you
know, I've got to get a broke.
His hand pedes broke
his hand in that fight,
so it was a tough fight
for him either way.
But then he jumps up and he's fighting
Wonderboy both use me in a dog in both
fights. He's an underdog and both fights.
Yeah. Yeah. That, that, that first.
And if I was fun Aliya it show.
It shows you what?
A survivor Ferguson as he
gets clipped and you know,
he got hurt in that fight
and he just grabbed,
how about Max Holloway and Tony
Ferguson Talking Shit to each other?
The, that's the on the, on the dark
web. That's the room. I liked that,
but I don't like that. Why don't you
like it Ferguson versus could be.
I want to see that fight,
but why does he have to bebes out for,
he won't fight in Vegas. He has a
suspension, so he's out for a little bit.
Tony's ready to go that he won't do the,
the,
he won't do that thing that Vegas
is asking them to do commercial.
They're asking me to do a commercial.
It was like, you have prostitution,
you have gambling. Fuck you. What's
the best, so why does it, he's,
I guess he's right too. What is
the problem with Connor, Tony?
What's going on with that? How can that,
it's going to be Connor and cowboy.
Connor and cowboys had done deal as
far as I know, two. As far as I know.
As far as that we signed the
contract. It doesn't Connor. Tony,
make more sense though. Know what
kind of cowboys? Great. And Connor,
Tony's great. They're both great. They're
both great sites. If, if I'm, if I'm Dana,
I'm sitting on this. Eddie, you lie.
I want to be careful with Tony
because you love him, your friends.
I'm just saying why not?
Cause we'll need Connor that's been here.
Works for like two year. Here it
is. Eddie, Tony, Connor, Connor.
Be a slight underdog. I think in that
fight. Tony's a monster for anybody.
So I think Tony Max it and cop cars.
Connie's get a win. I'm not saying college
can be a huge favorite over cowboy,
but he's more favorable in that fight.
Then he is going, he's a window.
He comes back
and he needs to,
he needs a more favorable fight.
And I'm not saying that's a great Matt
Cowboy's a motherfucker and you know,
fire cowboys on fire right now.
He's just so lucid in the zone right now.
And Cowboy. Yeah, it's a great fight.
That's a perfect stylus screen.
That's a better fight for
cowboy and Connor. Yeah.
Tony's Tony is a great wrestling back
then and he's a motherfucker cardio for
days and he's crazy. I liked that fight
a lot. I really liked that fight a lot.
Max Holloway. Tony's Elf motherfucking
fight. I love that fight.
Marvel studios do superheroes.
I think they've run out of superhero.
This shit on my hoodies.
I don't know who is this?
Samuel Jackson is a
different superhero now.
Who is at the end of the Avengers movie?
Hey Samuel L.
Jackson say no to some captain
marvel, but who is, wait a minute.
Captain Marvel's a girl. Yeah, and she
and she brings all of them back to life.
Wait a minute. Who was captain marvel when
we were kids? Uh, dude, wait a minute.
I'll look. I don't know. It's
amazing that it's not a trans woman.
That would be dope. That's what
they're going to be enough trans.
Who's a weightlifting champions.
Yeah.
He comes sit down some cheese and wine
and cheese. No cheese. People get mad.
People get mad. She's chewing on
the microphone. We're pros, man.
You guys a couple of one,
two pros,
cheesy dude.
If you didn't bring stuff in provolone.
Hey, how about this fight? Uzman Huseman
versus Tyron Woodley. I love that.
That's March 2nd. Come on at. He's now
our secondary watch guys, come, come,
come to Vegas. Okay, here.
Captain Marvel was a guy and a girl
in the capital different. She was hot,
but that's from 2017 men. This is
when it's already been diversified.
Captain Marvel,
dude,
give me type in 1992 Spiderman
that just made captain marvel.
1956 when I was about this,
this spider verse movie that just came
out is that it's like only a four year
old Spiderman story. It's of, it's
not some old thing they brought back.
That's a cartoon. The captain captain.
Marvel's old school. No. Yeah,
but what are those? Spiderman is
like a duck, right? He's a pig, bro.
It's a great movie.
Best movie I've seen in long
term Bruce Lee and a superhero
and give them like powers.
My kids said Nate to the fucking legos
movie and what do you want to see?
The lego movie that
we seen. The other ones, my son loves
the Lego movie. Oh, it's the new one.
Both of them. A new one just came out.
How many have there been to? Only two.
Really? So cool. That Batman's a douchebag
girlfriend. Right? And
then the girlfriend,
because Han Solo pulls up in the
Millennium Falcon or whatever
mistake. Wait a minute. This is the old
captain marvel, but he was a damn shot.
Zam Zam Zam Zam also known as
Captain Marvel terms in marvelous.
She's him. Dude. If you held
a gun to my head and asked me,
it's Shazamm DC or marvel out
of cities DC for sure. Yes.
Yes.
That's what I was trying to say.
There was a captain marvel character in
the DC comics universe from back then.
I don't know. That's what you're
remembering, but that's one that existed.
So that's the confusion that's
Shizam will be looked like.
Is that like someone from Bella
tour fighting someone from the UFC.
Confusing dude.
All I know,
she comes back and you know how
everyone died in the last one. Spoiler,
it's been up for now a year or so.
Fuck off. She brings everyone back.
Then how the fuck she do that?
That's the comic books, Dude.
Do you remember and
Lego movie when Batman,
he leaves his girl to jump
in the Millennium Falcon
with Han Solo and Chewbacca,
and he says later he jumped in,
he thought he was gonna
Party like in space,
and then he comes back to what happened.
He goes, turns out that he's a dude
that was fucking hilarious.
There was no chicks because there's no
chicks on the middle of the android too
to deed. Okay. [inaudible]
68 1968 but scroll down.
That's the first appearance
was the image of a female girl.
68 two this picture,
but here's the deal.
Girls weren't built like that back then.
They're building.
It's a new thing now because those are,
until you scroll down,
let me see that image that's not
like a, Oh, a Primo crossfit chick.
That's legit. That's a new version
of her. Oh, and I'm in 2012 yeah,
that's a UFC fighter chick. Right? Okay.
That's what they used to look like. Wow.
There's multiple captains on a marvel,
so captain marvel, sometimes a guy.
Sometimes the girl about it goes both
ways. I can relate to it. We're just like,
all right, whatever. But
they run a silver surfer.
There's so many superheros that they have
like 10 different ones on Netflix and
Amazon ships.
You guys watch that fuck fucking
wasp girl or some shit. I can't
fuck with that. Or aqua man.
Get that shit out of me. This is a good
fight to Brian Barbarina in vicinity.
Luke K is a good fight if we didn't
watch miles. Jury, let's be real. Oh,
this is a good fight though.
For sure. This is a good
point. Won that fight. Miles.
Jury did a few late feel
decision. Yes. To seal it.
Even watching the decision.
Well, we watched the flight.
We were taught the decision. Oh
Shit Brian, but marina, good. Right?
Do I can't wait for the main event. Meet
you. I can't wait to get home. Gracie.
I want to see, I want to hear a
prediction on the main event prediction.
Brian Councils need to really just just
got here and we can get that mustache
bro. Up the bottle. Do we have
a bottle opener? Mustache?
It looks dark. Yeah. Looks cool. It
looks cool. I'm a good looking guy.
You are a handsome devil. You. Yeah.
Um, what do you think in the main event?
Cain Velasquez. Francis Sugano.
Well, well let me ask you this.
How has Francis going to solve canes,
wrestling or his cardio?
It's been trading in France. So
what's your, I mean it's true,
but I speak French been eaten.
Escar go and throw a nuclear weapons.
Would his hands true? This may be true.
It's was very dangerous, but he's,
I feel like guys, he's got a
one, a one shop puncher's chance,
but everything else came does,
including boxing. He's better at it.
I'm just for sure.
See what he looks like now after all
this time off injury and all that.
The injuries are the big ones.
You want me to open B?
You can open them all my
friend. It doesn't matter.
All right, let's get crazy.
Crazy. What kind of, what did you bring?
Anything? I went a little California.
I wasn't one Barolo and I
decided to go California. I went,
I went old standbys standard. Good. One
more red one. What do you think of that?
Menage a trois. I get from, I think what?
I think it's [inaudible] just tag Bob
Barbarina would've left hook Barbarino
never bring up my daughters. No, no, no
different guy. Brian [inaudible] Marina.
If you got,
if I look a little harder,
it's cause I was just at
American top team with my friend,
my good friend Dustin Poray,
Mike Brown and Tiago Alpha didn't
make you cut weight. You look skinny.
Took a private, went 10 rounds.
Dude, I don't, that's the sin.
That's cause I can't have any wasted
space when I'm doing striking with shack
with Chaco Elvis. What did he have you
do hit the pads you have. It's great.
Kick and head. Low kick. He was
teaching. She does. Yeah. It's great.
They came to my house. Has Dustin's
hip doing, is he all right? He looks,
he looks fantastic. He's
waiting for a fight, man. Yeah,
he was getting some stem
cells or something, wasn't it?
They need to come up with a good fight.
He's so great. He's such a great,
good dude.
Talk mother fucker.
So I was like super impressed with him
against Justin gauging it looks. Yeah.
Fuck he's, she's fantastic. Who's getting
paid? He's got a great fight coming up.
Who's Kate? You fighting? Katie's
fighting someone really good. Oh,
it's our post
ads.
I hope he wrestles.
Interesting. Saint Peter,
the bar blows is going to go.
You like leg kicks. Oh Man.
Check these out. You can't see
your wrestling thinks he can kick.
Fantastic. Let's play like Django and uh,
that's when we're showing
me like what those,
those low kicks there like the details,
the details of where you kick your leg up,
nerves.
Your nerves are so exposed with that.
Get Premus what he did to Michael
Chandler literally cut his fucking leg and
again with Dj and so Hutto first
fight or first? First round.
The second fight. Ugh. That's a terrible
kick. I've never been hit by one of those.
I don't know what it feels like. He
said worse than kicking the knee. Yeah.
You know the thing about kicking the knee,
it's hard to fuck your knee up.
Like you can hyper extend
the knee with a side kick.
You could fuck someone's knee up that
way, but oh, okay. Just got tagged or no,
he's all right.
How dare
you. Oh, oh.
Oh, your kid, dude. If he gets him here.
Oh, that was unbelievable. He's
got to put that leg hook in.
He's got to put it in and
flatten them out. Oh yes. Oh No,
no. He's on the chin. But Arizona Chin.
There you go. Oh, he's cranking that neck.
Oh, trying to get choked
up. Body triangle.
Cranky.
So he's now he's
guilty.
That's okay.
It's a beast that's over right there. It's
got a hook. The leg that's over right.
Maybe not. Maybe not. Maybe weights.
He's probably a check that's
checking to see if he's okay.
Gave him a thumbs up.
Oh
God.
This is the height.
Is that fighting Brian?
That's from a guy who trained to top team.
I can tell you that's a fight.
I mean I can top team in coconut
grove or wherever the fuck it is.
It's such a nice facility.
I wish Amanda Nunez walked in and beat
the shit out now. I was looking for her.
I did see junior desantos walking around
and saw junior and that was pretty cool.
I would love to see them as much
bigger than you. Bubba Jr. I was sick.
I took him in. I took him
in. Now he's training a lot,
but I took him in this way like with your
eyes or your mouth. Well, with my book,
I outlined in my online with my hands
and I was producing estrogen when
I saw him. But uh, he, he was,
uh, his, he looks, he looks more
menacing. Dang man. What am I,
he looked at me and he
goes, hey, tell shop.
I'm not hearing a fucking peep out of him.
No doubt.
I'll be in Miami March 16th to the
18th to standup. So come see it.
Whoa. Yeah. There you go.
What are you at Miami and pro?
Yeah, I can't damn bro. What the fuck?
Evernotes and your club.
It's supposed to be haunted.
It was so bad. It was so bad. I last, last
time I was there, I go, I go, I'm done.
I go, I'm never coming back.
And they were laughing. I go,
you people are too stupid. I go,
I can't come back here anymore.
They were laughing and he never came back.
Never go catch the joke.
Never does my answer. No, I
did Miami last year. I did a,
I did a theater when I was, I had a
great time. Just, I'm the only bullshit,
but they're, they're a little crazy.
I was doing right before my special,
I was doing those, a cell phone bag. So
they had to put the thing. That's right.
So to use your phone you
have to leave the theater.
So you would think they would just sit
down and watch your show everywhere else.
That's the case. Not in Miami and
Miami. They kept leaving the bar
and having a fucking parties in
like the greenhouse
gases. Yeah. Oh my God.
These going back and forth and back and
forth. Not too flat ass to be found.
Not a flat ass to be found in Miami.
And it's my maybe my favorite place in
many ways. That's where Tiffany had just,
she just had a really bad new year set.
She just didn't prepare, I guess. Right.
[inaudible] trunk.
She's also Doolan movies.
There's a sneaky thing that happens,
man,
when you're doing movies and
then you become a huge star.
So you're doing these
big theaters as well,
but you're not really doing enough
standard to do those big things.
You kind of fucking do mad reps to do
big places cause you not the same thing.
Are you watching? Yeah. Bang away
at his head. Brian by Marina. Oh,
big elbow by Lou k. You don't see a lot
of Mohawks these days. When I do see one,
you know he means business.
We're going to just turn and walk,
turning away and getting them back to the
center. So you're going to deep breath.
But when Lucas throwing
elbows like that from enclose,
maybe he's really good at ovals or maybe
heard is a Mohawk. No, none other one.
Okay. I can just sit there and kind of
take those shots off his gloves and he,
Ooh,
nice chance he's not ooh elbow,
but not afraid to just sit there.
Si.
Well, he's also probably really tired from
the choke and tasks and then the Darcy
attempt in the first round.
Nice.
He's not one of these guys are worried
about leg kicks. Are they? Oh, nice.
Front kick to the body.
Yeah.
I feel like front kicks. The body is one
of the most underused weapons, you know.
That was one of the things
I was so impressed with.
Barboza in the hang man fight in
the Dan Hook fight. Oh my God.
Fucking body kit. What's the
fucking, oh Paul, a fight.
Paul Felder said I was stage a cage side
when Paul Felder was taking those kicks
to the body from Barbosa. Oh my goodness.
And his skin was so red. And I said,
I was like, you seem like you didn't
even notice. He goes, dude, they hurt.
They hurt so fast tonight. Yeah, it
does change. That guy's a killer.
He's like one, one from fucking, I feel
like being that guy. He's a monster man.
Yeah, but gauging knocked him cold.
Remember the last fight? Yeah.
You didn't get to see how you recommend
we won like 10 before then. Oh yeah.
He's a piece, dude. He's a long,
tall dude too. That's right.
Gauging off the fuck of
knocked the fuck out of him.
I've never seen so many fucking
foul balls being thrown at.
You and Barbara arena have
the same chest. They are true.
You're so rude. What? Know that
it's not a bad thing. I know cars.
Barberino mashed my chest, a big chess,
getting Brian something nonstop. Brian.
Barbara is a professional fighter,
but doesn't mean he has a good chance.
Painters and granny that are body.
Then I'll take my shirt off
right now and put it up against,
I'll stand right next to him and you tell
me if I don't have a better Bob. Do it.
Bitch,
you got the same chest. Let me see.
Throw some punches. Oh, you look better.
You look very good. Brian's
shredded, but he looked very good.
Very good.
You're very slim around the forums
and the wrists doesn't look what,
you'd have a lot of pop two
shots. I'm relaxed. No. Yeah.
You know, flexing it all
choke you the one hand,
you're very jacked.
You know what's confusing to me is
the hand, the hand to risk ratio.
I don't see a lot of power coming
out of those hands. Take your forums.
So they're so small. They're so small.
They're like, you could pick locks,
you could pick locks with your wrists.
He does have a better body though.
You do have a better butter camera. Well,
no, not the set it up better than Luke.
I'm going to get on tier two and then
for gay Vicenta Lucchese his name.
Gentlemen, please bodies
better news. Oh, Luke,
better than yours by
Rina give you a rescue.
Was there playing rock 'em
sock 'em robots here, man.
They're just standing right
in front of each other.
You wouldn't you think that Luca would
want to take this fight to the ground?
I mean, you almost fucking choked him out.
Hey, did I get that he's tired. I mean, I,
I really do get that, but I mean, I want
to see it temps like whiskey, Eddie.
It sucks.
It's filled with series.
You know where it comes from?
Thirsty comes from abortion fetuses.
Oh, how that, wow. She's
brought it dish. Oh,
looky with a big left hook.
Oh Jesus. These guys are just,
I rarely see a fight where guys just
standing right in front of each other like
that
pushed him down.
Yep. Did they hate each other?
What's going on? Fighters,
Bro. Professional fighters.
Yeah. True. You don't see a lot
of guys just swing in these days.
Mm pressive Brian Count.
Did you,
did you watch MVP versus Paul daily
lives did not watch it. And I,
I only wonder how someone like MVP
will do if he ever goes to the UFC.
I want to see him fight guys like me.
I'm not assigned yet.
Tournament though that belt.
It's legitimacy. It is legit
as fuck. He's a killer.
He's not ready. He's not Michael
Venom page. You get no it.
And after watching daily take them down,
you got to think what Tyron would do to
him or would Uzman would do to him or
Colby Covington and he was
really the shit wrestler. But,
but the thing about Tyron, Tyron still
legit wrestle with nuclear weapons.
It's not just these going to punch you.
He's going to put your fucking job
all in through the back of your head.
And he's a phenomenal boxer, like
struck fucking Wonderboy rock driveway,
which is impossible to do one.
Wonderboy,
how about he sat down and tilt down with
one shot? Correct. One shot in the fight.
Dude. Imagine. Imagine Darren till Mvp.
Tyron is like these most Jack.
It's like the best body competition.
It's like first of all,
you got to give it all to the
Cuban heel over Merrill winds,
best body competition, parish rock
colds, right behind them please. Bigger,
taller. It's a different thing.
He still looks like models. Great.
He's got a beautiful body.
But when Yoel Romero were talking freak
with bikini briefs on you like you're
talking to take it. Yeah,
that's fair. What is that?
Oh,
hold my cucumber.
And then Brock Lesnar,
he goes, hold my d bar
and Allister
and there'd be,
nobody had a better body than over him
when he was ubering. Nobody can fail.
But he kept bringing up on it.
Pretty Boring.
No, no, no. [inaudible] was
ridiculous. But you're well, just as a,
as a perfect specimen,
that cute whenever
everyone was 265 pounds.
Shradda fortunate jazz.
When he's standing on the
scales and he's flexing,
I remember being behind him when he
was waning. Just blink and going,
what in the fuck am I looking at?
What is this?
Even Brock closers like what you see Ya,
I was so pumped for that fight cause
that was his UFC debut and his UFC debut
against Brock Lesnar. I was like,
I was so pumped for that fight.
And both of them went on that saucy sauce.
The sauce is like a fucking
grizzly bear as well.
Where's that wine for wine, Bro? Was
that one for you bro? What up, bro?
I'm drinking whiskey. I'm doing that
too. I thought it was Ireland over there.
I didn't free. We're free to do whatever
we want. We're, we're Americans.
We pay taxes. Can we get,
can we get some more whiskey?
Men Don't want no more or less. You're
good. Oh, right hand by Luke cage.
These fights are both all five
minutes. Five rounds today. Gentlemen,
what's, what's more fun? You
can hook them up with more.
You're a bad person. Bad Person. Cheers.
My favorite, my favorite, we were
talking about this before we got here.
My favorite, it's the best. It's the best.
I love doing podcasts. I love doing
podcasts with everybody, but man,
there's something special about these.
Look that upward elbow,
Anderson Silva style dude Anders
and we haven't talked to us.
Anderson looked good.
He looked very good.
He looked very good like stopping or
didn't be like an old whether they know or
something like that was a good go.
Yeah, I mean Anderson look a little,
I mean he looked a little overmatched
in terms of like technique cause style.
Bender is a legitimate world class
world championship caliber kickboxer but
Anderson was hanging in there with them
and answer and also try God look at
Ariadne behind like good lower.
That is reduced to Joe Behind on what?
In the fuck. That's so stupid.
That's a scares fighter of all time.
How do you score this fight?
How would you ever score this one?
I'm looking at who's going to win this
fight it. It's impossible. It's scoring.
Very good question.
It would suck to be a judge if
you saw us in a movie you back.
Nobody punches the one at a
topic about the ties to things.
I watched some glory fights
today while I was working out.
Two things that Gloria does better than
U of c. One five judges, not three.
Brilliant to open scoring. Love
it. What do you mean open scoring?
You know who's noting going on, you
know what's going on after every round,
the judges have to put up their scores,
so if you see a fucking domination and
then you see ten nine for the wrong guy,
the whole crowd and go, what the fuck? I
love pressure on, I love it. I love it.
Love it. Two, it's the commission
and by the way, you know the best place
to to do that kind of changes right here.
Andy foster is like one
of the most proactive, uh,
ahead of the curve intelligent
guys in all. And you know,
and Bob Bennett over in Nevada is
just as good. He's excellent to,
they can do this, but if, if
Nevada need to vote on it,
if Nevada does everybody who
was going to do it? Everybody.
So we just need to have that entirely
true because of the new rules.
The new rules are not decide. Yeah,
they're not adopted by everybody.
Adopted by Nevada.
Are they the unified rules in Nevada too?
Nevada, Nevada. And I
say I just say Las Vegas,
Las Vegas,
Nevada.
And I say Notradame do you
say to Martin too much on t.
Dot. No, I, I, I've done Chili.
Do you say it?
[inaudible] I say that and
I say quiet and Paraguay.
What it what about Afghanistan?
Afghanistan,
of course I always have enough clothes
pull what I say and I say, and I say,
Oh God damn it, this fight,
this fight. This is insane.
These guys are wrong. This is not
the way to file a long term career.
If you want that $50,000 bonus,
you want to play jeopardy when you're 40.
It's a bad move. How tough
are these dudes? Yo, you know
what I saw the other day?
I saw a wolf blitzer play jeopardy.
He Lo,
he ended up at the end
of it with minus 40.
Oh my God. Holy Shit. Cat.
Amazing fight.
Both of them look like not
there because the clock was off.
So in less than two seconds to stop,
they stopped.
They stopped. You can't, you can't stand
and bang like that. They stopped it.
That's not good. Sometimes you
can. Wow. Raleigh. They said, Woo.
She just looked at his quarter goes,
whew. Wow. Does he Brazilian too?
Did you see fucking, uh, how bad ass
or Brazilians just overall just stop.
Just stop and think about how many bad
motherfuckers came out of Brazil coming
out. Europe ain't coming out of Belize.
Belize coming out of Columbia. Hold on.
There's a few.
I'm sure there's a few,
but the majority are all
coming out of pursuit.
How about the hose in Brazil as well?
That's just the whole nation hose.
Or the girls need help with their rent.
Take it easy.
It's not, usually they'll
have that. It's, it's real.
It's real. Get it straight reos
real nice. Remember the difference?
Cause they're their church is the beach.
Look at it.
So everyone got to look good in Rio.
Mm.
Boom. There's the right hand. Boom.
There's another neat on the way down. Oh,
the mouthpiece went flying. That's it.
Stopped it. Get this good.
Oh my God. And this is,
they had been playing rock 'em sock.
'Em robots for three fucking rounds.
You can't fight him. That's crazy. That's
it. That's it. Stop it. It's like though.
And good for ESPN to the common
fans watching going. Yeah.
Suck each other in the face. She
hit him. Bruce. Head off Bro. Bro.
Do you could do that.
Do it for Georgia.
Nevada state athletic commission adopts
new unified rules. Oh, excellent.
When does this, what does this
labeled? Uh, November 13th 20.
So 2018 okay. So they finally adopted
it. So they're going to do in this optic.
It's do the grounded fighter
rule. Oh, interesting too.
They took the new rules,
but they don't accept
the one point down rule
glory does
that grounded final rule.
It's a Gig. It's too gray. It's
too much of a gray area. Dude.
How about that says fucking
Paul Daley protests.
MVP loss says bell are rigged it
to protect their investment. Ah,
Paul daily. You're a monster. When
he's, when he's on, he's a monster.
There's no man on the planet who,
I mean,
think about what he did to Lorens Larkin,
right?
Lorens Larkin is a really tactical
striker and Paul daily time he lands that
fucking left hand on you. You, you forget
your child. Childhood has been fighting.
He,
he's been disappointed.
He says MMA politics and
Beltour protecting their
investment. I fell in one,
three rounds to, to my opinion, I beat
that full, really close fight. I can't,
I can't see how he thinks
he went three rounds.
So like if they give to daily Mikaila,
fine. We all lost the fans loss.
But if you how he says three, I'm like,
all right, that's fine. I don't know.
It was a bullshit fight all the way
around. It was, it wasn't the best fight.
It wasn't a lot going on. Well, I've
nothing, nothing wasn't the best.
Cautious is watching two
blue belts grapple daily,
kept trying to gala daily,
took him down,
then he lost position once an MVP
got on top of him and beat his ass,
got his back. I thought he was
gonna choke him out. Me Too.
That they had a naked different,
yeah.
I was amazed that Paul Daley was able
to take them down though and we really
made some big improvements
in his wrestling. I mean,
I guess maybe felt like after the John
Fitch fight, if you can't beat them,
join them. What a great did. This
is a great fight, man. Yeah. Wow.
Six seconds left. What? Wait,
was it 70? Uh, yeah, that's 70
sorry. The House 10 at American top
team. Yeah. And when's his hand?
He just finished working out. And when you
see them, like when they're off season,
they're just, they just, you're like, how
are you bringing to the table? It's ugly.
Stay by my God. I was like,
you fund at one 55 he looks,
he's so thick. And I didn't even recognize
him. He should go. I go, I think.
And he goes, yeah, it's dealer.
I was like, why not? Yeah, he,
well he looked huge when
he's weighing one 55 yeah.
He would get on the scale and I was like,
what does that, what do you hollow? Oh,
that's cool. So one of those
chocolate chocolate Easter bunny.
That light. I asked for it. I hate the
fucking hollow ones. I like a solid,
the hollow ones. The ones fucked my
teeth up or asked first years, bro.
I go ass. Really? The big girl.
Yeah. I know your skin looks up.
What's going on, Bro? You look good.
You look tight. Oh really?
Shiny. And it looks very well.
I've been worked out over a
week. No, maybe that's it.
That is just stop working.
Healthy body's recovering.
Maybe I was moving. I haven't
been able to work it out.
It's good pizza every day. Maybe that's,
well good. You have a rosy complexion. Oh,
I'll take it, man. Look very healthy.
I'm just saying with the
cold weather you look 23
maybe it's the booze and the rest. I have
been drinking and sit in a hot tub. Eat,
eat dough and cheese and tomatoes.
Body likes cheese. Anyway,
nice to interview both of them.
John Anna Cause Interviewing Barbara
but it must be from the truck.
They must be from the truck out of
respect. Who has it? They give you?
Sometimes I'm walking to the cage and
they give me the thing in my ear winner
and loser hundred school. Yeah.
Every now and then man. Yeah.
Did David approach you to work for ESPN
or not? We just got, I was like no,
we know where he's not,
not interested know but like I would
take this for zero money over being in
Phoenix right now,
although I would want to see those fights
live and I'd love to call those fights
slide. I'm good with 10 a year.
That's what I like. I like 10 a year.
But did they use a lot o chew and they
didn't even want to, nope. 10 10 a year,
10 years. What? I like once a month. 10
shows, 10 a year. What's a month dude?
Once a month. What? Just the paper? Two
months. Two months off. Once a month.
Listen man,
I was thinking that I was on my way out.
I was really thinking I was on my way out,
but I still love it and I love it way
more now because I don't have to do it as
much and I love it way more now because
we do this because we can do all this
shit talking and have fun and be silly.
It's so fun.
What am I doing this for? Some of the
big boxing like to Mikey Garcia. Yes.
That's good Mike.
You got to see if it's Earl Spencer.
Dude, he's got light brown hair. No, get
good. Well, it's a little bit of gray,
handsome son of a bitch. Damn. He looks
good. He pulls off. It's go stash like no,
I want to talk to him on the podcast.
I want to reach out to him and get him
on because he had some amazing stories
about wrestling back when he
was wrestling and you know,
he would go international
wrestling. No, no, no.
We're starting to get more current.
I would love to get marker on.
I would love to get him on.
How's he doing now? I don't know.
Here's the in Phoenix because he selling,
he was selling cars.
Last time I heard a Z. I've heard
some classic stories about them too.
It's not Jeff Manson at uh, I didn't
say the Russian. Yeah, he's at,
I think he's a Russian citizen,
but I saw him Russian citizen.
He seems Russian songs.
There's a video of him driving around in
a Russian car singing a Russian. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Here's the, I love this
guy. He might be on the, on the list.
We then Betty,
you remember when he took off all his
clothes and left Abu Dhabi in 2003?
Remember Eddie beat Heuler
we were down in, uh,
in South Paulo and a Monson got robbed.
So Munson to fucking to protest,
took off all his fucking clothes
and threw a shorts and tennis shoes,
like a shade polar
bridge. He was so, so big.
North south choke, the months choke, you
know, I asked Eddie at the time, I'm like,
is that in a legit choke? And he's
like, I think he kinda gooned them.
And it was before Marcello
started tapping guys with that.
You remember that shit?
We used to think that the north
south truck was a goon was just,
he just grabbed his hand and
squeeze the shit out of it.
Like Martin mark curb or Mark
Coleman style you have wants,
it looks like he's in shape. He
couldn't look thicker. She's a bit,
you need to pass a test to oh yeah,
he'll pass the test. He test positive.
That's the test.
Like I will for wheat
Novitsky but if they tried
saying like, nope, no, no,
no, no. We just, no, no. Yeah,
he definitely looks like he's, yeah, he's,
yeah, he's, he's probably 45 and he's,
he's in very, I saw 82 weekend I
was at it. He's older than that.
I think we're almost 50 yeah, probably
because he just, he fought chocolate.
Dell's a light heavyweight
way back in the day.
He remembers old school man who
is in the UFC at all the statutes.
You're seeing a picture of him when the
protesters and he's fucking like this
and that and he's got that fucking the
capitalism tattoo on the back of the and
the head gun to the head says capitalism.
It's a guy with a holding
a gun to your head.
Like he's crazy Marxist like free day.
I like full on communists,
no
about it. He's a libertarian picture.
We'll get those guys, see that
picture on the left side plus this.
We don't get paid enough and they got to
know who he is to the guy with the mask
and if you don't, you're like, what the
fuck the guy with the mask. How is that?
Can really bite my nose off.
Get Kellen because your first
step to get it for 10 points.
Do you know where that's from though?
You know what, that, what that signifies.
Have you,
where do you know a picture that Trump,
you could have all the points that's from,
that's from I believe,
and that's from Vietnam where the guy is
shooting another guy to famous picture.
It's a real picture. Yes. I've, oh shit.
The guy shooting, I believe. A Viet Cong.
That's dark dude. Yeah. Well this has
allied with America's crone. Next.
Okay. This one we got to watch. We've
got to actually watch this. Damn,
this is a great vice documentary.
The munchies documentary on crone.
What crone eats and his training
routine. It's amazing. You know, he's,
he's a pescatarian. He doesn't eat
any meat. He's a flat earthers oof.
I don't know. On elite both
physics and you know, all
those other things. But yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Love is fighting, not his
world, right? Yeah. Well,
someone needs to take them up on
fucking hot air balloon. Well,
that's what I'm saying.
Anybody who tries to get away
with a crime. For example,
like this Guy Jesse Smollett or whatever,
uh,
how this is when I had our
notes or I'll fucking call it,
people call me and Jamie, we shut
the, the cameras are we like,
is everything done alright buying
this Shit Jamie? Jamie's like,
I ain't [inaudible] shit. I'm
like, I'm never going to say it.
Clad people texted me. This
is bullshit because, you know,
it just sounded Kellen I went hard like,
yeah.
Some people were saying
online that it was like,
like what happens when you let
actors write a script? Right, right.
Bridget even worse, getting an actor
to try to get away with a crime.
There are cops,
Chicago cops because they haven't seen
everything cause they don't cause those
guys don't study crime and you're new to
the game and you come and you're going
to pull the wool over the Chicago police,
all those detectors. It's like me.
I started fighting a little,
I saw some stuff on youtube.
I'm going to go and fight. How about,
how about, how about they Brian,
his boys and they squealed real fast.
Quick.
Hoggle cops fuck's going on in and give
us your phone and let those guys loose.
They're like, they're like,
we're good here. The guys, he uh,
he hired her jacket.
Look flushing that sculpted the
right trainer. Hector Lombard,
all it looked like fucking Francis looked
like two friends that might meet your
neighbors yard. What'd you
well, who's on top? God,
I think the brothers just like a spit.
Just like a Chinese finger
head tucked it in plain sight.
Have you guys seen that on Netflix? So
he's obsessing that I haven't seen it yet.
Don't tell me anything about it.
Fucking see abducted. I will in place.
Have you seen a Joe? It's fucking
incredible. You have to see.
I should about spoiler alert
and this should sell you on it.
The Dad sucks off the dude who's
molesting his daughter and having cetera.
Second Mafia. There's the
seventies. So why did he do that?
Well check cause he had pressure.
It's a long story. Long Story.
But this guy,
this girl drugs her and she
wakes up strapped to a bet.
You don't know where she has. She's 12
and night for cheese. Holy Fuck Dude.
Jack Knife.
Cheesing chrome,
Gracie talking more custom knives.
Tough line of Hudson.
I find them on Instagram without
giving given to me by wow.
Below Donny Vincent gave it to me.
That's a work of a hunter.
True Work of Oh yeah. Yeah.
For Real. That's an inmate
tuck. A mark. Gotta calm down.
They've got a great Instagram page.
Handmade knives.
Why is this knife in my hand feel so at
home? Cause you're a natural knife man.
You know what I am. I'm a
nice man. Check this out.
This 12 year old girl drugs her,
she wakes up,
she's strapped up and she's got the
speaker next to her and don't tell him,
tell him this guy, this guy
here this, she doesn't die.
Okay Dude, it's so interesting
dude. You're gonna,
you're gonna f if you watch this,
the worst I've
ever seen him. She, she
gets abducted and this guy,
this guy makes her think that
she got abducted by aliens. So,
and then the aliens tell her he's got
this on a tape recorder and she's tied up.
She just asked Mr B.
He has names.
Mr The guy who abducted her and the aliens
tell her that she must marry this man
to save the world. And if anybody finds
out, yeah, well yeah, you have to have,
she must have,
she must get pregnant by this guy,
that guy that abducted
her and a sociopath. Yes.
She believes it and falls in love with
the guy and she's in love with them for
like four years cause she thinks
she has to save the world.
He got her to think she
got abducted by aliens.
What do you think is happening when
people say they get abducted by aliens?
I can't get, I think
it's, it's uh, um, some,
um, people, uh,
high level people doing
experiments and getting them there.
They're abducted them.
They're not being abducted by aliens.
They're being abducted by people who
make them think they're getting more and
more interested in more.
Obviously they were just dreaming
because nothing happens to the physical.
You know the thing about the alien
abductions and no, there's no evidence of,
you look at lay people that
have been alien abducted,
like there's no evidence they
actually leave their house.
There's no like there's no hope,
no alarms go off and see what happens
is we believe that really have a hold on
when people sleep,
your brain produces all these
chemicals that make you dream, right?
So all of these alien abductions, almost
all of them, this is a great cheese,
three Kelvin, those cheeses, alien,
these alien abductions all take
place while people are sleeping.
It's real simple.
They're laying in bed at night.
They have this unbelievable
realistic dream.
They also have what's
called sleep paralysis.
Sleep paralysis is something that
afflicts people where their semi awake and
they can't move their
body because your body,
your body's just like in a half state of
dreaming and awake. We called Rem sleep.
So during this time your brain is
producing dimethyltryptamine. You're,
you're producing DMT.
So you're tripping your balls off and
you're having these weird fucking visions
and you think your board space ships
and shit. That's a possibility.
But after watching this documentary,
another possibility is that there, there,
I'm drugging people and making
them think they use day getting.
It could be anybody, bro. It could
be anybody. There is no, they did.
Everybody's cool. Bruce
Buffer, grown gray, monochrome.
I'm more excited about this fight
that I am the main. This is a coma.
No,
tell her
debut is like almost a Coleman and
this is probably the coal man. No,
this isn't a Khomeini.
Felder floater.
Vick looks finish and just ready.
He's a beautiful looking human,
handsome, beautiful. Ever
seen his dad and his mom does.
Mom was a as well. She
was, yeah. Wow. Gracie,
level of girl that he would marry.
Think about that. Think about that.
Who's doing Eddie? Are you chewing
on the microphone? Don't do that.
Don't do that.
People get crazy.
Good thing I don't read social media
and this kid is, this kid kills it.
This guy's to be, this is a bad
motherfucker. He's a Vegan and Crohn's.
A pescatarian. So this is one for the
people that don't read. I'll take pets.
Please move it over to the fish.
A pescatarian thing I read me hurts me.
Do pescatarians eat octopus guys,
I'm open to any fish eating a dolphin.
It is, dude. I, they're too smart.
They can feel are smarter than Dolphin.
So he didn't alien. I don't
need it anymore because I,
after I thought, here we go.
Here we go. Come on. We'll pull guard.
Pull. Yeah, he'll get his clothes go out.
Chrome Gracie's closed gardens in insane
so he will pull Gumbs submitted me from
close guy. Yeah. He submitted to
believe that he submitted Jimmy.
He submitted JT tours. He's one of
the best guys out there in Abu Dhabi.
2013 in China from close.
What? I'm surprised he's not,
he's not taking his dad's approach,
which is that front leg side kick.
He does that. No, no he, oh shit. He hit
him in the left hand. He heard him Crozer
oh shit. He's throwing some Kung
Fu cause Sarah saw some wild shit.
He's got so much more experience.
It's so crazy
fucking hammers.
I wouldn't mind if he just shot for Gotcha
clincher dude. Fuck yeah. He's
going to have to pull guard here.
He's not going to be an easy take down.
He's got a sense of grace.
You four minutes to work.
I need that last time.
He's going to take your bag show Benevidez
took a guy down three or four times
in his last fight with legit
move. Different animal though.
He's a different animal on your back.
This is a real world class
of mission strangled.
Oh No.
God is all over the ice cream.
There's no way he's going to survive. He's
fuck you just know. You just hold that,
hold that on.
Shut your
eyes. Get full structure and he's
got three and a half minutes.
Shack and if viewers
corner, man, what'd you,
you're fine.
Oh Shit. It's over. Right, right.
Listen, I bet everybody
could call. It's over now.
Now it's 100% job set now it's completely
fuck Alex.
Is Sarah so hot
his head like what the fuck dude?
He,
Alex just shook his head like
what the fuck that is the
kind of sister Khabib phenomenon. Admit
as he touches you, you're, you're done.
No touching on. That's a different
thing. He chose people out like no, no,
it's a different thing.
I mean not like that.
He just gets you in punches this
25 minutes. This is a certain flow,
Lemmy sound when people chew
cheese on microphone. That's
really disgusting. Dude.
That's so crazy. How good he is. Look at
this shit. He's so good. Look at this.
He'll pull guard. Just basically
pulled guard right here to the ground.
He's world class, man. It's a
different answer. She wouldn't do that.
You wouldn't take a guy down.
Like if it was a wrestling match,
it's this slow squeeze header.
Gracie's doing a breakdown of
it right now guys, check it out.
This is how it would happen.
Right now.
We're gonna go with the
breakdown breakdown that's so on,
but he's been graced with
amazing where they read,
they could choke the shit out guys.
It's a huge win.
That's a fucking big deal,
man. Sarah's is a good fighter,
but he just know crazy Jujitsu.
Let's, let's go a step by step.
You break that shit man. Fuck
is a spot. Um, shakes in there.
I'm sure you know he's,
he's maybe not even watching.
He's like surfing in Rio or some shit.
You might not even know he was there
and the most beautiful
Brazilian. We know. Dude.
There's no way I want to meet him.
I want us to talk to him,
but there's no way that they wouldn't
show Hickson that you never met.
Hixon we can set it up. My friend,
I love him. I want to meet him.
He had the most interesting description
of how he finishes people. He goes,
we started a neutral point. He goes,
and then we'd go to one and he goes,
when I moved to one, I'm not
going back to zero. He goes,
I'm moving to two and then to
go back on then checkmate. Yeah,
and just going back,
he's also,
he's the fucking confidence
that confidence is a blue
cheese. What does it, some,
some sort of a, he brought a
blue cheese when you're ready.
Now are we all going to shut our ready
already got this beautiful cream,
creamy French.
But then the crisis though,
that's going to be too
much on the podcast.
Don't even eat onions or your best case.
That like a weird thing. I don't need it.
I don't need that onions either.
You and I have a lot in common.
I love him though, right? Oh yeah. Okay.
Yeah. I mean, I'm not on
John's knows doggy style. The
right just missionary. No,
I sure do.
I'm an American man.
Why wouldn't you eat ass
dog style American prefer
we preached her legs up under the cheeks
down like Gene Simmons. You touched
the bud a little bit and then that's,
that's weak side. You go doggy style
eating ass. Let them know you love him.
Know what's up.
Okay.
For New Year's Eve, look at,
look at, look at Crohn's hair.
Handsome bastards like his hair.
He just lets it go.
School to Culver City in the house. Got
Out of grade school, got out of his, uh,
out of the shower and just shook it.
Shook it out.
You know it's in Culver city. I just want
to let you know that the earth is flat.
Oh No, please don't do that
girl. Oh Dude. He's way down.
He calls me up out of the blue.
He got it by now.
You still feel that flat earth there.
You didn't want you to go for it.
You need to go back, go back, go back
to standard glass pills for Santa Claus.
And then finding doesn't say we're
off of it. Then you go back to Santa,
cause I'm not even trying,
I'm not going to try and make a joke.
I thought you were off. If some reason
nobody goes off it. What's your flag?
And he's off spaces.
Santa Claus for adult now Eddie's off it.
But he has a following now of flat
earthers so he casts not shows.
That's not true. He called his
bluff. You call his bluff on flat.
You can't say it out loud.
Give me that. I can't eat.
You can't eat crackers on here.
Never go to draw the line there.
This is a softer cheese and I'm,
I'm getting this beautiful knife.
A little bit tarnished. We
are going to have to clean
it. Kron Gracie, a shout out.
You know, I was uh, I was uh,
a little concern with chrome's fighting
career cause when he was on my podcast
when we were discussing flat earth,
he said that he doesn't know if,
if fighting is for him. There's a
lot of pressure, the family pressure.
And he was basically saying that he
likes living without any pressure and he
doesn't know if he wants to keep fighting.
But now you know when you listen to the
countdown show and the all that embedded
stuff, he said no. He said, you know what?
I realized that just teaching is like
every day is like groundhog day and I'm
not at my best when I'm just teaching.
I'm not my best when I'm
training for something.
So I always have to be trained for
something. So I didn't realize,
I realized I need to be fighting.
So when I heard her say that,
know he's evolving and
figuring himself out. So this,
this might be the beginning
of some championship shit
here for the UFC. Listen,
if he gets his striking together and he
did tag because Sarah's with a couple of
punches. Everybody who goes to the
ground with this kid, it's, fuck,
what weight class was this one?
40 45 yeah, but guess what?
Good luck would Max Holloway Holla
at your boy? Yeah. Ooh, look,
I would love to see, this
is to my, why do we do this?
Why are you going to say fucking
Brian Ortega versus chrome?
This was 45 40 45 oh shit.
You know when he was,
when he lost, when he
was 12 years old. Um,
he wasn't that into Jujitsu is a little,
he was, he wasn't, he was skateboarding.
He was skateboarding and I, John, jock.
We were outside of the
tournament and John Jock,
we were walking and Kron Gracie at 12
came bias and skateboarding started doing
some tricks and John,
I'll never forget the John Dracos.
That's the one right there. That's the
one that's going to take over. Wow.
I really,
John's rock knew it cause he's really
tight with Hickson and a common sense.
How long is a crime been striking? Do we
know? Well, you know, I mean he's years,
five years, six years. He's been doing MMA
fights. He fought and rising, you know,
he fought a few fights.
The thing is like his striking his,
like his father striking,
it's just to understand it.
It's not really to do it in terms of like,
he's never going be close distance or
get better to jail. He's never
going to stand in back. Yeah,
to close distance and then grab you.
And once you went to a year in big truck
even could be these district more than
crone. Crone is just going to get
in and clinch up and like you said,
go from step one, step two, step three,
not go backwards. He's dangerous.
Can you just, it's gonna be
tough to beat. It's fuck yes.
I wouldn't have been disappointed or
shocked if Alex Caceres escaped a couple
times on the ground and
maybe stood up again.
Maybe crone got them in the third round.
I wouldn't have been that
surprised because Alex Concentra's,
he's been fighting for so long. He
squirly on the code. That's not an easy,
and you only have four or
five gate and some good guys,
you may remember when
he beat Sergio Pettis,
they look at that when Anthony
Smith knocked out shogun. Meanwhile,
how good did it fuck it.
Shogun look in his last fight,
Shogun has made some sort of a crazy
resurgence, man. Seriously? Yeah, man.
His last fight.
He was so savage who was so savage and
so did he pull up who shogun fight?
Fuck someone. Good man. I thought he got
Merk. No, no, no, no, no. His last fight,
he won by stoppage and he
looked like a fucking animal.
He looked like the Shogun of old.
Those old guys who keep doing it. Like,
what's that? I said Pedro Tyson.
Pedro. Oh, that's right. Or the mother.
He's a motherfucker. Trey.
He beat me in Australia.
Is this Guy gonna Fight Jon Jones.
That's what we're talking about.
This would be a highlight. Who would
this gentleman be? I don't know. Smith.
He's a beast man. He ends up being knocked
out. Shogun. He's a beast. He knock out.
Shogun owes de Mer. Rashad, he's
a beast. He, he's, he's a very,
very good fighter and I think he's the
type of guy that's going to rise to the
occasion. I mean, I like, I like,
I don't really heads that. Yeah,
I don't know if he's, oh, how
tall are you? How tall is he?
I worked for the organization.
She looks scary.
I don't know if he's a capable of beating
John Because I legitimately feel like
John is not just the best
light heavyweight of all time.
I think he's absolutely in
the conversation for the
best fighter of all time.
I agree. There's three or four
guys that are in that conversation.
Mighty mouse,
who I think is the best representative of
martial arts I've ever seen. Candidate.
There's no, no, I mean Keynes, the
best heavyweight have ever seen,
but the best fighters I've ever seen,
I think fate or is in the conversation,
and I think Anderson Silva,
when he was in his prime,
when he was in his prime but prime, he
was a savage man. He was an assassin.
Look at this. Cain Velasquez
showing up purple. Look at,
look at the suite, not purple jacket. Woe.
Lo can look Rockhold and Daniel Cormier,
he said when he was healthy,
he was the baddest man on the planet.
Well, DC said to me, man, he goes,
I can't beat that guy. Yeah. He goes,
what? Everyone tells me to change.
I can't beat him. He goes, I
thought about that when I was,
when I was training with him. He goes, I
can't beat him. Look at his corner, man.
He's got his headphones on too. It's
like, fuck it. Whatever he's listening to,
I'm going to something that's, Carmen
came. Slagged does a fantastic,
he's a fantastic looking past summit.
Here's the specimen of all specimen.
He's great. He really
is, man. All this junk.
We've got a Gal find Cortney
Casey all up in this bitch.
She's a very good soccer player. NCAA
soccer player. Oh real while ago.
Soccer translates by the way, what
they say, and Cynthia called Vo.
She's a motherfucker, a little team,
Alpha male beast. She likes to fight to,
that girl looks at scrap. This is good.
She doesn't choose a Diaz mentality.
Yeah,
let's give these people some credit.
Let's watch this fight and give me
some more wine because I'm drunk.
I don't meet up. Get a little
thing to do after this.
You want to get some steaks?
I can't wait till vision.
My boyfriend Andy Stumpf is staying with
me, so he's here tomorrow on my podcast.
He's doing your podcast.
He's a great guy.
I love having really good conversations
with that guy. He's really good.
He stayed with you boyfriend and why
don't you come with me in the pod customer
you shows done right. I could do
that, but I have a Comcast tomorrow.
What is your podcast?
You son of a bitch was your pot.
We haven't podcasting a long time.
Pug podcasts often you guys do podcasts,
flattering the kid.
Brendan Schaub and Brian can do a podcast
every Monday and Wednesday without
fail. Damn. Every Monday,
Wednesday. How long are the podcast?
They are as long as we choose three hours,
two hour nap,
usually two hour and a
half to two max interest.
Never longer than two interests that
they can remember that so many to too.
Usually hour and a half being grew by
33% this year. That I said it out loud.
I don't care. All right. You and Krista,
Leah doing some standup together.
You podcasts through by 33% this year.
Wow.
That's what Brandon are mostly Brendan.
It was all brand.
He rubbed a business and let's be
honest, I show up now. Here's the thing.
I tried to get involved with. Watch
this. I got like this. I go, ah,
you need any help with the business?
He goes, not really your thing. Is it
a, it's why I don't have
to do local press and why.
I basically sold out the West Palm
Beach Improv, which I've never done,
which is the adulation for me. Yeah,
that's huge. And that about 30 years ago.
I know. I know. I'm missing,
I'm way behind. You're the
canary in the coal mine.
Thanks for [inaudible] on all that
bunch of those.
That was a great club called beach.
Well, Paul Beach, if you have five
shows, you got to sell about 45
hi,
5,500 tickets,
about 25 it takes to sell out what?
Just what?
2,500 tickets to sell up on show so that
we're doing a show in Spokane at four
20 in the afternoon.
STANDUP
comedy clubs? No, not if it's four
20 they'll stoners will show up, man.
[inaudible] afternoon.
No, you're good. No,
not on April 20th at four 20 perfect.
March. No one it is. We'll
announce it right now.
You'll sell that motherfucker
out when the sun is still out.
It's a little bit tough for
common for stoners. That's true.
What are you talking about? Bert?
Kreischer does a morning thing though.
I always did those.
Fucking Doug Benson,
he always did before 20 in
the afternoon on Sunday spoken is
actually a fun place. I was just there.
Spokane is great.
I've never been in.
I and I drove down to Coraline
Coraline and beautiful. Amazing.
I'm doing Spokane somewhere. I left.
Lane is like God's calling Jude.
I want to move. You're going to buy
a place. Where's the Mexican? Yeah.
Quarter Lane. Next to Kanye. Yeah.
Wait, this is in Washington. Uh,
that would be Idaho. Idaho
is a beautiful dude. Amazing.
Amazing. I want to move there. It's
gorgeous. Let's get a pie in a heartbeat.
What do we to do? We'd have
to get all the homes, bro.
Listen, I had a friend of mine who went
there and took a picture of the lake.
This lake, a hundred foot deep. You
could see the bottom of the wall.
That's amazing. Great
restaurants. Still clear.
You could see the bottom of the
water. Yeah, they beat you would love,
it's like a great restaurant shopping I
never heard of because they want to keep
it [inaudible] bro Bro. Yeah. I
already started looking at property.
There is one issue. It's like a, a
stomping ground for white supremacists.
Like were quarterly and Idaho.
Yeah, that's what I heard.
Don't let that scare you.
So, so Friday, Friday,
March 8th Friday,
March 8th tin foil hat me
and Sam triply or in Tacoma,
but that for 20 shows in Spokane
on a Saturday. [inaudible] club.
March 9th the Spokane Comedy Club. We need
to have that. Yeah, I love that place.
Great Room. Okay, cool. To terrible.
I was like, almost like fuck that.
Four 20 in the afternoon. I shouldn't
have said that, but uh, yeah,
we're going to try that shit. I'm at a
table open or more than once in my life.
I'll be at the, nobody starts Thursday.
I'll be at the vogue theater in Vancouver.
Oh, this Wednesday I'll be
the ice house in Pasadena.
That's the only show that we just,
we haven't even announced it yet.
He'd go to the Ice House website because
a Monday night at the comedy store sold
out Tuesday night at the Improv is hold
up. You got a spot on that ice house? Yes.
100% 100% what's going to attempt 100%
you're in the one on one Wednesday night,
10:00 PM
10 like a fight companion show fucking
ice house and it's Wednesday and that
Wednesday night. Okay, I can do that.
I don't think I'm flying to Vancouver.
Don't be scared.
I know when you're lying bro.
We actually did do a
fight this fall planned.
It just happened on one of the Sam show.
You want a sandwich?
I'm my fucking do it.
A bright flash like a motherfucker.
You know what?
I don't believe in anything you believe
in, but like I like to keep it on down.
We live on a ball and all that shit.
You really don't believe
you're not serious and
he's kind of a meant to be meant to
compliment. I get drunk. I get confused.
I just, I just want to
cause any, I mean any of it.
Some serious conversation and there's
some stuff I do agree with Eddie on just
certain stuff but can talk. I can talk
about the soap. I don't wanna die.
So with certain ones with like the flat
earth is right there in the middle. Man,
I'm a middle anymore than anybody thinks.
Oh, Brandon's right fucking there.
But what my point was, we don't,
when it comes to our beliefs,
we're on opposite ends
of the fucking spectrum.
But you guys said that he fucks with you.
But that doesn't mean that I'm not
going to compliment you when I,
when I see you live, dude,
you fucking smash dude.
Fucking crush as serious.
Believe we live on a ball and all that
shit. But I didn't wait until every,
I think politically we're pretty far off.
I am.
I think you're a socialist.
Socialist.
They got them wrong.
I thought you are. You out of your
fucking give that vibe off. Fuck
both of you. Stop. Stop. No one
talks. He's fucking with both.
Okay.
Spill
table up bro. Listen to me right now.
Look at me right now. I'm an American.
I don't. I believe in, in
in the constitution. Yes.
You believe in gun rights.
Okay.
I'm, I'm a very, I'm not, I don't
believe now that he's free speech.
Yeah, Bro. A coffee. El
Cortez. You like her?
I don't like her. I love you. But
was 28 which has not about the,
I know I was really into her until she
had this clause. No, listen, listen.
This is what I meant.
Young people that are interested in
helping people and changing the world.
I don't agree with a lot of her ideology,
but she had this one clause that was
people who were unwilling to work.
She wanted to give money to
people who are unwilling to,
we want this knife. I mean, how about,
how about like passing legislation
anymore? Late term abortions.
The fuck is going on in New York.
There's a reading late late
term abortions. I celebrate.
We'll have a party. It's dude, it's, yeah,
they're partying. They're doing coke.
They're doing all that shit for late
term abortions. And how bout this?
Walls don't work. What the
fuck is going on? I let Eddie,
you like the wall. Eddie try going to
Canada. You can't even get into Canada.
If you had a fucking Dui,
hold up. Stop, stop, stop.
Do you know there's no wall?
There's no wall.
There's no wall between us and Canada.
You could walk right through the woods.
People do it all the time with your mom.
Not know that cause they know literally
hundreds of miles opens woods.
We just walk right through. Well,
the problem that we have, uh,
with against say well don't give,
don't head.
He's Mexican so he's good and he just,
because I'm a capitalist and free market
guy and because his father secretary,
I'm a Trump guy.
I didn't say what I don't want to train.
We're all going to be fine. Cynthia got
vo. Everyone's on the same team. Yeah.
When it comes to the
ground, what? America.
Now that he's got to hear you
more than that. You look here,
you're a fucking what? Cheese.
You're a problem. Bring the Trump.
You're a Goddamn prankster.
Yeah. We got two more bottles
by the way Brian Callen you're fucking
wine choices. Excellent. Actually.
Cheese man. Cheese selection, mom.
And I know, I know. What's up.
The youtube comments will be
filled with hate for the smacking.
Sometimes she got to say fuck them.
You know all comments.
How about all the time I never read it.
How about stop correcting boys?
If you want to make it have a better life,
stop commenting on any youtube.
I don't know anyone who stopped who
goes on Youtube and you think Michael
Jordan's up on youtube comment thing.
No these guys that,
that you know when you can comment and
video and the whole world's going to see
it, it gives them power. Well you
know what it also is, it's like, um,
it's like a message board
that doesn't get censored.
It's a very rare form of message cause
the only one that doesn't get censored,
right? Cause like Instagram, Twitter,
you do shit what people
think it gets censored.
But what happens is people like say
you're spamming and they mark your shit of
spam. And if enough people do it, it
gets voted down. And it's hard to see.
But you can find it ultimately.
But the point is basically everyone can
post what chewing into Mike who's doing
it. That was Maddie. Jesus. My,
my thing about a negative comments
is that I've had red salmon.
I'm of the thing is I'm like, well, I
kind of agree with you. Uh, you know,
I'm not my own biggest fan,
so fuck off.
You're not going to say anything that
I don't, you know, kind of like, yeah,
I'm not a big fan of myself either.
Right. I was going to say like, whoa. No.
What are you saying about,
I'm amazed.
I'm amazed I've gotten as far as I've
gotten with how little I feel about my
work.
I think you become,
I think I've known you for 25 years and
I believe you become not only incredibly
thoughtful and you probably have made
the biggest transformation of any friend
I've ever had, and you've become somebody
who listens and podcasts so well.
I listen to a podcast all the time.
Thank you know,
I made a mistake of listening to one of
my early ones here the day I was like,
oh my God. Listen to one from like
eight years ago hits and says,
don't go back listening to you now.
Listen to how you like, listen,
and don't take a position and just are
so open about everything that that POC
debate. Um, it was just unbelievable. Man.
You know what the pot to
Beit was important to me
because I legitimately think
that there are people
who should not smoke pot.
And this is coming from someone
who smokes a lot of pot.
You're a reasonable human being. I
see it and I'm not a zealot. I see it.
I see it in people. I see. There's
people that shouldn't fucking do it.
And there's people that it
does make them lazy there.
Everybody's brain reacts differently
to caffeine, to nicotine, right.
To fucking all the drugs.
Yeah.
And there's some people
that I legitimately feel
like have a really hard time
with THC weather, especially in
edible form. I think edible form is,
I think it's legitimately one of the most
potent psychedelic drugs that's freely
available. I called the poison control
center after I had a Brownie. Okay.
She's that fucked up. But
with the seat. I called him,
I called the red band, called the
cops on himself. Garden rang up.
I woke him up cause already is a seasoned
drug addict and back then I had eaten
a Brownie and I didn't know what was
going on with me and I said, dude, I,
I think I'm dying. And he goes,
you're not tying contract.
I can't feel myself breathing.
I can't hear my heart.
How old were you at 23030301030
I would understand that.
Wouldn't like make a sign
and free choice illegal.
Like I don't think guns should
be illegal and legal is the CBD.
My education,
I believe in education and I think it's
one of the things that I'm trying to do
and it's one of the things I was trying
to do with that pot debate podcasts is
let people know,
hey,
I've taken some pretty zealot like pull
positions in the past where I was like
everybody should smoke pot. Don't listen
to me from three years ago. Right.
Listen to me from right now
everybody should not smoke pot.
And if you're thinking about smoking pot,
smoke a little tiny bit,
but that's what this looks like.
Alcohol don't finish a whole one shot.
Don't be one. I've always said cause I'm
influenced a lot of people to smoke pot,
but the one thing including me,
we said for the for the
last 20 years is I've,
I've always said this,
that I don't think you should
start smoking weed until
you're at least 28 it's a
good, that's a good, that's
great. That's great advice. Oh,
I never said 2115 I feel
that fully developed.
Know who you are,
become who you are and then smoke weed.
That way you can tell the difference
between what the pod is doing to you and
what you are without the plot. Well
not only that, your frontal lobe,
your frontal lobe does not fully
formed until you're 25 28 is perfect.
To that point, they say you shouldn't
play football or fight or sparring,
if you know what I'm saying. You
shouldn't play football. Period.
You know there was people fight.
Joey Diaz sent me this a link or
he told me about rather this, uh,
Hbo Real Sports that they did on. That's
enough. I don't want some more cheese,
more cheese.
Real sports on football with
his kid was 10 years old.
This 10 year old kid had a double
concussion, he had a concussion,
then another one right afterwards, and
he committed suicide at 12 Jesus Christ.
Here's my thing with this though,
and football,
99% of people aren't like that though.
Like that kid probably was
going to have problems with,
they had that concussion or not
down the road, let's say football,
just exaggerated.
It might be an ally.
You know where you see the
proof though isn't the, the,
the retired NFL players that get
into commentating, you would see,
you would hear it in their speech,
but like Troy Aikman for instance,
he's had like a hundred concussions,
but he's one of the best commentators out.
Tony Roma's had a level
guys like junior sal,
but hold on Rhonda.
Patrick actually detailed this in length
is actual scientific evidence about apo
for, there's a type of, there's
a Genova Jeanette. Yeah, yeah.
This is a genetic thing and if you have
that, yeah. Did you, do you not have that?
Uh, I'm on the good side of
it. Good, perfect. Beautiful.
You're all right. You know,
so you still get damaged,
but it's not the same kind of damage.
The CTE risk is less CTE is
this cheese will knock your dick
in the dirt. No, this is a new one.
I just opened up. Yeah, that's
fucking, that's a daddy smell good.
Or I don't fuck around a
Cypress g midnight moon. Yeah.
What do you coach or how quick it goes?
Don't worry about whether a fluff,
like what are you wearing
when you walk into the door?
I always wear a robe and I go
into a dark cave. All right.
That cave where it smells like
hang out where they're hanging out.
You know where I want to take
you inspect, you know, tend,
I want to take you for Apl, APL
restaurant, Adam Perry Lang,
he has a steakhouse where
I ate a 380 day dry age,
New York strip. Pleat the fuck out of
that. It's amazing. We had an 80 day,
180 days more than he gets rotten
is, fuck huh? That's weird.
It's not because it's all like 35% right?
Dry Age beef,
disgusting or no, he brought it. He
brought out the photos of the meat.
It looked delicious.
Yeah. I mean it was red.
Just you don't like it and he
doesn't like onions. Did this.
No let needs in the city. There's no
onions and cheese. It's garbage. Right?
It's delicious, man. I didn't do any. It's
nutty and sweet. What's the problem? Well,
you know how this jeans for brain damage,
there's also genes for flat earth
belief and bad cheese tastes really bad.
He's in flat earth got
go. Oh, just delicious.
How could you not like this?
That's a good fucking try it again.
I think you got it. I'm not bringing
you to APL because I'm all over that.
I want to take you on vine in Hollywood.
It's Adam Perry Lang his place.
It's fucking amazing, dude, don't we?
I and I got something to say. Well,
we don't do dinners enough. We don't. We
don't. We're let's wait till we're old.
Shit in this fucking guy goes home and
sits there eating your little snacky
pizza. Yeah. Pizza. And we and I believe
that never mentors are very important.
I agree. I have somebody come here to
go to cook. I know. Wow. That's waiver.
Never shy you cause you won't come over
cause you're like man, I'm too busy.
You have a chef come over and cook or just
some guy you know he's that good chef.
I have a chef come out,
comes over and just 12 tubes and
we get our dicks out and Wa hard.
Do you know where we need
go? Goes crossroads. When
you go to crossroads tribes.
Parker's Vegan place down. So John Joseph
invited me this, what is it, Wednesday?
Fuck. It might be Wednesday once a
year going up fucking Pasadena asshole.
You've worked, you've committed to the
fans upon taking office barker. Wow,
I'm going to do that when we're
going to Pasadena. Eat, eat.
It's already sold out by the time
we mentioned on this podcast.
Can't back out for a dinner.
Hey, I'll be in Salt Lake Marsh.
One you want to do eat some
cucumber Bautista. I know March one,
March one and two wise guys,
guys, I know Bryan County.
Shout out to Keith the owner.
How great is he is my favorite owner.
I love know why Keith. No sports.
We can talk sports in the back.
His brother was the offense coordinator
for the Alabama Crimson tide. Wow. I know.
Me and him talk deep sports.
She's say appreciate the fuck
out of the comedy I plays too.
That's one of the most underrated
clubs in the country. Live.
They have this weird thought about Salt
Lake. My parents live in deer valley,
so they come to my show, bring on their
friends. There's a place next to keys, uh,
wiseguys called Red Iguana Mexican
food, Bro. My girls Mexican. Fuck.
This place is so good. Ready? Guana
Red Iguana. She can handle it.
She hasn't been there. She's
Mexican. I thought your wife,
is she so Mexican bro? She was
Miss Mexico, wasn't she? Yeah.
Look at this. Cynthia Kavio trying to
get that strangle on Cortney. Casey,
one thing I was talking about,
I was talking to test Santiago.
I was talking about how your
lifetime is not enough to learn MMA.
Everything. Yeah. And you're always
having to keep up and always having to,
to exhausted. It's exhausting.
Hates me. I saw you, I saw your boy,
the guy who needs that guy
and that had the child,
that Guy Chai and pro ball or black
guy. Oh you told Greg Hardy? Yeah.
Did you punch him in the
face? No, he's giant.
And I remember we had
kind of bad mouth them.
I don't know anything about him so
I didn't want to be, but I was like,
you were saying stuff and I was like,
yeah, can I go bad on me in front of Greg?
Oh I would've though.
Cause I said I'm a coward shit.
I saw him and I knew that that we'd
gotten kind of bad at it on the podcast.
I go hard in the paint.
So I saw him and I was at
American top team and I was like,
and I said to Jimmy Burke, Jimmy
Burke was one the, I go, Jimmy, Jimmy,
I go with that guy. I think I bad
mouth him or I was at least didn't,
I was kind of like,
yeah I called you so trying to go,
I gotta take a shower but I
just got to sneak over it.
Cause when I went in there a
bunch of guys were like, Hey,
cause they all want
listened to the podcast.
I was like a celebrity and I
thought he was there and I was just,
I legitimately was to
love no, but I just, yeah,
I would just to slow down and
choked them out there as I'm dying.
Bread is gonna get you for this.
He is impossibly large.
Well it played for the Dallas cowboys.
Well novel athlete, phenomenal athletes
just hits women. So I can't fuck with it.
That's kind of my thing. Legit allegedly,
well no, he did get convicted of it,
but maybe he's re kind of, you know,
let's be found. You hold on a second.
Oj Simpson got acquitted so let's
settle the fuck down on convicted. Well,
but he got it. He, but he did charge
guilty in civil court. Civil. Yeah.
We all glove does not fit.
You must've, let's be the bad.
I know nothing.
I know.
I'm not saying that's the reason
why looking at it that way,
he might be a great guy. Me and might
get along. It might start puking.
He seemed like he was very well liked
because the guys around him were just all,
I mean I put out a tech,
should
I have oh and my podcast, Yay or
Nah. I said, hell yeah, you should.
Why wouldn't you? He's not going to
open up. It's not going to open up.
It would be one interview
where he was like, no,
this is what I did. Remember that
book you wrote a book. If I did it,
if I could talk to him
and he just needed one.
Life is like now that talked
about one of those interviews.
Can we do like if I did
it? Part two is yeah.
Yeah. These are all
lies. These are all lies.
Just want to let the audience know this
is not real and just let them go off.
Come on man. Fuck silly
getting there, dude.
52 but hit.
Um,
did you guys ever see when Oj did a
music video after he got acquitted,
he was doing like rap. That's why
we're friends, dude. Have you seen it?
It's amazing. It's amazing. Yeah.
He's hanging out with all his heart.
He was like dancing and yeah. Jamie,
pull up the Oj Simpson music video.
It's going to make sure you guys get
juice and he's fucking, when we play it,
are we going to get with
his girlfriend in the video?
How crazy is it that he beats that rap
and then it gets thrown in jail for some
stupid shit. The stupidest of stick
with kidnapping. We can't listen to it,
but look at watch the cat, but he's
got a crown on. Just think about it.
He cut his fucking ex wife's head off.
You went to Miami,
got weird kitchen knife and look at him
in there dancing and this is right when
he gets out of, they all got titties
out. Get juiced. It's uncensored.
Look at this. A porn
channel, uncensored video.
Look at Oj Simpson and wearing a wig
dressed up like Elvis after he murdering
people. This is our two years after he
got to quit it. Just think about that.
He murdered two people less than 10
years before he made this video and he's
dancing around with these hoes.
That is bizarre. Some hosts,
when he got to Miami,
they said he fucked all the girls
lined up to fuck Oj Simpson three got
acquitted after how creek
while dark Ted Bundy.
They want to fuck murderers, Bang
and bitch. And you think that, let's,
let's talk about that. What do
you think that is? I have an idea.
Not all the girls. It's a, it's a small
percentage of girls. What does that,
what does that,
I think that it's probably primordial.
I think it goes back to the Alpha male
who kills and rules with ruthlessly and I
think that there seems to be there,
there's probably a feeling of safety
if you can align with that with the
biggest, baddest male. But yeah, but he's,
he's killing women with that
power lifters with half that.
So I think that is also the
idea that if I can tame him,
that there's a challenge to that there.
There's a, I knew certain fuck that,
you know.
Right.
Have been with many women
who are drawn to bad ass.
I don't know. That's exactly what
I was going to, because I have,
I had to jump to the gun.
I know my wife is I think said like dot.
Tony Soprano is sexy as fuck.
Even though he had belly and everything
and he was choking everybody with a wire.
It's just not saying when you were
watching Narcos to Pablo Escobar,
even dude's are like rooting for him.
He's a fucking murderer.
Like Tony Montana for instance.
Yeah.
You were rooting for him
when he died at the end.
Every time where you watched Scarface at
the end, you're like, what are you doing?
And get the fuck out of the house too
is you're the mouse can you're giving us
all that you're the mouse came today.
I'm rarely give me no more.
That shit I don't trust. You
know, he's just drinking.
Does that don't cheat
too in front of the mic?
The whole key to making people happy as
well as doing a good show is don't shoot
you on the mic. You're correct.
You're doing it right now.
I can't get over soon enough. Oh, how
dare he is and good scrap. That's great.
Fight amendment. Cortney Casey
and fleets Herrig they literally,
one of the things we were talking about
during the commentary was like they
never moved from the same spot.
They literally stayed in the same spot.
Like Courtney stayed in one spot.
Felice bit stayed in the same spot. No,
it was weird.
They were just standing in front of
each other and Courtney's a Felice spit
blood on her.
Jesus Christ.
You spit her brow got dealt
with her name's Luke Sanders,
the bad motherfucker. He
came out with a chip. Yeah,
White Guy Dreads Nashville board and Ruth,
he's a beast.
Cool Hand Luke Snow motherfucker.
I mean he's no one to fuck with Dell.
Bad for Hennen Browne. Yeah.
Well he used to be so god,
TJ ruined Tim.
Are we going to see Tj say Hutto at 35
I would like to see it again at 20 Tj
wants it at 25 that five or
stopped too soon. I think he gives,
he wants at 35 well it would be good
for pseudo, it would be good for Tj.
If it's at 25.
I really believe that it'd be better for
so Hutto because it would give him the
chance to be champ champ.
What do you do with the flyweight
division stolen there? Well, you could,
you could have one more big fight.
There's a few guys.
What's the plan with joy do they're about
to cut. Better be to have to cut it.
They're thinking about it,
but they hadn't made the phone.
Dana could do whatever the fuck he wants.
He could have cm punk one
23 could have cm punk off.
They could in and fight
that they should have a,
if they do keep one 25 have joy Benevides,
fight him.
He said Udo for a championship. Who
stands for side? We're very close fight.
Who's next for a Cyborg? Cyborg. Oh, the
female female. Hey, who won that fight?
So who door or um, Benevidez when they're
pseudo by split decision. That's right.
So who'd only lost one fight?
Yup. Yeah, just TJ. Yeah,
but that was just what you're
saying about Cyborg. Was that,
would you say it'll last to DJ?
Yes. Oh, I thought you said Tj. No,
Dj. Um, I might've said Tj.
I met Dj up if I did what?
What did you say about Cyborg?
What's next for her?
Amanda Nunez put her on another planet.
Amanda Nunes and then she's out.
Why not?
She's going to retire. Yeah,
she's done. She's done.
She's talking with all mad at us. What
else is there? Yeah, she's just going to,
she's like, what am I going
to stick around naked? Make
Miami? No, no. She's not on,
she has money to me suck and she's going
to be naked with a pink fur coat on
sucking titties. Yeah. All that shit.
I don't think she's made enough money
to be talking about retiring millions.
Millions. Yeah. She's my
biggest women in history.
Who ever sideboard did
you made a lot of money.
What about boxers by mass and all
those guys? They all come back.
They retire and then they think they get
used to that money. That was, oh my God,
I have 3 million. Then in two years they
go, oh my God, I only have 2 million.
Cris Cyborg explains why she's a
WWE performance center. Oh my God.
She's going to go to WWE and challenge
Ronda Rousey's. Oh shoot. Magic.
Her and Rhonda Rousey have a
Goddamn WWE type match. A kid kid.
That's probably how that ends.
You think that's how men's number,
we didn't watch 30 seconds.
I'll dude is a good one though.
Based on throw those comics.
My favorite
guys is my next step to do it. Can't be
welcome to that 19 so my neck. Look Jack,
I would do that. Iron Nick, is it stiff
goes when you're like talking about duty.
I think I have extra meat
on my Mac and Brendan Kinda.
There's a pause and many goes. Do you
really need a thicker neck or, I do.
I got real problems. I was thinking
about this, trying to get bigger.
I'm trying to get fit. Guy
Choked out that mountain. Mine.
I always think of that 85 pounds. So
you son of a bitch. Shut the fuck up.
I know this. This guidelines like, Hey,
I know everything that was in 85
pounds. Listen to me, mother fucker.
I know everything about this
kitchen to me, mother fucker.
The cat was half eaten by another cat by
the time the Rangers got, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no. Know
the frame of the cattle.
We know there's a juvenile cat.
It was 85 pounds is huge. Big Cat.
That's a police dog. No, no,
no. It's big for a police dog.
It's not big for your
juvenile or Kathy pounds.
I know everything about this case. What
we want to get that guy, whoever you are.
Gentlemen, sir, what's fine. This
man's name, I want to get you in here.
I'll pay your medical bills. Oh,
Travis. Travis coffee. Yes I do.
Travis Kaufman. You bad motherfucker.
I'll pay your medical bills.
I want to know how he did it.
Tell me everything stopped on his nut.
Bake him from behind. He sent something
was there. It jumped him from behind.
He got a wild scramble a bit. His face.
He's got his giant Gash on his face.
They scraped.
It was a wrestling match and he got
his fucking foot on this things neck.
Let me see. The picture was
skeptical. Hipaa lies. No, no.
He killed his fucking cat with his
goddamn bare hand and there was a stick.
Right glace Babs, Bro. There's
sticks in the woods and he's like,
hey, he's like the world's not round
but sticks aren't Sir sir, sir.
Ticks aren't real sir. According
to Colorado, parks and wildlife,
wait 35 to 40 pounds so you know. No, no,
no, no. I'm that cat was when it was dead.
That's a cat when he was baby face.
Easy fast.
Find another one. Yeah.
There was one today.
There was no fighting
news, Bro. I another one,
stop reading fake news. I'm a
cardiologist and I can tell you right,
it's an expert on cat's
fine. Another one, Google,
Google may as a scratch on his face,
man gets attack starving.
Fake news
can find another one that's
lessening to Steve or Nell's podcast today
and he said it was 85 pounds as well.
Steve Call those fish stories.
What do they call them?
Fish stories.
That's the call.
That's a way that thing was sleeping
in a den and he stopped at two up.
He murdered getting murdered
and eaten by another one. Hold on.
You were just fucking with you.
Turns out there some real legit shit.
Fucking I do. I just typed in
85 pounds and see what comes up.
There's a three articles.
Once those 41 says 85 once this
one says 110 to 180 pounds,
well that one's bullshit.
That article man's a murderer and fucking
chill. You're not going to
kill and a 180 pound cat,
but you might kill an 80 pound cat
for sure.
He came across
the thing was already eaten and he
took the nails. Any scratches on
85 pounds, eight Joe, he
doesn't know. What did you see?
His face got a little scratch.
Got a couple of strobe off. Well,
that was a month ago, Bro. You
know what dude? This fire guy.
Yes, he's implanted that mountain.
Okay. How does, let's, let's ask,
let's ask this question. How does
the Empire Guy Recover? He does, man.
He's done working Hollywood.
Dude. He's done. How do you,
how do you recover the pride?
You someone like logo,
TV or the black communities
like ridiculing him now and
he's done because he's a
liar and he asked her all the support
too, like that the director of uh, empire.
Like when I was like, I can't believe
that he goes like this. He goes,
I fucked back the
sisters hot as fuck dude.
Did you see his interview with Robyn
from fucking Good Morning America?
He's like in the people that seek,
I'm making this up
like full, like full blown and
performed. Wow. What a scumbag.
I don't call it a bad guy. Comment 85
pounds thing. I can't find one. Yeah,
I know it's a 20 pound. It's a 20
pound cat is a 10 pound medicine.
Fucking a house cat. Jamie, how dare
you. You know what? Even if it was
on a mountain,
so
there's some,
at least he killed the measure and trivia
murder of what did Paul Felder major
in in college? Theater theater.
Come on, Bro. How about that?
There's a hilarious
picture. Hold on. Jam. Jon.
Anik was doing research today or
yesterday and he put up on Instagram.
What are the picks of Paul Felder
from his, uh, theater days?
It's hilarious. It's
hilarious. He looks like,
like a Geisha look at
that. Oh Wow. He looks like
a complete bad ass. No, he looks
like Stephen King and drag at,
I'm not prepared to make fun
of them cause he's, he's not,
he looks very similar to Stephen King. He
to me, it looks like Stephen King's son.
See that young Stephen King. But
he's saying really? Oh my gosh.
Amazing. Jamie, what's
going on with that screen?
Why does it keep blinking in and out?
HDI still fucking up. No, it's just,
what a great picture.
I'm trying to think of what it looks like.
Who's the filter is as bad as they
haven't. How about John Onc goes,
please don't let me in the face for shit.
Maybe that's a Halloween pick, you know.
No, no, he was, he was in
a play. He was playing.
There hasn't been a couple times. There
is all handsome. He's looking rugged.
He's a man, Bro. Man. Manly man. A man.
Felder. I think Felder, I mean he, he's,
he can beat anybody in the world at the
right time. I mean, I don't think anybody,
he's not a cake walk for anyone. He's
definitely tough to tough as shit. I mean,
he went the full three rounds
with Barboza and took some,
came in the row shots. He's an amazing
commentator to really very, very good.
I really enjoyed doing commentary
with him. Damn Danny Castillo.
Should we vape?
Zabbix wheels of cheese.
What's that quick correction?
Something you guys were just a five
pound mountain lion. Oh, suit. Also lost.
Oh.
Benevidez
best style on the UFC.
Joey Benevidez me
correcting us by the way,
been benefit is one of the nicest
guys on the planet is a great guy.
Nicest one of the his
wife Megan will Libby.
I'm also using the two of them together.
I root for them with everything they do.
Every time I see him I go have
kids. Yeah, you need to have
four foot 11 babies. Oh, how dare
you. I'm flattered with apple bottoms.
They're going to be in the
circus. Very adorable. No circus.
By the time those kids get older or their
sales circuses in fucking weird places
like, you know, weird fucking middle
of the country, John and stuff. No,
I'm talking about America or
England. We were, it's during lunch.
It's done because you can't have
elephants anymore. I'm out. Yeah.
You want to talk about tough people
like Izer by Shawn? We don't,
there are a lot of fighters there
that are waiting to get visas.
Just like with dog Estann there's all
for MMA and wrestling and Azerbaijan is
their national.
There's that one.
My buddies there and now he's working
there and he said his son is in a
wrestling club.
There's a wrestling club everywhere
and he said they the all the kids from
literally from eight to 16 years old,
they're all wrestling guy comes out
with mouthpieces and boxing gloves,
no headgear and all the kids like, yeah,
they start cheering, put on their gloves,
putting the mouthpieces and start banging.
Well the need nuclear physicist so they
can compete with us in the global world.
War is the next country to
little thing is that shit.
That's great. If you want
cage fighters. Yeah. You know,
Oppenheimer flip the switch on all
that shit. He's just very cute.
You can't do a Mongol style anymore. You
know, this is a bunch of old masculine,
the powers. Oh Man. Oh Shit.
Taylor boss. Fuck it's guy.
He did a great job, man.
He painted for me and I looked at it
and the first time when I saw it in the
flash I was like,
that needs to be in the fucking studio.
Kids good looking over us.
He does a great look at her eyes.
That's a good artist right
there. Yeah, no, Tim is amazing.
Hunted Hendricks out in the hallway too.
He's painted and that's really
hard to have a Hendrix problem.
How many fucking Hendra Patriots,
Huh?
The reason why this show's called
the Joe Rogan experience is Hendrix.
Jimi Hendrix experience.
I probably listen to Hendrix more than
I'm listening to any human being on the
planet earth. You love him.
Love. I'm feeling about it.
It's about the size of that to me is my
number one who dumb he's saying from me.
But I think I've listened to Hendrix more.
You know,
it's just like he was so pure who was
so free with, what did he die from?
20 zero seven drug. This one dies,
knows what am drugs. There was a story.
Stories truck. Yeah. The official stories
do me, what is Joe turns into conspiracy.
His manager,
his manager was a gangster in it.
There was a guy who was one of
the henchmen for his manager.
They said the manager killed him
cause Hendricks was leaving up.
The one thing that supports that is that
it was weird that he died like choking
on his own vomit and he didn't have
heroin in his system or like there's like
some weirdness to it, but then the
other part of it is that the girlfriend,
Hendricks girlfriend was allegedly
committed suicide by jumping off a roof.
But the henchman says they threw her
off a row. Yeah, white chick, which she,
she knew that without. The other thing
that's disappointing about Hendrix,
if you hear that Hendrix used to beat
his girlfriend, but that might've been,
she was smear campaign prior to,
we talked about how he hit his wife.
She did a lot of coke and fucked everyone.
Richard Presto hit hitters.
There's also rumors he suck
Dick. Not Rumors. No, his wife,
his ex wife confirmed it like he
fucked Marilyn. Marlon Brando.
Richard Pryor. Yeah. I don't believe it.
Not shut the fuck up. You don't believe.
Have you seen it been the day man,
back in the day,
parents white came out with a whole thing
in the 60s she was smearing. No, no, no,
no, no, no. It was okay back then
everybody. But the story, the Bachelor,
I've never done coke,
but when you do coke and you were in the
sixties and seventies apparently those
guys are just fucking whatever was in
Jackson. I'm David Bowie did that shit.
Well she was saying
Pryor's wife was saying,
her exact quote I think was you'll fuck
a radiator if you get enough coke in
front of you. You guys, you guys
are trying to deal with you guys.
You guys want to do some
code? Know what? Maybe a no,
no, no. Marlin broke. Maybe David Bowie,
maybe Mick Jagger, maybe David Bowie.
Did they get their stomach pumped
or something like that? Rod Stewart.
But that's all I, that's all your
Dear Journal myth to Keith Urban.
The Telegraph for this might be real,
but we know we didn't think
about Richard Gere, Juno.
It was thinking about the Richard Girls.
He's gay. Straight. No, no, no, no.
But here's the thing.
The Richard Gere durable thing apparently
came right after he left Scientology.
That's the real, Oh yes. Okay.
That's a smear underwear,
but it's such a good smear campaign.
When I like lemon,
when I first met Eddie, Eddie and I talked
about this because he grew up in La.
I grew up in Boston.
We both heard the Richard Gere
story at the same time that exactly,
because motherfuckers spread across
the country who was a healer as a huge,
they were getting,
no,
he just had a baby and he's 85,000
years old still doing it. By the way.
I ain't got Jamie Brett Young,
Richard Gere looking at a sexy,
a little with his shirt off.
Hey,
how about officer and a gentlemen going
nowhere else. I'm all that movie, Dude.
I love that movie and I love
that scene. Oh, it was amazing.
How good as Louis Gossett
Jr. Oh Damn. He was good.
He won an Oscar for that or was it
nominated? He was incredible to watch.
That movie didn't win the world.
Fucking terrible back.
Do you ever watch them an unfaithful
and you watch it with your share?
Like cheating on her show outward?
Huh?
What are your truck? Rough?
No, that's the old movies.
That's like his tenure three movie get.
I'm looking at him. Look at him, dude.
Fuck Dude. He was, he was the shit
when he was younger, man. Yeah,
but he didn't have any kids until his low
to be fucking like 380 [inaudible] New
York strip right there. Beautiful.
He steals your girl all day long.
That's an I beat that guy to death
in front of his mom. Doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
He's vulnerable.
He cries and you're doing a young
Clint Eastwood beats that lesson.
I was a handsome boy when I was young.
You were cute too, but gear picture,
you and I in the nineties I know.
Going to fucking know you had some swag.
He dressed like shit. Yeah, no, I
was just ridiculous. No, your show.
It was cool that he kept the sweaters in.
We were both in disaster.
My sweaters while we may as
well. He's a, here we go.
James Vick, Duke. Can we watch? We
do that. We're going to watch this.
It's a good fight.
We're gonna Watch this would definitely
have watched the main event fell.
There's such a competitor, man. Little,
they're all competitors, right? Yeah.
Well they're competing for living Brian.
Jesus calls, but he's just telling me,
look how big Vic is so long, but you got
to think he cuts the shit out of weight.
He is a giant. How much does
he cut? He's like struve.
Is that Stefan struve is this, this
is 55 right dude. Great references.
D five yes it is this 55 Oh fucking one
six three six six three
55 that's a big advantage.
Cuts so much weight when he
gets hit. It's true. Hey, fuck,
Felder and I were in the fucking locker
room last time we were working together
and we're getting changed,
getting ready for UFC. I go, dude,
what the fuck do you weigh? And he
goes, whoa. One night I go, bitch,
you 200 pounds and we're laughing about,
always lie about their weight and he goes,
what about you?
And I go pitch him on TRT.
I'm 50 years old.
Not all the juice I need to
get on that stuff. You should.
I've been telling you for
about eight years, Brian went,
his mind has so much energy. You
look good. You look good. My Cock,
I just injected in your little
skinny neck. Dawn could cut a dye,
should shoot it right into the
tip of your heart. I don't have
a cat would blunt its claws on my friend.
Come on. Ooh. Fell to just connected
with it. I'm still fighting
that hard issue to knee lost.
Still fighting though.
I think he's still fine.
I don't think he's officially
retired and on the top last funny,
he might've retired. I don't know why he
doesn't use his jab more struve. Yeah.
Oh good. He's seven foot tall
and the nicest guy in the planet.
Hard for the size of an elephant. It's
a problem. When I interviewed him,
I feel so awkward. I'm
like, well dad, what zoo?
Or we go into or whatever, dude,
I wouldn't got coffee with him.
Like get your dick out of my face.
And he's just so tired.
That's me. Do you remember
when we meet? I met him.
We were all hanging out cause you guys
had the same manager and we were hanging
out and he's sitting down,
he's as tall as I am standing and I,
and I said to Brendan
and I go, I go, dude,
what would you do if you had to fight him?
And Brandon was still fighting.
Can you know him and brought him down
to that to him because Brendan Goes, Oh,
I'd knock him the fuck out. That's what
I took it. You took it personally, Cyrus,
we were supposed to fight like twice.
You were looking at this fight right here.
Let's watch this fight. Yeah. Let's
watch two fights tonight. Paul Felder,
Double Jab, Double Jab. What
did you,
do you ever think about doing actual
commentary because I know you played me in
a movie, but you're willing to do
actual commentary, Bafta, Bafta,
Joe Rogan, warrior. I
had an offer and I said,
I don't know enough about to do to fight.
I think.
I think everyone should pick you
up or rice and beans. Epstein
and Dennis Miller do commentary.
Hold on.
That was the issue. When I started
working for the UFC, I was concerned.
I was legitimately concerned because
this was before UFC 37 and a half when I
started working for the UFC.
Dennis Miller was doing Monday
night football and I was like,
I don't want to fuck this up. So I
decided like I made a conscious effort.
I'm not even going to remotely try
to be funny. No, I'm, I'm like,
I'm funny actually you shouldn't
have to write. It meant a lot to me.
Like martial arts means a lot martial
artist and seller didn't ever play
football. He couldn't relate to any
of you. Please put in Jackson, junior,
all American.
Does it change when George Washington
was coming across to Delaware?
We have a black, he was
hard. He was horrible.
I feel bad for him because he
wasn't set up for success in that.
That's not a good place.
Well he was trying to throw those jokes
around like he had written out like he
was getting to like spite.
I think they probably brought
him in to do that though.
But then thinking about it for his jokes,
they have to, okay. All of his shit.
So prewrite that was a nightmare.
He really thinks so hundred percent
they didn't give him the free reign.
Crazy seeing about the UFC as that.
They don't tell me what to do.
You've never said anything outrage
on here. You've said some shit,
really ridiculous things, but you're
also the best at what you do. So,
but the fact that they have this billion
dollar multibillion dollar organization
and let me talk is fucking insane.
Never.
I never fought MMA.
You're on black book,
Joe Buck number play baseball
and he's one of the best color.
Yeah. It was a play by play
of color. Different play by
play. Guy Doesn't have to,
he doesn't have to be a professional.
Don't put it be
generally has to be. What I'm
saying is Joe, so goddamn good.
Some of them they said, fuck it. We don't
care about that shit. Well, the thing is,
I wasn't good when I first just
have been doing some day one.
Day One,
it's over.
We tagged them. Fell there is,
he's clinching is a beast. Well,
vix trying to hold out. He's so nasty.
He says, I feel sick for so much cheese.
Cheese.
I had my cholesterol just shot up to 3000
I don't think it works like that. Nope.
No it doesn't. No, it doesn't have any
effect on the skin. Is that tree? Yeah.
Dietary cholesterol is almost zero effect
on blood lipids. Mostly it's genetic.
There's a lot of different,
various issues,
but people that have certain genes
really shouldn't fuck with a lot of high
cholesterol foods.
But for the most part,
dietary cholesterol has
been scientifically proven,
have almost zero effect on blood,
high cholesterol. So I have to, well,
some people do well,
the thing is about what is it,
LDL or HDL and w w if they're
balanced out together,
the real thing is like checking for um,
artery.
I can slack like Che checking
to see if you're okay.
Can you do that with a sonic? No. You need
to go to a real doctor, mother fucker.
No, no, no, no. I'm saying, can you do
that when I do it? I can't do it for you.
Can you check my arterial branch? I can
check your aura. Check my was that same.
He saw a doctor,
but he was such a for your psoriasis.
I can't tell you how to finger in your
butt. Uh, about two, three fingers,
deep fingers or size of bratwurst. And
should I do that? Did he grow over,
done that
colonoscopy when he gets
all three of [inaudible] 15.
When you're 50 you got to
get a colonoscopy. A doctor
gets all three and he goes,
you gotta go get a colonoscopy. Did you
get a call on that? Yeah, me too. Yeah,
I was getting my butthole
looks amazing to put you out.
I'm still happy. Request
a female. Like I say,
I gotta say that I'm so happy
that the UFC is on ESPN. I really,
I think it's so good for the sport. It's
so much better than Fox. Cause so many.
Yeah.
It's so good because so many people
that are just sports fans just watch the
ESPN all day long to bars have ESPN
on all the time. Just on a loop.
On a loop. I'd leave ESPN then. Yeah,
if I'm just at home, that's my default.
He used to be that. Yeah. And I
don't give a fuck about sports,
but I understand it. I know it. It's
such a big move for the UFC. It's huge.
I think it's so tone for that perfect
home. I agree. I'm so happy when, when I,
when I heard it was happening and then
the streaming service because you know,
because I spent so much time,
oh look at this James Vick,
I spent so much time doing online stuff.
I was really happy about that.
I was like, good streaming is where
the future lies. What is filters? Rank?
He's not right. He's a, you know,
it's probably a top 25 that they don't
really rank you until your top 15 though.
He's aiming at the top 15 I feel like,
well that was why he didn't get that
Khabib fight and al I acquainted did,
but in retrospect that was actually really
huge because al fought a great fight,
went five full rounds with could be,
which Connor couldn't do and then beat
Kevin Lee's ass and his next fight and I
was ranked number four in the
world and should be and should be.
Ally acquainted when he's focused is a
fucking gangster. He's the one restaurant,
right? He, I don't know what his name is.
D One wrestled at Juco is not
going to Dustin and, and shadow.
Somebody asked him and Mike Brown,
I think Jimmy said,
what's the one discipline that you think
is the best thing to have in wrestling?
Have them, I don't know. Wow.
I know wrestling,
that's why you shouldn't do commentary
except in the movie stripes.
Being smart around gets
a conversation going.
Wrestling's everything man.
It's the ability to dictate them to fight.
That takes place. I wrestled in high
school did, that's why I do the champions.
All the champions hit me that night.
I remember what Brian Callahan,
I remember when I brought Brian to Carlson
Gracie school back from Carlson was
still alive and the Carlson
School in Hollywood off Hawthorne,
right when Vito was making his UFC debut
and Brian and I became friends and he
was wrestling with Sergio Cohen and
Sergio got mad at him and headbutted
remember that Brian,
cause I was taking,
I was taking a lot of those guys down
cause they didn't back then they didn't
know how to take that. So I was doing,
she wasn't there. I remember watching,
I was rolling and I was looking, I was
a white belt town cause look it over.
And Brian and Brian was
going hard with Sergio.
Can you go too hard and she'll
just like this? Yeah, he took it.
He talked him cause we are going take
downs and I had my elbow and he just
pulled it out and like boom,
knocked you out. He broke my nose.
Nose did you had to get my septum.
What you're saying? I was young.
I didn't just kept going. He goes,
I think that got broke my nose.
I saw that shit for two years. I was
not doing, we were like little kids.
Well I can't believe we're here.
We're a little boost of Monte
Carlos buttheads all was there.
[inaudible] California, Mario
[inaudible]. I tapped him a couple times.
No we did not. Mario Sperry was teaching
the class. Mario Sperry was hilarious.
One of the things Biros Barry said,
he goes,
I got so good at my triangle because I
get my girl in my guard and I get her in
my garden
and she says, no, I don't want to do no
more is it? Fuck you. You stay there.
Did I ever tell you that story about
his girlfriend?
I taught, I taught an old
girlfriend of mine, the triangle.
So she gets really into
it. She's like, oh my gosh.
She was a stripper back when I worked
as a DJ, as a stripper in a strip club.
So I showed her a triangle and she,
cause I wanted,
I want her her to do it on her next
boyfriend and then have him ask her,
where the Hell you learned that from? I
got pissed on her. You know what I mean?
Chess.
So she was obsessed with you triangle.
He's marked her.
She's obsessed with triangles.
So I'm trying to watch Howard Stern,
right?
And she's trying to put me in a
triangle and I keep telling him to stop.
I'm like really into this
Howard Stern episode.
She's probably trying to
put me in a triangle. You
fucking stop. She's laughing.
She's putting him in a triangle
that's like, you got to stop.
You've got to fucking stop.
And I got really pissed. I go,
you're going to fucking
start crying right now. Stop.
I'm watching this fucking stop.
And she wouldn't. She's laughing.
So she put me in a triangle and
I fucking quitting web page.
Ricardo Arona at her on the bed
though I wasn't trying to hurt.
So I picked her up and I tried
to get him to start crying.
She has me in a triangle. I picked
her up and slammed her on the bed.
It was the salt that when I slammed
her on the bed, she lets go,
bounces off the bed and goes flying and
lands on the ground and lands on her
wrist and she starts fucking quiet.
So she runs to the bathroom and I walk
into the bathroom and she's got the hot
water running over her wrist and she's
crying. She said, I said, get dressed.
We're going to the emergency
room. She goes, what? I go
get dressed, we're going to
go, let's go. Let's go. Let's go to
the emergency room. Your Shit's broken.
I just the her and I just want her to get
her to stop crying. And she stopped. And
that was what round? Is
this a second? Oh yeah.
The second Paul Felder lifts his hands up.
Feels like you won that round.
I have no idea what happened in a
good story. It was a great story.
You're going to jail.
I'm like,
when you started about two hurt,
you never signed me girl.
She never got tickets for a show.
Your girlfriend how to do a triangle
and she'll get obsessed with them.
You try to watch fucking [inaudible] now,
but you're fine. I'll to take
a swing at you. Uh, yeah.
I had a girl take a swing at me
halfway into the punch. I was like,
I can't believe this is happening. I
know. I saw her fucking haul off. I go,
this is why he's not going to fall through
it. This. I was like, oh my God, shoot.
What did
you do? Need this? And I grabbed her
like, what are you doing? Don't hit.
You just got to grab them. Mom and dad
used to beat the shit out of each other.
Ah, they did enough crazy
girl when she, when I,
when I held onto her afterwards and
she admitted it to me like he was like,
it was just a real ad. It tells
me when it was really, Oh God,
Oh shit.
Vic was landed some shots thereby felt,
oh, I cannot wait for us.
Made a fag, man. Hey Boys,
we're talking about domestic
violent moment. Dude,
we should enjoy this fun live in the
moment than I have been beaten by.
That's a weird thing,
man.
When someone expresses some shit that
they saw from their mom and their dad,
I had a real, I really lucky
that my step mom and my dad,
my Stepdad,
and my mom rather had a
really good relationship and
my mom and my dad had a bad
relationship, so he saw. So I get to
see both. I get to see like what people,
when they love each other and
just real friendly. I just had,
how well do you remember
your dad, your Stepdad, and
your dad and your step dad were
shitheads fuck yeah. I was like, yeah.
Did they hit you Eddie? My stepdaughter,
spinning back kick to the body.
Their Stepdad was
Paul Felder looking good,
but I'm glad he was because it made me
the man I am tonight and I'll put my
parents loved the shit out
of me. Hello, left Toe,
your biological dad.
I even talked to him since I was seven.
Do you remember him at all or nope. Does
he hit you up now for money and Teslas?
Put me on the [inaudible] podcast.
I got some great stories. C'Mon Bro.
We're talking about how I left your mom.
Talk about how your mom
couldn't take a shot to kill.
Imagine if he bugged you. Go.
That's the worst shit ever.
It's like when dudes bugging
you to be on your podcast and
one of those things, how many people
contact you to get on the pocket?
I got people that contact friends that
I know that contact me to contact you.
It's a nightmare and I always tell him,
I go,
it's never going to work all the time.
It's never going to work.
I get that all day long. Let's see
coffee today. The guy goes, do it.
Fight campaign tonight, right? Went, Yup,
sure. I'm with my son and make sure I met.
He's a cool tell Joe Gary from,
I'm like,
yeah, I'm moving in Montana and he's
crushing those. When I have enough money,
I'm going to move to Montana and get
off the internet. Quarter lane, Bro.
We're all going to go to correlate. I
liked Montana. No quarter better. Okay.
Why do you like quarter Phil? Dude,
it's fucking, what does that mean?
Everything's perfect.
Beautiful. Gorgeous man. Eddie,
if you go online, Jamie Vernon,
pull up pictures of your own spoken.
It's like 30 minutes rather
just drive the opposite.
That's what I did every day and
spoken out. Drive Uber, Spokane, like
full time property. Just hurt man.
Oh, fell. Fell. He's got
them hurt. He's lipid.
He's slipping by into your
headquarter and Felder. No,
just switched guys. I'm
gonna Shit my pants. Why?
I ain't seen shit bro. You have a toilet
shits. Waterworld it feels wonderful.
That thing confused me, man. Shoot the
water before I could just shut it down.
You can do both whatever you want.
If you shoot it up there before it will
make you shit harder. He like shoots out.
It's a primer.
The problem with that is when you take
one of those shifts where you got just
shit all over your ass and spray
something on, it gets messy.
Shit goes everywhere. So we're going
to, do you want to use a quarter?
Like totally. Come on
Bro. That's beautiful. Wow
Lake. No, it's gorgeous.
They're like, no dude,
I'm telling you this gorgeous big bear.
There's less white trash up there.
The families get the other people
that are going to hate me for it.
They hate when I bring it up cause
I get so fucking sacred. Like,
well they don't want it to be like
Nas Kanye restaurant. How share,
how's it a secret of Kanye West
has a ski town or what? No.
When is he going to be on your podcast?
What's happening? Oh Man. What's hard.
Is that happening? No, it'll
probably happen. It's just Kanye is,
you know, he's a complicated artist and
I'm sure there's a bunch of other issues.
First of all,
he wants to get to know me.
We got to get to hang out together and go,
oh James Felder with time that shit,
we'll do it.
We'll do it to bring him.
He's a really nice guy, man.
When I talked to him on the
phone, he's a very, very nice guy.
You already talked to him? Yeah, I
talked to him on the phone, so nice guy.
We'll do it, but I'm not
in a rush, you know? Hey,
I told you guys I really liked doing
these. As much as I like doing anything.
Like when someone says like,
what's a,
what's your favorite guest or a zero
one guests. You've never had aunt.
It doesn't exist. They don't
exist. There's no one I
like. I like doing podcasts.
I like doing podcasts with everyone
watching flights to than a future that,
that guy who's working on longevity
drugs. That was fascinating. Yeah.
John Sinclair. Where do I get resurveyed
or all? I need some of that resveratrol.
You can buy it online. Really shouldn't
learn how to spell it first. Oh Shit.
You drink it all day.
It's in wine or really low doses.
You really want to know more
fan industrial grade. Oh Shit.
Felder's spinning like a motherfucker.
Ooh, leg kicked by Vic. Oh,
Vik with the jumping knee.
That's it. That's a wrap. Okay.
55 okay, that's fair.
I know he's Vic soaps,
so he got being cater.
Francis Kane of course Eddie.
Um,
he's a great fight.
I should be going for king because
he's Mexican. Take that out of it.
When it comes off,
the best vaccine is titled go a fuck about
Mexicans when we inbox only in boxes.
But I'm going with Kane.
I'm going to ask you,
just scared me when throw any punches
against Derek Lewis. That's scared.
But his last fight though, he fucking
starch Curtis blades. Yeah, he did.
Here's my house. Here's my, I
don't know, like I use up wrestler,
who's a fucking row,
a national champion.
Juco risk snatch him.
So he's back and that's the
second fight they've had. Okay.
So he's bet was he throwing a large amount
of punches and it was the first like
30 seconds talk man, here's,
here's my take on it.
Francis is a fucking specimen and his
story literally is like right at a corner
and the barbarian or the
heat or lower heart. No,
he worked in a fucking sand mill,
digging sand,
making sandbags all day. That's how
he, his body got strong. I mean,
he lived in this incredibly poor country
in Africa. He called my room. Yeah.
He went and moved to France.
It was homeless.
He learned how to fight and they
wanted to be a boxer and they said,
you should do MMA.
Four years later,
the guy is like at the pinnacle of MMA,
fighting in the UFC against worldclass
competition and fucking people up.
Do you understand that?
When he knocked out Alistair Overeem
with that vicious like shovel,
that'd be the hardest upper
cut I've ever seen. It's,
it's insane that he beat a guy
who's not just a worldclass fighter,
but a k one grand Prix
champion. A Guy, 20 years.
Find any Mexicans. He's older though. I
don't know. That's an older Allister star.
We got heart. Well, it's an Alice
to weigh out the secret sauce.
He didn't get that when Jamie goes,
you never seen Jay relief.
That all fell to one is fine.
Felder one,
this one is fight Vic
Vic shaking his head.
Felder,
Paul Felder.
I'm gonna text him right now
cause I'm friends with them
to turn it up. No, no, no.
That's okay.
He gave it his all.
He's in Moses to get all fancy
texts like certain people. Yes.
Still in the sky. This rapper
that I'm a huge fan of shaving.
Well shake. Well, oh man. Conspiracy
Rapper. No Dude, he's just, there's a,
there's a video called leg lock
on Youtube shake. Well it's,
it's like a Tim and Eric. Awesome
show. Great job type video.
It's fucking brilliant.
Watch that shit.
And now we're texting now and I'm like,
we're going to make a song together. It's,
I'm like, I'll Gideon fast.
And a lot of music unity.
It's the same like I've always done.
I've never stopped. I never stopped.
I've always made music always. It's always
been doing the podcast for a second.
Stop doing podcasts. Right. Period.
You're not doing that anymore.
You just started repeating myself all
the time. I'm like, you know what,
that's so annoying to deal with the
things off triply tinfoil hat podcast.
No. When did you see same? So I'll
Tripoli I haven't heard from days ago.
Really good. Yeah, I see him at the
store. I see my right. You know what?
On this podcast,
that guy, I do my best. Sam's the
reason why it's also a great comp,
Tripoli. He's fucking killing
it now. He's killing it.
He's literally one of the
reasons why started to cheat.
Every time we go on the road some, you
know, sometimes I have shitty ass nights.
I thank God that Sam triply goes
after me and saves the guy we went to.
I spent two weeks in
Afghanistan with that guy.
That guy would get up and he would open
for us because he was the only one who
could soldiers just sitting there.
We'd be in the middle of nowhere.
He would get up with a
shitty mic and destroyed.
Now he's got 10 years under his belt.
Scheller he said,
I called him.
I've been doing standup.
What's Tripoli for 20 plus
years and you know what?
I'm straight up love tripling his fuckers.
Look at him.
Sam Tripoli's podcast,
tinfoil. That's a Comcast.
That's where I go off. Don't
hold. Don't hold John hostage
like subdued myself here.
Conspiracy theories, but if
you want to hear, we go off,
go to tin foil hat podcast. That's
what he goes. A good chance.
I wreck that new raptor after
out tonight. I love that. Raptor
was nothing.
Brendan,
I love that you bought that Elon
Musk took a bigger hit than that
you have MOUs losses. This is legal,
right? He didn't lose his job.
Come on,
dammit.
That had to be one of the most iconic
moments in the history of the Internet.
First of all,
it's the small one in podcasts and it
was a a completely on the fly moment.
Is that your biggest podcast? No. Biggest
one. What's the biggest one? Ship.
You don't know who's number one?
Number one down most views.
I only go by what you see on the,
first of all,
that'd be the biggest one in podcast
history. It also made me like Elon Musk.
He's a good decision. Before I've
saw him around his kids go to a gym.
I just go to, I didn't dislike it,
but that may. I'm like, oh, he's cool.
I had to buy his car because I told them
I would buy his car when I did the part.
I don't like him anymore.
That's right. I'm so happy. I
wish you did it. No, no, no.
I have eight other cars. It's just see
if my rap, you can run over your time.
I love your raptor. But um, listen man,
I'm telling you that God damn Tesla is
the future. I think other cars are stupid.
You know how many cars are their cars are
stupid. You know how many cars I have,
right? Yeah, I do. What
am I driving here today?
I know it's harder to drive your title
Joel on cars. I drive here today.
You drove the Tesla,
the Tesla.
I cause cause I know cause you're like,
cause I drove cause you're like dude,
if you drive my I do like dudes. I don't
like to fuck them all. I thought you did.
Oh cool. Joe Likes to fuck dude.
Brendan, you can't go there.
You can't go there because look
her podcast, Bob cool with it.
We're still friends.
I like to think that if I was scared to
tell you all you really think test the
cars are gay. They're just not. I just
don't like, why don't you just drive mine?
That's what I need to do. When you drive
on high and drunk right now, listen,
I get another one. If Shit goes
wrong, what about that Tesla did.
He pretended to launch into space.
What about that one?
That one's coming out in two years.
It's not out yet.
That one goes zero to 60 in 1.9
seconds. Good. That's trouble.
Let me tell you.
Mine is 2.4 mine is the fastest fucking
thing I've ever driven in my life.
I have a Goddamn race car.
I have a Porsche gt,
three Rs from shark works.
I have a real goal that
Tesla as well made.
It's feels like it.
It's different.
Look at the fucking doesn't feel
the same because the same. This,
she'll say you write mad
mad because now Joe can,
Brian can bond on their
Teslas and now you're not
F-150 shit. You know what I mean? I
love all of you. I love all of you.
You've got to listen to me.
The future or their cars are bullshit.
I'm going to write it.
I'm going to write a an article for like
cars are bullshit. No, no. Better yet.
Other cars was dumb.
I don't really started going to
his barbecue on the weed, Bro.
Best car. No, no, no. Elan
told. He told me that, but he
did the podcast. I was like,
get the fuck out of here because I had
an m five at the time and the m BMW m
five is a phenomenal car. The new
one's even better than the one I had,
but I was like, come on man.
I got a four door sedan.
It goes zero to 60 in three seconds
is shut your pie hole. I was like,
this is a nonsense coding through
Brendan. He hits. Oh my God. Listen,
300 300 fucking miles. How
are you supposed to go to
Vegas? Last minute, whim,
trick. Anyway. Can you get someone else to
drive? It's good for a married man. Yeah.
Tests for sure.
Trying to get a test.
You're telling me you feel
alive when you draw me a test.
So compared to your gt three,
I feel like I'm living in the future.
Tesla,
do you
remember the switch was?
I do remember.
I remember when they went to Vegas.
We can talk over each other. Do you
guys leach when you get sick to you?
Fucking old timers. Fuck you with general
electrician. What are you driving?
A Golf Cart
or horse shoe.
You Fuck Blacksmith, you guys, you
must get guns.
My car has four wheel drive,
more than 700 horsepower and it goes
zero to 60 in two and a half. So
I got a Tundra. You gotta watch
Japanese at a wonderful car.
I will never talk shit on Tundras. It's
one of the best cars you can buy. Scott,
we want to buy a car that will never
break down and can tow your fucking
grandmother's house. Get a
Tundra Mason dry. Latanya.
Turn stumbled on my word,
Bro.
Give me your car right now.
I'm a gigantic Toyota fiber embarrassed.
When I drive with the podcast and you
guys pull up and you're fucking 90 fucking
a hundred dollar cars
ton truck and back. Yeah,
we're on. Get with it bro.
With your internal combustion engine.
This is his wife flew. I lived,
if you guys knew how I fucking,
I got a f dude. I live wonderful.
I never buy clothes.
You know the clothes I wear the clothes
my other schools get 10 planets.
San Antonio,
I have 10th planet Franchisee.
You might be the most successful Jujitsu
guy. No, with Henzel Gracie Henderson.
Listen, I have a hundred success. Gracie,
Gracie bog at 1800 [inaudible]
alone. Hundreds of scans. No, no, no.
Gracie Baha got 1500 schools to work
at it and you're like, I want to,
but you don't work at, he works at he, he,
he successful just out of the
love to what's going on. I'm like,
I think you're better than us because
you have Tesla. I'll fucking turn it.
I can't turn this table
over. It's heavy. All right.
I gotta put my earphones on. God
dammit. This is Paris Hilton.
That's his wife getting excited.
I think we're kept up for this.
We got people listening at home when they
got their headphones on and then we at
Dick head in the back, it hurts
their ears. Okay. Yeah. You know,
he is such a bad ass,
but his body is not
just the double decker tacos. He
doesn't have, when you look at his body,
you'd be like, that just
doesn't look like, okay,
but I'm gonna save all that look shit
because he's got the best body ever for
the MMAS heavyweight division. When he
was in his prime, well that body body,
he knocked out,
make it tomorrow.
He took giant bombs from Czech
Congo and I see what you're saying,
but not that that was the same body mass
that's not flapping around like a ball
cap the biceps or lose number one
heavyweight for me, Jon Jones.
Hey guys, let's not talk over each
other. This has gotta be ruthless
in his prime when he was at his best,
like when he knocked out man Notaro you
know when he beat up rather as an error
look at fate or his body.
Yeah, exactly. It's true.
It's the body that the way it looks,
I was talking about flat earth.
It means nothing. It doesn't matter. Well
guess what fucks we'll find out tonight.
Cause Francis has the best
bodies body and k looks like a a,
they were talking about like the,
the female UFC bodies.
Louise, do you guys never
do? I always do. Never here.
My favorite is volunteers. It's always
about with, I think she's so hot.
Cody. Garbrandt it's
always the same shit. No,
you take the stage. Oh no sort
of itch. I'm going to show us.
She's better looking than the ring cargo
van Zandt dime piece Rose Nama Juniors.
Oh, switch has preposterous
genetics. Oh rose.
Nama Jealous.
They're just
to me so much money stripping in
wigs like long wigs. She come,
makes a ring walk and she's got
this long as it takes it off.
And that becomes your thing I think.
I think for me,
I don't know what it is so hot.
You know,
rose is one of the most beautiful women
in the history of the sport and she's
the one who emphasizes it.
Almost the least.
Who naturally beautiful magazines,
Beautiful Bald,
Bald Rose Rama, Julia. She's stunning
looking. She's stunning. Looking amazing.
She's cool.
She's a great fighter.
She's also like super
fucking like Keith Carradine.
She's into her own life,
her own way, you know.
Definitely hasn't gotten Hollywood with
the Nah, man. She's like, she's like when?
When she wins the fight and knocks
out nominee Eunice, y'all, you know,
y'all just be nice to each
other. It's like, why?
She's great movie right there
at that fight with Joanna. John,
John to bitch.
Tell her name right now and I can say it.
Spell it
again. Genji yeah, but we can
say it. You had to write it down.
It wouldn't be right. What does it,
Jay can't spell. What do you think?
What percentage don't fans of hers?
It's a hard name.
Brian. Stan just started calling her.
You want a champion? He just gave up.
That's just lazy. Bryan Wright
at house, while he's respectful,
he's a Goddamn all American who's more
all American than Brian's kind of hard
enough thought. He can't be crazy
names. As an American, it's tough.
No level of hard. It's that. It's
that that tie level, you know,
cause some of them tie names.
Song Tong,
jeopardy champion level. Yeah.
That's a hard one. Those show me be,
I'm right there with the
brushes and money. Me and
Wolf Blitzer was on jeopardy.
I'd lose five pounds,
something like that.
Can anybody here spell,
does the beats last name?
He's the one I might be able to
get online.
Why would we want to spell that?
Normal. No one spells really anymore.
What I'm saying Jamie could do it.
Those whose names are hard to remember
because to this day right now I still
don't know is the beats lashkars
hormone monster Sherif part.
But here's the thing about these
nerves and worked for the FC Bro.
But did you have to be
practiced it over and over again?
Because I had a really hard time with
it to the point where his coaches were
saying just calm rooms that beat and that
felt that was disrespectful. But yeah,
but it felt like this, this is the
gentleman's name, he's excellent.
I don't see the difference.
I never thought like,
cause Dave's last name I
just gave up on it. And said,
there's no way I could do this. You know,
we have to respect the phallic say this,
but we have to respect the fact that
they have a totally different language in
terms of like their letters,
letters,
they can respect the fact that they
have complete different language.
Makes a fucking tough. It's
very hard. It's difficult to,
I don't know what the fuck's
going to happen right here.
I do not know what the phone
can we hear them discount,
get his head in his chest.
He kicked off of Youtube or some shit.
We just need to watch this on her own. Um,
I'm, in my opinion, this is what it is.
The greatest as it in terms of best I've
ever seen performances. He's the most,
one of the most stunning
athletes I've ever seen.
Cain Velasquez like one of the most
amazing heavyweights of all time,
if not the best of all time.
He, he, he might be the best.
And then Francis at all the guys I've
ever seen fight is the scariest of all
time. He has the most of all in.
Sure. Yup. Yup, Yup. Most potential.
He,
he's only been fighting a small amount
of time and he's already in like world
class competition.
You have to understand to knock out a
guy like Alistair Overeem literally like
five years in a training that's insane.
He something uniquely special
in terms of his like, like the,
the what,
the shit that he had to endure working
in a fucking sand mine digging bags of
sand,
the kind of power that he possesses.
If he just gets all those
other pieces in place. He like,
in terms of like an
overall physical specimen,
he's one of the scariest of all time.
So this is, this is an amazing fight.
I mean this is like as good as it
gets if you're an MMA fan. Holy Shit.
This is literally as good as it gets.
It just,
just depends on what
version of gain we get.
It's not uncommon in this sport for uh,
you know,
fast rising stars that are
a rising because of their
beastliness and their knock
out power. It's not uncommon for
them to not train Jujitsu. Right.
We've seen plenty of them.
You know what I mean?
How crazy would it be if Zingano
actually trained Jujitsu, right.
And fell. No, we got time for
that. You know what I mean?
We don't know what he does.
Right. We don't know if he
does not over there. Well,
I know when he got in for Steve Bay,
they show you just hit [inaudible] center.
But how loud, if he say he just,
he just went to Danaher's just
fell in love with John Danner.
They just became best friends.
That would be the jumped in I imagine
how good he is. 36 so that would be,
you know what I mean? Up with Jujitsu.
He's how old is, you could only survive,
knock out power for solar.
You know what I mean?
After a while you're going
to be getting clips easily.
Tail Hook guys were killing this show by
talking over each other like this. Yeah,
you're, you're 100% right. You know what
I'm saying is eventually no matter, no.
We see over and over again.
No matter how Beasley you are and how
powerful you are with those punches,
eventually you're going to get clipped.
Right. You're going to go down.
So eventually you might have to switch
your strategy to instead of going out
there and just trying to knock a dude
out to going out there and try to take it
to the town and submit this month where
we go, well, and he's so powerful.
If he had good wrestling skills,
holy shit,
you're gonna find out right is
the thing is like with wrestlers,
don't you think that you have to
learn it at a really young age? Well,
George Saint Pierre
didn't, right? Oh shoot,
ain't got clip on the left
hand right there. Good Damn.
Damn. Look how giant he loves.
So shit dude, he's so big.
He's so big and so dangerous.
Oh my goodness.
Come on man.
He's incredible.
Did he blew his ACL, MCL, LCL.
Something's wrong with
his leg or maybe not dude.
And Cain is one of the best of all time.
That's how good in Ghana was.
Damn. He got through that block. Fuck.
He got through it and a
big
guy I've ever seen,
and it wouldn't have been a surprise
if in Ghana was super cautious.
Maybe two rounds of being super cautious.
We wouldn't be that surprised, aimless,
the aggressor. Chill out, Bro.
But the fact that he fucking threw
down like this, boom, he went, oh,
you almost like forearm. He got
forearmed in the first. The first
to
admit,
no, let's see. This again.
Never got hit anywhere.
Oh Jesus.
Oh Shit.
We saw the fight differently.
Oh Wow.
Everybody missed it. We all missed
this Friday. Then for Caina,
let's be real damn
back injury, and I said this, that
the Lcl, MCL blog gets MCL. Right?
Then when it's bent this way, when
it comes to this, that's all of them.
That's MCO. How old is he
now? I don't know, but he's
a weathered, whatever it is.
There's 37 37
now. I wouldn't even fight. You
could only take so many wars.
Each war is significant in your life.
Like each one took some of your
life and eventually that's it.
You can't, you already, you went to
five crazy wars. That's not that.
That's what Tom or that ended that
way. Well, you know what it is, man.
I think guys that are that
championship caliber like cane,
their mind is so ferocious that their
body is almost like a space ship
reentering. It's missing tiles and
it starts fuck a chicken apart.
There's so powerful in terms of their
ability to keep driving, keep driving,
and then the knees go in,
the neck goes tobaccos and then you deal
with these physical realities of the
body that you're giving. Still
there. [inaudible] still there,
but I know that when I was
saying in the middle of that,
I'm in the middle of trying to come
back. Yeah. You know what I mean?
Right now since my shoulder,
it's been six months in my,
since my shoulder surgery had my
bicep reattached to my shoulder,
had knee surgery about 10 months ago.
That's still not 100% like it's still,
they're not red.
They're still rolling with,
I'm rolling with 130
pound blue belts and shit,
but he read my shit the last three weeks
I've been rolling with some little blue
belts that I gotta be able to have like
50 pounds on them and have total control.
You know at this point,
you know what I mean?
I'm little for Francis and
blown ACL for Kate. Well,
I mean it definitely is a blown knee for
cane, but Francis, when's your fight?
Because like when Francis was
coming after him and he clipped him,
he definitely clipped him with
that forearm behind the neck.
80 or hundred percent. That's a
nightmare. That's a nightmare outcome.
100% cause Francis
just clipped and knocked down.
Do you want to hear about, they say,
yeah. What do they have to say? Yeah,
give me some volume.
I look at the teeth on them.
I don't hear anything.
Good job, Jamie. There it goes.
Okay.
I mean he believes date now.
He did, but I liked it the way
he was moving in on them, man.
I mean he really did look
on that Land Rover at that forum. Did
that forum later in the back of his neck.
You know what man, I'm going to rethink
what I said. I'm going to rethink it.
I know.
I thought I saw his forearm clip.
His neck. He blows it. Wait,
no, no, no, no trouble.
What do you think you did
hit him with that? No,
he kind of felt though before that
he'll Jaynie goes, that's what it is.
That's what it is. And he gets
out just a shit. The thing is,
he's so heavy handed.
I think you might be correct,
but I do think that he connected with
his neck or the guys this heavy handed
that? Nope. Nope. Nothing here.
Nothing. Nothing there though.
Nothing Nigos out. Oh, because
you're right. You're right.
You're right. I was wrong. I thought
it was, I thought it hit his neck.
It did not hit his neck. It hit
his back. Right shoulder. No. Yeah,
here we go. It was clear. There is
that. Here we go. Yeah. Holy Shit Dude.
He was throwing him around.
He's a freak for it to saint gotta.
Yeah,
that's a lineman right there.
A middle linebacker, right?
Well, he's not done. See
the thing about this guys,
he hasn't been fighting for very long
though. Even though he loses to steep.
Bain has that. The timid
performance against Lewis. He says,
so little mileage. What does
it say about his name? Hold on.
Is that that's how it happened. I know
it wasn't the result you're looking for.
It will take some time, but how soon
might we see you back in and you know
they're more calm and relaxed,
so breaking everyone was going to happen
or it's the worst. Very classy.
Yeah. Came very classy. You know,
never bitter.
How weird is it?
The Fox and this one, he's not
even talking about his knee thing.
He's going to retire things.
You're more tired.
No need to apologize. I know I
speak for UFC fans around the world.
That's Cy way, by the way. How good
is, how good is Jon Anik? He's a bass.
That's the best. It's such a
bummer to lose. Wonderful that Jon.
Anik is so good. I love John.
I'm so impressed with him.
Like when I work with him,
he's, he's, he's so like,
he's such a good commentator.
He had the first thing, I'm
going to make sure it ESPN,
MMA, like can I, let me, let,
let, let's look at this was
the shoulders was the, was
maybe an upper cut. Might've landed right
there. Ooh, my right there. Right there.
I'm going to lay in that
upper cut. Might've sat them
down the Opera Cup. Mighty
God. Here we go. It's hard to
tell right way to go again.
Here we go. So nothing, nothing
so far, nothing. Watch this right
here. Right here. Right here.
Oh,
oh,
upper cut yourself.
Can I redeem myself?
Okay, let's see. You are
correct. You're right.
Different anger missed
it. That was a legit, when
I was getting too close,
I was just, cause he,
I forgot he blew his knee out
for sure because the upper cut
down that sat him down.
He knows this is what's important.
This is what's important.
And Matt, Matt Tie,
he has a fantastic article out right now
about one of the problems with society
today is that people look at the
news like they look at sports.
Like someone asks me write about things.
You have to know everything.
But it's a great article.
Matt Taibbi,
this is a perfect example of four guys
who are lifelong martial artists and we
both went both ways. I was like, you're
right. And then we saw it again. Like,
you're right, you're right. That's how
you're supposed to look at Shit. Yeah.
That's how you're supposed look at once.
It
can't be attached to certain fight.
Certain fights, it gets stopped early.
Okay. Tj Answer Huda. I thought
it was stopped early. Don't,
I've talked to people that say they
didn't think it was stopped early and I'm
like, all right, Oh hey, I'll
listen to me. He clipped him. Right.
But I felt like when I watched it that
you got to give a guy a chance to fight
more.
But especially on the,
I'll hear you out in the NFL when they
review plays they review them and one of
the most important things about reviewing
a play is that you have multiple
angles. Yeah, it's all good.
The all, all three angles,
they keep going back to the
first angle we didn't get,
we didn't get a good enough angle
because that right hand was like a ghost
writer. I didn't see it. You
guys saw it. I didn't see it.
Well you know what I say we need them.
So exciting was shit like that is going
on and the UFC truck has the best in the
world. Like mark till the grotto
and all those dudes back there.
Anthony Giordano and the whole crew.
They're always moving.
Mark [inaudible] Mark Tog
Rodney motherfucker. He works,
he figures out what the replacement. I
love him. He's like, he didn't know that.
Take it from the best. I didn't
know that. I fucking love that dude.
He's the shit he's,
he does like,
he'll like pick the play by play angles.
He'll pick like shit and cause
fights because he knows. Yeah.
Todd Feldman Raid Bank off a fucking
Francis by the way. He did big bank. Damn.
I'm telling you dude, if that guy keeps
learning and it seems like he got out,
he had a weird spot.
But you know what I really like about
that weird spot that he got into?
He was honest about it.
He said,
I carried over fear from my last fight
guy who can look at himself that honestly
ego plus his ego got out of control
because he was not going to dude's out and
then that's a good thing.
He said that in an interview like
even as his ego's his coaches,
like he just thought he
was bigger than the game.
Got humbled and now he fucking just
knocked out Cain Velasquez before that he
murked fucking homeboy.
Yup. Chris Blades. Hi.
Can't remember the name.
He looked,
he looked like he was in a
different weight category.
I can't remember the Alaska. He's
the based on your strength, you know,
it is like the future is an
athlete that really at 265 pounds,
it doesn't have to gain any weight.
It doesn't have to lose anyway. Oh,
they're going to show it to us again.
The the future is until we've talked how,
who is this? Her debut a Fox.
Cain gets knocked up by G jds.
Jesus Christ. You have ESPN.
He gets knocked up by Francis.
He took that jab right there to Frances.
Frances clipped him with a Hard Jab.
Yeah. He's so fun. Understand
what you're saying. Okay.
That's a legit point. I
just wanted to be like, oh,
100% some quick fast and gum.
I want to say that again.
I want to look at how fast he is. Back
up just a wee bit. Yes. Out of the play.
This over and over. Let's look. Let's
look at this. The kitchen. We're sweet.
See he hits him.
Nothing fucking right hand shovel.
It's
can we get slow mo is that he hits
him with a right going into the faith.
Pursue, pursue. He said, see you try
one more time. I think his knees. Okay.
Right now. Nah. Hell
No. Ooh. Wait a minute.
That's why I came to him and he goes,
I can't really keep close to sue.
He's so powerful. Watch
this. Watch this. Play,
play, pause, play, pause, play,
pause, play pucks, directv guy.
He gets a VCR in the nineties this angle,
it looks like we're trying to get a TV
in the nineties for sure is a good angle
for in Ghana right here.
Oh right.
Watch this. Watch his head move. Ooh. And
then he got clipped and that's what I,
that's why I came. Did it, address that
and he goes, I got to close too soon.
He's too,
when you,
when you think about a person that might
be like for period the cocaine party
where you're saying you think about
a person like he, you know he's,
he's essentially like optimize
it to 65 or he's optimized.
He's like a fish,
a real to 65 for five
rounds of July is optimize.
Well here's the thing though,
he all he has to do is get better at that
first round and do you really think a
lot of guys are going to make it
into their second or third now?
Just play it in slow motion.
Fuck, I missed this angle.
It looks like you missed this and I don't
really know. He shoveled. Who Know us.
Can we hold on, hold
on, hold on. Slow motion
kind of percent.
That's clips of the hundred percent
says that you see his head move.
That's why I came to throws a single
leg on the ref cause he's concussed.
He went for the single Francis is the
scariest of all time of all time over
ubering. Dude. The thing
about Francis speed, he's,
he's learning at this
like really rapid rate.
When you look at a guy that's only
been doing it for how many years now?
A hundred percent train has
been fighting for two weeks.
He's been fighting for
like maybe five years,
I think five years from the
time he learns martial arts.
His Dad was some legendary fights.
He was doing this with saying, dude,
he's a movie character. If he can
just get over the hump that he got,
look the steep pay me. Oh, chicks
fight. That's what's up man.
I mean he got to the top of
the mount dude. He's fun.
DC now bend your boy k.
Alright. Alright. Michael Jai White Guy.
Like terrified right now
how Francis Michael just to
spawn is huge.
But Francis is a giant.
Francis has giant.
The giant. No, I've trained with him.
He's nowhere near as big short and he's
still played rock. You train with Hoop,
right? Michael Jai white came into a box
somewhere. Maybe he's not as tall spawn
and John knew.
Maybe he's not as tall as him,
but in the movies you could
make them taller. Oh for sure.
Be The permanent jet fighter.
Oh 100% I was kid.
I watch Michael Jai white do a hopping
sidekick on a bag at legends and snap the
chain. The chain broke. You remember
that? He has, he has he ever had? Nope.
He fought. Fought some cute
boy Joey lights in the spawn.
He's legit.
Blackbelt and Cook Shin Flexing nobody.
Nobody is more critical judge of kicking
technique than me. The kicks. Perfect.
He does everything. He's a
monk. 100% legit black belt.
So I'm telling Michael Shy why about
how he's a black male for sure.
This is a real quick, there's a good
story. Let me finish this while he's here.
Michael, I'm telling Michael
Jai white over and over.
I'm trying to explain to him how bad
of a motherfucker Joe is with that turn
inside sidekick. I go, dude,
I'm telling Michael Shy why
all the stories that there's
so many stories of Joe
hitting the bag in front of
traditional martial artists. You know,
nobody can kick the bag.
Like fucking show. Yeah.
Everybody knows that now cause
it's all over youtube at fifth.
But before that I was the one trying
to fucking tell everybody because I'm
hanging out with Joe.
He's kicking the fucker.
That della grout there when he's holding
that thing you were kicking out and
everybody, GSP freaks out when he
GSP freaks out. When Joe Rogan kicks,
I and I knew I had a film this year. So
weird, flexible. You can do the splits.
Let me finish. Let me finish the
story real quick. Let me just finish.
It just seems really crazy. So I'm sitting
there and listen, let me just fuck.
I'm telling Michael's I white all
about Joe Rogan's turning sidekick.
I'm blowing them the fuck up.
Telling him the GSP story that's
on youtube that has a million,
gazillion views. All this shit
everybody knows about us now.
The old taekwondo footage just coming
out when he's fucking, there's a,
there's a a clip with Joe do an attorney
inside sidekick hitting the dude and
the guy drops. You know what I mean? And
George's walks away like he's seen him,
like he's done it a million
times. He's just, you know,
so he's become like this legend. So
I'm telling Michael, shy Hawaiian,
all this at legends and then we walk
up to the fucking the bag. He goes,
I got a pretty good turn inside
kicked too. Oh, she's Atlanta.
This was a real story. He fucking does
this. This was like eight years ago.
He fucking just asked.
Mogens does a turn inside.
Kik blows the bag off the shit.
Hold on a second.
I've done 30 minutes talking
shit about you. I think you are.
I think I was there for the
a hundred percent of it,
but I'm pretty sure he did a hopping
sidekick. He just attorney tech. Nope.
It's all about the attorney was
100% whatever it is. His Texas deal.
His techniques and people,
Bro.
Did he ever do team martial arts or
shitty about deep doing like high level
martial arts?
Like he fought Kilkee shit.
I know he fired like real kill Kachin
fights and not only was I embarrassed
because I just,
and
he just fucking broke precedent.
The first thing I thought was
like, Oh shit. Chris Riley
owned the gym. My, Oh shit.
We got to hide the chain.
We turned it into one of those grappling
bags that you fucking mountain and beat
the shit out of him.
But we had to get rid of the chain and
he looks like a legit athlete. He's
seen in a movie that's Michael Eddy is
talking about kicking bags and shit.
My Hook DIY blocks up to this bag.
Literally chain breaks and it goes flying.
Did you ever see Miss Bondo and
someone said to me afterwards, yeah,
we're having a problem with that chain.
Like shut the fuck up.
It's like you wouldn't have
any problem with that chain.
Can you imagine if I would've just
said, well anyways, chose kick.
Amazing.
I shut the fuck up about you.
I never brought you up ever again.
You went ham on that bag though. Huh?
You some fucking, that's a real story.
People would get up and walk out of
the Goddamn movie if you put that in a
goddamn move. Yeah, I saw
him flying spot. Brian Cowen,
we're talking about one
thing at a time for, no,
I'm just saying like basketball
and nobody is watching this.
Most people have a high teen
went. You know what? Let me,
let me try and hit the Mitts.
He'd beat up everybody.
There's certain athletes and this is
what I'm thinking about Cain and want to
thinking about Francis tonight.
There's certain athletes that if they
can get the mental game into a place,
a lot of Warlick Cain was when he was
at its peak. Yeah. It's all it's about.
It's all about like
how easy is it for you?
How much do you have to work for it?
How much of the reason why you're
successful is because you've built up this
insane work ethic so you have phenomenal
cardio and an ability to push and can
you get a guy who has that
but spectacular genetics,
like how do you get to Michael Jordan?
How do you get a Brock Lesnar heart?
How'd you get,
how'd he get out freak and can you get
that freak to train the way like the best
train Coby Bryant,
can you get that freak,
a genetic freak who has advanced and not
have to say there's a big difference.
Like you might be a great athlete, you
might be a great athlete, but can you,
when you get hit in the face,
when you get knocked out,
what are you like when you, what are
you like the next day at practice?
How much does that get in your head?
I think certain sliders 100% and people
that doesn't deter them and some people
it would know. Talking
to her sparkly, I said,
did you ever want to do play football?
He goes, hey, he goes, he's so big.
And he goes, ha, those guy I
played for one day and I was like,
these guys are crazy. They Bang
into each other. You're just,
I want to cure 100 pounds.
So it happened with Saab costus.
Yes. Where he's like, football's bad.
There's should be Ct. They went, cool,
why don't you sit the
Superbowl out? Yup. His,
his exact words were someone told
him that he crossed a line. Yeah.
Well he is on their
platform and network shit.
That's like you shitting on the UFC.
The UFC would go cool.
That's your belief and
you're probably right,
but we can't have you on our airwaves.
Well,
there's gotta be a way to say that on
your show and you're like talking shit on
them. Well, listen, let me
tell you something. These dean,
Dana White is one of the first
guys to tell people to stop.
He's one of the first guys to tell
people to stop. He told chuck to stop.
He was paying chocolate's not
fight. Don't fight. It goes,
I'll pay you to not fight. I do not
want you to fight. Yeah, I killed.
Tell guys that he can make millions
of dollars off. No, don't fight. Wow.
They make plenty of money. I mean, there's
people that want to fight and there's,
this is where the real philosophical
debate comes in. Like if you think, Gosh,
you're retired,
but he doesn't think he should retire,
but he's going to die some
day and so are you who said,
tell you to say fighters you can and
can't do if you have to say fighters.
You're right, you're right.
And he's right. Everybody's
right. That's the problem.
It's like one of those really
complicated debates where it's like,
what does that mean to
do that? To Brendan? Yes,
but I love him and I knew
he was on his way out.
I knew he was on his way out and I,
I would hope that if I was fighting and
someone was close to me and knew when I,
when I was like really good when
I was doing taekwondo tournament,
who got to a point when I was somewhere
around like 20 or 21 when I realized it
was no future in that and I started
dropping off and one of the things was
because I started training
with other young guys,
they'll like a lot of guys who are doing
kickboxing and boxing and I realized,
oh,
they're doing it the way I used to do it,
but I'm not doing it that way anymore.
It's that they're obsessed really in
the gym all day. They're living it.
And I realized, I was like, you know, I
had met some, some young guys, one kid,
this Guy Dana Rosenblatt and want to
be in New England middle weight boxing
champion had we did a
lot of training together.
He was a really tough kitchen and
find on Tuesday night fights. Yeah,
he fought Vinnie.
Patsy enza twice.
This is rob mutherfucker knocked out Terry
Norris who was obsessed with it. Yeah.
Not Excuse me. Yes he did knock out turn
yours. Um, he was a legit knocked out.
Howard Davis Jr too.
He was legit.
He was the the boxing coach
from American top team.
And you sparred with them a
little bit, right? Yes, a lot.
He beat the shit out of me too.
Did he clipped them though once?
I definitely did that but I hit him.
But the thing is like,
he let me know from sparring
with him that he was,
he was way more focused on fighting
than I was and I used to think I was as
focused as I used to be and then I
realize, oh, I'm not anymore here.
I'm a 20 year old guy
with a bunch of jobs,
so a 21 year old guy with a bunch
of jobs and here's this kid who was,
I think at the time he was 18 he was
kickboxing and boxing and he and I talked
about it. I was like, dude, you just
box. He's like, you think I go, yeah,
you're boxing is fucking
awesome because when we at spar,
that's where he would fuck me up. He would
fuck me up with boxing. I'm like, dude,
there's no money in kickboxing.
There was no money back then. Zero,
but there's some glory pays.
Bella tour pays. You can make money. Lion
fight pays this. There's plenty guys.
It's hard bop computer,
the sports,
but the PKA PKA,
but what I'm saying is that's gen
zero money. You're saying that
kid was super passionate about it.
That's 100% and I was like,
I've got to get out of this.
I'm going to get brain damage.
I'm like,
these young guys are going to fuck me
and spar with them. With kicks. Yeah,
we split. We did Botox, we
kick boxed and we boxed, boxed.
You ever land side kicks on his ass?
Um, we sparred, man. I don't remember.
It was like we were 21 years old.
I'm sure I hit him,
but my take from it wasn't,
you know,
my take from it 100% was oh this guy's
way more focused than I am. Yeah.
I had my foot out the door and so when I
saw that you had your foot out the door,
I was like, shit, he's got his foot
out the door. Thank God you did. Oh,
cause I saw it and was like,
life is so good, right? Yeah.
But I saw it and I was like,
dude, come on. Have a real chance.
A real chance. You have struck
while the iron was hot. Boom.
You had a giant golden opening.
I was like, Dude, you're
funny guy. Like you're a,
you're a fun guy to listen to.
I like hanging around with you.
Other people don't like you too. They're
going to like you on podcasts and do it.
Stand up.
You don't have to get punched in the face.
And he misses fighting every day.
Look at him,
but you can't give that
advice to everybody and a
lot of people got mad at me
for giving that advice. I'm
like, I wouldn't not anybody.
Family members, we love.
Joe saw it and I was like,
oh, this is like fuck.
I'd like a part of your past. You know
what I mean? Like you got some other shit.
I can't believe I did that dude.
I was like,
this is the hill I'm willing to die on.
I know you don't want to be doing this.
No one wants to tell you don't want to
be doing this. No thank you. I love it.
Thank you brother.
Thank you for listening.
Thank you for listening because
instead of like losing a friend,
you know what the noise, I have
a friend grow. It is weird.
I did that for a site like the competitor
came out. I was like, Fuck Joe, man.
Two Oh five and I was dieting training
and I was like, what the fuck am I doing?
I Sunday night shut my
first comedy special.
I knew it was you open. We've got
a good life is great. Perfect.
Lenny's pictures of us,
all three of us. No,
I've never told anybody to do that before,
but I didn't cry,
so let's move up for man.
It's like we love you, man.
You almost started crying when you were
going out there because I'm about to cry.
I fuck this.
I don't know if you miss
fighting or whatever. Just
know. Just like, Oh God. Okay.
What's crazy is I did,
I did stand up comedy people hang out
with Joe back then once Roy Nelson Cro,
Cro, cop fight that. How crazy is
this? Amazing. Amazing. I knew it.
I knew you could do it because you have
a pro athletes work ethic applied to
something that you really enjoy.
You might be doing comedy
comedian 100% I'm like,
no,
you know what? If you,
I'm going to be honest,
I'd go Brett and got a lot of size on
I love,
I wouldn't be the Joe Rogan Latin fucking
turning sidekick. Look at me right
then and decided to fight Joe.
It hit me.
He kills both of us if it
ended up on the ground.
No ways Brennan going to be able
to finish. Joe. No one. Really.
You don't think so impossible.
Let me, can I just say one thing?
Joe got to be what you got to worry
about. Joe, Eddie, Eddie, Joe.
Is anyone else? Samara talks
about himself and the Joel. Fuck.
Excuse me sir.
Can I just have to say one thing?
I know I have seen brand new
shop with the, some of the best.
He's just two guys in the world
and I've watched him tap them every
12 seconds and I'll tell you the names
afterwards, some money, and
you're going to go like, listen,
I saw Brendan a hundred percent stall
out with Cyborg and getting his guard and
go to the ground with him
purposefully called the
[inaudible]. This is no way. No,
listen, I'm not dogging
your to stop it. If not,
he would crush me like a bus
stop. Got Moist towns, big team.
I, I gave him his black. Here's what,
here's where I'm at at. He know what?
He's joking. Tap me out right now. If
we're debtors, I wouldn't give a fuck.
Good for you and working on new material.
I don't give a
fantasy world to that.
Let me be honest.
I've never tapped anybody who was any
good anywhere near as big as he was
spreading shop. Take the best in
the world. It wouldn't happen.
This physical advantages that people
have that are so, they're so stunning.
They're so stunning that it's
creepy. Brendon has the reach I, I'll
give you a name when I tell you the name.
He's a giant. Yes. People that
they get ahold of you. It's,
it's confusing. I watched
Roy. I'm going to be honest,
he ain't got no cardio.
Any shops in the 600 pounds for rags.
You can't talk over each other.
I'm trying to tell you,
I'm trying to give you props.
I'm saying I'm going back to Brennan Cause
I know Brendan's and fucking Colorado.
He's in the fucking mountains.
I will listen to me.
Listen to me. He tried new material
about being a backstreet boy,
puts it really well.
He puts those yoga mats on his hips and
does like 500 pound fuck thrusts. Yeah,
I'll just settle down bro.
He's a different kind of person.
It's a different kind of humor.
That's what I'm saying.
I know the difference between,
you always got no chance, man.
You know how many times I saw him get
through around and I want her to give him
advice on what he did wrong. He was like,
shut up. And I'm like, I can't breathe.
Breathe right down to it.
That's an interesting thing.
I've never done more cardio in my life.
I do cardio like super record cause
those fills you run or no joke. Your boys
had aerosol. Helped me out. Them get
there. My car. Did you finally get one?
Microsoft? I love, no, my cardio was,
my cardio was always the worst part
of my Jujitsu game. When you got,
when you got somebody in a fuck in the
truck and you put a crotch rep or on Joe
would just read through people's legs.
It's a crotch ripper. It's uh, it's a,
it's like a banana split
and and rescue team. Yeah.
But it's a little different than legs are
spread differently. Uh, Joe, her bucket,
the master of that motherfucker crushed.
He scratched me.
But it's awful submission because it gets,
it goes against your hips.
Are there any other comedians who like
wrestled or anything like that? I'm on.
It's just a really good wrestler.
He's really good. He teaches.
We wrestled the same houses there at the
company more and Jay. Mark can wrestle.
No, no, no. Jay Moore can
wrestle around with Jay a little,
but people tell me that Jay Moore
actually has coach wrestling. Well,
Jay Morris not. I know he's not. He's
all right. But he's never coast it. Look,
coach Jay wasn't a real wrestling.
Jade.
Jade heard cook can. I'm just being, oh my
God. Look at this. Crash on TV. Holy Shit.
Oh my God. Look at all
these cars. I, oh my God.
I thought walls at the moon.
It's round Eddie. That's fake.
This whole thing is fake.
The crash. Fake look.
They know the laws don't
work. Oh man, this shit. Oh,
look at this pile up to look at this.
This is insane.
These guys calling you think, uh,
202 miles an hour. So true. Yeah.
She was great on the podcast. I like
this. A really, really, really nice guy.
And talk about a guy who's
had some problems with
concussions. 1000 concussion.
Dale Earnhardt, man, he had to go to
rehab for this fucking crash. Man.
You're all different crashes
flat in the same day. Oh my God.
In the same day.
That's what the fuck is
a really,
they sharpen up 100% watch.
Do you watch it?
Take the family to the raceway at good
night. Three, four crashes. Let's take it.
Let's take a guess. Let's Google it.
Eddie, what's your guesses? What's that?
Do you think there's a crash? No, no, no.
I believe Jamie cause he's from Ohio.
Daniel Watch. I'm going to go with James.
I think Jamie's correct watches now I
will say most and in some kind of a crash,
Colorado, all that shit. It's all the
same guys. All the same dude who won it.
Cause I could give two fucks.
Racing is a weird thing.
Imagine taking your family to spending
200 bucks on the race and there's no
crash and average of 220 crashes per year.
It's through how sheets.
Maybe show the race every day.
If they raced every weekend,
that's a shit load of crap.
I'm going to close.
Don't worry us every weekend. So,
but to the, to the main guys, coffee,
counting all the amateur races,
Jesus talking about the
assholes in the back burner.
That scars the top demolition.
Then boys make bank though. Huh?
Just left turns all day.
A lot of money.
Is there racing that goes the other way?
Do they ever say a good question?
Is there, is that piece so
hard? Probably in, in uh, some,
well, the real racing is Formula
One, correct? My boy. Yeah.
Well that's a different thing. You know,
I was watching the, there's a, on youtube,
there's a video of an overlap
between a gt three car,
which is like a Porsche like Brendan
has and a Formula One car. It's like,
Geez, strikes, there's so much faster. You
watch the GT three car, you're like, oh,
that guy's flying. And then you see
the Formula One car. I see that.
Do you have a video? Yeah,
there's a video of it.
See if you got online comparison between
Formula One and gt three t three it's
like a Porsche. Do you know how big
Talladega nights the sequel would be?
Oh, motherfuck. Right. Especially if
they can get bore out to jump on board.
Are you kidding me, Bobby? He was
amazing. Who's better than John C.
Reilly and and remains a feral
when they're together. She,
I know it's fucking magic. Yeah,
it might be it. Look at that.
Look at the difference.
So get this si the one in the left and
one of the right leads and one on the
right. The one of the rights
flowing. Your one left, his GD three.
It's fucking crazy. The difference
here, that car and then watch it. Look,
it was faster. Oh Shit. Oh my God.
Is real racing. That's why Europeans
think Americans are goofy. Fuck.
Nd you're marsh. That's
Formula One. Formula One.
Basically you're like sitting on a
missile. Well, they're also honest.
If you see it's a changing course,
like the course to Formula One course
has a lot of turns, right? I mean, what,
give me see if you could get a a,
a map of,
it's like an like a crazy track
when a NASCAR's just a circle.
Exactly. Exactly. Nascar's look or
an oval. Right? When people say, I,
I do have street courses. I don't
usually do it though. What is a,
what's an average formula? Like
pull up a famous, what's a,
what's a famous formula? One
race. They have a bunch, right?
Sure. Uh, I know there's a
famous formula one race, Mario
Andretti. Famous Formula One race.
Race her, right? No race. A
race isn't the one in Monaco.
Isn't that one?
Do you know what that one's called?
Grand Prix de Monaco
turns in it. Yeah. Okay.
Let me see what that looks like. Let's
see what that looks like, Jamie. Hey,
this grateful man. That shit.
Look at all those turns.
God Damn. Those are crazy. Look
at the upper right hand corner.
Like a fish's mouth.
Look at that crazy turn like an eel face.
Like the Nascar thing is why
don't they want all that shit?
Cause they want to be able to see
the whole race from whether city.
I think it's because
here you can't see shit.
You're sitting formula for the
cars to pass by. Like this sucks.
That's why there's nobody there.
There's like four people standing there.
You wonder what the car just race.
I get it.
Those fucking country
guys think you're right.
You're right to get to see. It's like, aw,
he's right. Are you listening to and
fucking tense and shit may have barbecues.
Yeah,
to get see 30 seconds of car.
Meanwhile, the country, they're
the ones that are geniuses.
This wreck happened this
year and the girl fucks up.
I had someone die. I don't want
to say no. She broke her neck.
She's back though. She's pretty hot
too. She's still racing shell. Yeah,
she's back right now.
Broke man. That she just,
maybe there was just bone spurs in there.
Oh my God.
She's wearing flies into the wall.
Flew into the wall. She's young too.
She's all right though. She's only 17
she races formula one. He's not legal.
Fuck Dude.
How crazy is that?
Her parents got assigned sign for
that Shit for sure. Go to school
for the other one is so expensive, like
just to have more expensive. Does it?
Wow.
How come so much fucking European pricing?
Some tellers in the Rothschilds? Is
that what they do? It's like it is
even Nati dude.
How couldn't it be? It would be,
what if it was, I know it is.
What if it was would it is?
It's just a quick Google search price to
run it or not a for me the one racist.
What the fuck are you saying Jamie?
Hold on.
Listen to Jamie here for a moment please.
I just quickly Google search to an average
team costs anywhere between 20 to 60
million for Nascar.
Yeah,
for f one it's anywhere between
200 and it's around 250 million.
It says first expensive.
Yeah,
and those like red bull,
Mercedes, Ferrari, Porsche.
Those boys make bank to you.
Hey Buddy.
Daniel Lewis Hamilton.
How it Lewis Hamilton was a mixed family.
His Dad would fucking work like three
jobs just because it's so expensive as kid
to do it. He's like, I'll pay for it, but
he got a, when he got a fucking winning,
if I'm going to do this, knows about it,
but it's fuck, there's so much money.
America,
America doesn't know about it.
My brother does guys,
we've got to stop talking about,
no, go ahead. No Buddy.
There's no like nope.
Kids aren't into formula one racing.
You're born into like the Vanderbilt, the
fucking airman's. You know what I mean?
They don't,
there's the masses are not into this shit.
You and I are not getting a chance,
but is that a newer one?
That's only in America, right?
In Europe. It's very funny.
The kids don't give a fuck about
that shit in Europe. Fuck up.
The two kids, they love
it. They love it. I think
that's incorrect. I think, oh
you're the Rockefellers are into it.
I think that's incorrect.
They like it in Australia as well.
As somebody who grew up overseas, I can
promise you they kits in the Middle East.
Express your rich dad and my,
my father is a Vanderbilt. Damn,
it's so popular area at Santa. So
Senate, let's look at centers. Funeral,
bring up areas, funeral in
Brazil. He died. He was the best.
He was the best.
And take a look at how many people
showed up for his funeral in Brazil.
Take a look at this place. Oh
yeah, it's inquiry. Jackson eraser.
Yeah he was,
he was on TV.
Like he got his son who
races now I believe.
So he was the greatest
and he was such a monk.
He wouldn't even hang it in the near
West. We would, he was like a matador.
He only, he only thought about
racing and he's a beast dude.
And I think a thing went through his,
look at that. Look at that funeral.
Everybody came out. Hold on
buddy. Boy. Amazing documentary.
Cause it's called Santa. You can get
it on iTunes. Netflix maybe. I Dunno,
maybe it's on that. Why is
everything Netflix with you?
It might not. I'm not sure.
I'm not sure. But I got it off of
iTunes. It's fucking incredible, man.
We see the footage. It's nice guys,
man. It's, it's just like, I mean,
you're living your life on these split
second decisions and controlling some
impossibly powerful vehicle
when you're going around.
He's fucking turns and
everything's happening so fast.
And this guy just had this lightning
precision ability to make decisions.
He was a hero. Well, it's
like Dale Earnhardt jr when
his, when his pappy died,
then they fix the car. So no one's really
died. What's his dad died? They're like,
we need to fix this shit. And now there's
all sorts of safety stuff in it. It's,
um,
that was a fascinating conversation
about how many concussions that guys had
because I never would've thought of
that. How many did he have? A ton.
He had to forget to do rehab for a bunch
of Rehab and he had like moments where
we're like, for six months he was just
a mess. Andy Stone, uh, like he, he,
he's had so many concussions because they
would blast doors and he would be the
one to set the charge. Now,
all his friends are hanging
Haydn and he'd be like,
where the fuck am I going to go?
[inaudible] he's had over like 201 that
Kevin will got shot in the hip. Can't,
can't feel his, his foot from the
why is he staying with you right now?
Because he had no, he had place to
stay but I go stay with me. What the,
what are you doing? I got, you
know, to have a fucking bad day.
When we were on the man
show we had a sketch
that got declined. It was about an
Asian Nascar driver. Oh that's right.
It was blowing up because he was just
always racking and tolerance drove the
ratings up so they, everybody wanted
out cause he would just sketch.
It would have to have an Asian guy.
Right? Like if Bobby Lee wrote that,
it would be cool. But the most
epic rallies, people loved him.
What do we got here? We're
watching golf. How dare us.
She never played the shit.
Played it. I played a lot,
a lot. Big happy plays right
once a year and a cheer camp,
but they can't wire tap you out. And
the fact that golf course, you know,
that's why that's what all those
rich people, they're out there going.
I'm glad you guys agreed that you
have the same view on politics.
How we control shit. Yeah,
that's just an excuse.
Is there a one game that symbolizes more
like really super rich dudes out there
making deals playing a game like golf?
They literally tell you if you want to
succeed in business that people tell you
what it should learn how to play golf.
Tell us how it happens.
He doesn't go out there
playing golf up business.
Just the magic theoretically like,
oh Jay,
if I'll tell you I'll make all the stores.
How does it go down?
A good story for you. Tell me about
it. So my mother and my father,
this guy comes out to play golf with my
father who was a big investment guy and
he wanted my father who
invest in his company
in this investment from whatever thing is,
this is 19 2090 1990 Yup. Yup,
Yup. 1990 and my he, they got to
play golf in Greenwich, Connecticut.
My mother watches him.
Everybody cheats at golf,
but my mother sees him kick the ball just
a little bit into a better lie because
it he, he was in a taller grass, kicked
the ball on to like shorter grass.
We'd get a better swing. Here's the
difference. When I do that, I go,
I'm kicking the ball and he did it,
but he looked around and make sure
nobody was watching. My mother,
Sicilian girl from New
York City just went,
snake, she's a fucking snitch, bro.
Mother goes, wow. That guy just cheated
secretly and it's a bullshit games.
She goes, bad guy. She says, my father got
the hatch. She goes, she goes, watch it.
She goes, what did they say in this thing?
That guy's a crook and my father goes,
bullshit. She goes, if you do, I'm
going to divorce. My father goes, Jesus,
you're really serious. She was
all divorce. You. Well, Hey,
what if you were playing chicken
guy, went to jail, guy went to jail.
I 15 years like I was.
Donald Trump was a huge deal.
I'll tell you his name afterwards,
but it's a huge,
he was a huge fucking scam artists.
He was one of those guys in the news.
Everything else, that whole thing.
Everybody who invests, who went broke,
he don't do shit. Her
Mama talents a snitch.
You know that guy? You
know that guy. Gosh.
Okay. So, okay, so what, use the little
things in life you can pick up here.
Perfect example,
Eddie.
Remember there was one time where Eddie
met this guy and the guy just started
doing Jujitsu,
like he was a white belt and he called
Eddie up and he told that he, yeah,
I got a bunch of guys, I'm like triangle
today. Armbar guy. And he was like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
And like, you knew like right away,
like this is this guy's full of shit.
Like triangle a bunch of people and
arm bar people. It's your first day.
You don't even know how to do
those things. I didn't hear,
but he knew right away like Eddie and
talking to him, he was like, what?
Because the only reason he started
doing Jujitsu is because we were,
he wanted us to cope,
promote some kind of martial arts event.
And I didn't know,
I didn't know if he was a legit
promoter nod. He seemed really cool.
He knew some cool, he knew some
people that I knew and he was, he had,
he wanted to do this show and he was going
to involve me in it and it, you know,
then he came down to my school and,
uh,
and after one class he's telling me the
next day, oh, I fucking loved it man.
I triangle the couple of guys fucking
arm bar. I'm like, wait a minute,
first day ever. He goes, yeah. So crazy
just comes natural to me. And I thought,
shit, maybe I shouldn't go into
business with this. Exactly.
So right there I was like,
I got to back out now.
This is my fucking line about Gigi.
He'll lie about everything else. And so,
um, that came a time where I
had to sit him down, you know,
but it was ugly and kick
him out of the Joe and I,
Joe and I are there ever since we were
like we'd known each other through a 28
and we just be talking and then like I'd
say something I like, yeah. I was like,
I don't know. I, I do. Yeah. I,
uh, thought whatever it might be.
Like I tapped him out. Now I'm like,
not really, you know, whatever we'd say,
are you telling a little white lie?
Cause you're just, you're just,
it's convenient and you have to walk
in. You're like, math didn't happen.
But it's a weird thing when
people make shit up though. Yeah.
He was a Kung Fu champion.
Travel Okinawan fun everyone
bare knuckle where it was a fun,
that was a lot of those guys.
When I first opened up 10th planet,
this was 2004,
there was a girl that trained there and
she just started turning their shoes or
like a crossfit type chick.
She was like buff and she just started,
she's like six months into it and she
starts telling me that she tapped uh,
one of my purple belts and she's
105 pounds. I'm like, damn,
I know what you tell we tab Cade say that.
And I said,
okay,
cause I don't want people to have like
a false sense of security in Jujitsu.
You got to know it was, you
can't, if someone, if you,
sometimes when you go with the kid,
you let them take an arm bar.
You know what I mean? You let them when
their kids, but when they're adults,
if you do that to them, they're going to
actually think they really tapped you.
They're not going to know. Some of them.
Southern mom will say, oh he let me,
he's being, he's gone. Like he let me,
he's going like some will go, fuck,
I'm tapping these motherfuckers
out and I'm a bad motherfucker.
Yeah.
And this girl totally thought that.
Well I remember when I first learned to
man, I was a little confused. I was like,
what's happening here?
My actually tapping this person.
This doesn't make any sense.
I figured it out pretty
quick and the girl called me,
the girl called me and said,
hey listen, I'm excited.
I just won first place in my division
and second place in absolute call back on
an Italian up calm.
She was so excited.
She won first place in her division
and second place in absolutes.
How many matches do you think she won?
Two zero.
Oh well did everybody forfeit
division?
Cause no one showed up.
Know she had one match in
absolute and she lost. I'll see
wonder division and she got the second
and the lesson she was acting like she
wanted a lottery. There
was a girl crying and shit.
There was a guy when I date
like it's insane. American idol.
Weird. I tell people do that. Like I said,
I went on a date with a girl and she
was weird. We want on a, and I was like,
this is weird. Just did Cynthia. She
was just weird, just a little zany.
And then I get a call from
her a year later and she
goes, um, make sure you watch.
It was like a show. Like the practice
was, I make sure you worked prior to that.
Why? She goes, um, because my
hands are in it and I put like,
I push a door, I'm not
kidding. And I go, I go,
I started laughing. I mean, yeah, right.
I go, well my hands are, my hands are,
you'll see my hands.
And I pushed her.
I'm just calling my friends Tom Cause
that's like my first team. I go, I go,
you got to get out more or their hand
after you got to get out. More goes,
why don't I go?
You can't go.
You can't tell people that you
can't call people. She goes,
I have my whole family. Watch it when
he's talking about is my first time.
And to be, I guess it's
not, it's your hands.
Cause I guess Glenn close to somebody
who was going to push the door,
but they used her hands instead. Well,
she's not going to do a cleanse. And I go,
I go, you can't. You can't
tell me. It was true.
I was so excited and she's a good person,
but I was in her name.
And you can't tell people that.
You can't tell them because
they're going to think it's weird.
And some people just don't have a gauge.
Maybe for how weird might be a big
deal to them. The you don't like.
You're on all these big Josh and
know that that's not a big deal.
She comes from a small town. She's like,
look, those are my huge part of it.
A huge part of success is knowing
when you suck and when you're good.
That's not a matter of sucking your
goodies and matter of not being that
important a moment,
but for likes you.
She thinks maybe you'd want to see her.
Oh, that's my friend Alice. His hands. No,
we hadn't come.
[inaudible]
everybody may be or warm. Maybe
she's trying to reconnect. You
know I was number 78 I wish that was true.
Maybe she was Tracy
being stupid. It's too, she wasn't enemy.
I'm promising a well-read,
handsome gentleman with a real six pack
without either real career and she just
trying to fuck.
She likes strange widdled
down wrists and hey man,
don't say anything on my wrist,
but I'm sensitive about that shit.
Protein pokey risks as
you took your shirt.
I'm an idiot. I'm an
idiot. How ridiculous.
And I took my shirt off and I was throwing
punches and see your friends, man.
The only difference is you're better at
being a person than you were when you
were 32 or 22 or it's all
just stuck in your ways. No,
you're better at being a person.
You're better at doing it with like
the least amount of fucking stress.
More friendly in life.
You better at life,
but at the end of the day you're just a
person. It's all the same shit. Shred.
Did he have, what? Does the obliques,
a six back route or route not even
show it. Take Root. Yeah, he wouldn't.
It just when guys pulled
their sweat pants down too. I
know Dan has a couple
of pictures like that.
Comedians do that
take it as a totally normal.
It's a weird thing that you know,
it's kind of grown.
I think it's going to go the way of the
bell bottom. Personally. It doesn't make,
no one shows it. Now this guys are
still slinging it. There's this
game. They're still wearing fucking
affliction and the game his dick, I can't,
I don't have to show his dick.
He's at fat day.
I want to let you guys know that I
coopt I'm, that's my term Dick Route.
I invented that shit until the lexicon.
You know my boy Brett aren't
says that guy's got a good root.
It's aggressive route, but that's a
different thing. That's different.
He's talking about the fiscal tick itself.
He's talking about the root is the
base like the bottom of the treat bro.
Like where the League is. Good thing
in DC are clear in that picture.
He's got a Mac book or being
clear on the right there.
Well you know they're skyping them in man.
That's the difference between like ESPN
from decades ago and now people don't
give a fuck. I think about how many
youtube videos that people watch it.
They're all going and you and shit.
They don't care.
They want the information and your
core me a talk. What's going on?
You got to fight Frankie.
I think he needs good production
options. You know? He's like,
you need to see Washington Post.
He's going to defend his back
again, brother. Wow. He's,
he's DC versus Francis would be
Faulk and crazy still calling DC.
Wow. Really? I don't bet against DC.
It's hard to bet against and
gone. No, that guy really,
I mean you could tell how much stronger
you Jon Jones usually cane throws people
around but he couldn't throw.
This dude came from kinds of strategy.
John John would beat friends. Let me
tell you something Jones. Yeah. Wow.
I bet.
$5.
John's on another level now or something.
$5 don't mean that.
The thing about if you get a DC fort,
Francis DC would not eat. You know
he, he has more options. He's,
he's healthier than Cain is.
Right.
He's got more options in terms of the
way he moves. 40 also. Yeah, he is.
But also he's got success at
heavyweight against Steve Pay.
He's won the Strikeforce Grand Prix.
I mean he threw trash down at around
like he was a fucking tank man.
He was a tank when he was in
Strikeforce at two oh five you know,
it may very well be that he
fights at its best at heavyweight,
him in John Five you wait because
dcs power heavyweight wake up.
We've never seen John Heavily.
I don't want to see them at light heavy.
We've seen how that works out. It's just
not, it would be a phenomenal fight.
It heavy heavyweight heavyweight. It'd be
phenomenal. But this guy at heavyweight,
this is, that's the scariest
one. I find John Scarier.
Ooh, I find John Scared. I think
it'll be like a DC avenging.
His brother's lost. Oh, there it
is. There going to be ended up,
the DC's going to retire in March.
He says when he turns 40 which Dana's
might shut your fucking mouth if they keep
cup when I say so here's your
money pulls out that John.
Here's Brock. There's John
or here's Frances. Yeah. Wow.
Impressive.
Just from his stature as the
most impressive fighter to
ever step in the octagon.
In terms of what he has to work
with as far as being five, nine,
five, 10 minutes. He's,
he's told them that he's,
I think he's five 11
you see at least five,
10 let's say five 10 let's give it a five.
10 year righties below six feet tall
and he's a tank and shoulders are narrow
and just takes and his base undefeated.
Except for John Jones. It's astonishing.
It's, he saw Jason. Jamie could
find out right now. But you,
the Google doesn't count
for height and weight. Yeah.
Instagram hit me standing next to
him. It's so weird. He's outstanding.
UFC fuck the UFC. How he's still
here now. You could only put shank.
You could wear high heels guys.
Fred SIPOC.
Carmen at six five he's
six to shake shaker.
I'm pretty sure it's like is probably
the shortest heavyweight champion in the
history of the sport. Right? Oh, he's
a hall of fame right there in Ghana.
Well that'd be nice to say it like 10
times more muscular than that dude and
God, I was a real true,
unusual person. Oh Shit. Snap.
You just want thing. I don't give
a fuck bouts. College basketball.
I don't care either.
But it's weird though,
when you see these
markets and understand it.
When you see these athletes like like a
Lebron James who's like a clear top of
the food chain freak. When you,
when you see one of those guys,
you see more of those guys and things
like basketball and football clearly.
Right? What do you mean more? You mean
to all of them? All of them, right?
What are the numbers? So it's not all,
but what do you think it would be honest.
Yeah. Yeah. Freaks. We're
the freaks and the MBA.
Mba has the biggest free NBA.
Nfl. Let's just add them all.
Let's go three gas free and alignments go
off three together. How about your boy,
your corn Fred Fan, you Brett brought
to San Diego. Who's that? Jackie. Okay.
That gigantic gentleman. He's from
another gene. Cool. I don't know.
Fucking super nice guy.
Skinny right now. So big.
She has legs and has the worst
that you've ever seen. Football,
fast food every day.
This is the perfect example because this
is a to hitting each other all day long,
different sport. They're tackling
each. Wow. You know what I mean?
There's swells up freaks and bolts,
Herschel Walker freaks in the NBA
and the green down the freaks.
Two guys that are just throwing balls.
There's some freaks,
different kind of beast right there,
guys with the ball.
Nobody tackling him against a guy that
where there's people trying to kill you.
It's the nature of the sport.
But as far as pure athletic ability,
NBA has the biggest freaks in the world.
Wow. Tallest guys is what you mean.
Although like all over.
So you have these specimens,
you have these specimens,
the same day Lewis,
you have these specimens to stand
out and almost every sport. Right.
And Brock Brock Lesnar is
a great example of that.
What basketball play
can fuck with Ray Lewis?
Name One and what asked me
what we were just fighting.
No, no, no. You did as a castle.
Hey Eddie were talking about before and
if you did it to Kathleen of all the
athletes from NBA, NFL, Nhl. No,
no I don't. I'm a football guy.
The NBA beats all of them in terms
of like ton of raw food. Yeah,
like speed jump, no. Everything Jill.
Annoying. It's basketball by far.
So let, let's just say dominating another
man. But let's just say, let's just,
let's just say, let's go, let's
go NFL. Let's go NBA, UFC.
Just narrow it down to those three. Yes,
he's waiting. But what are the, right,
but what are the
percentages of real freaks?
Like the Brock Lesnar type freaks
in the and the NFL and NBA.
Who gets the most, who gets the
most NFL and what does that number
get down to the UFC to 10% is
it 22% of Tutsis freak athletes?
Wow.
And I'd say nine or 6% fell felon.
Nine 9% and below you're a
freak because unusual. Hugely,
hugely unusual in every facet. Like,
Oh, you look at a Lebron James,
you look at mean fill in the blank.
There's,
there's a bunch of guys and
majority player he played in there.
You look at all the fuck golden
state warriors to creek free. Jack
Three. Yeah. Yeah. Height
is important. And basketball
because basketball for sure,
but I mean I'm an Irish fight and
football too. Well, you know when
you're talking about fighting,
football's a way more violent encounter
and people that would like be probably
better at fighting would be drawn to that.
More of a freak to be in that more
of a violent sport has a mass port.
Especially to be like super competitive.
Every cell is way higher than the NBA.
Well here's the other thing too. It's,
wait,
there's way more on the line is way more
on the line in regards to in the NFL
physical punishment.
Exactly.
But that's watch flooded cause you're
willing to run into a wall or get punched.
It doesn't mean that that's how
you're ready. Separate roles.
But we need super athletic guys to survive
in this sport. But here's the thing,
so important in the UFC going on, there's
not enough money. But here's the thing.
What if, what if those guys are still
trickling over there nodding the UFC?
Why would they trickle over the jail?
Well because they think that they could
educate chance at controlling their
destiny fighting than they would if they
think 20 years colliding with people
all the time when the football field
thinking about colliding with people,
it's like, I really feel like
certain guys like look at Ryan Bader,
his last few fights,
I mean they were talking about this,
they were talking about this
in the belt or broadcast.
I got the guy barely got
hit and like three fights.
He won the heavyweight Grand Prix and
punch against worldclass competent much
money you make. I don't
know. That's a good question.
I'm sure you've made a shitload of money
football player to be begging like 10
million a year.
But the thing is like he controlled
his destiny in these encounters,
which I don't think you totally can
and football, but still Ryan Bader,
the money he makes and the
longevity and all that,
is that as a fraction where
the NFL or NBA hundred percent.
So you might be the most
famous guy in the world,
but there's the guy who's the third string
quarterback on the San Diego chargers
who makes more money. Exactly. No, you're
right. I'm 100% with Earth's train.
Third string stuff.
They only carry two and then these
days it's just an exaggeration.
Wouldn't you rather be the guy
who controls his own destiny?
Like the thing about like, oh,
because for every guy, sorry,
judged for every guy that
controls his destiny.
A lot of those guys are fucked over
because you have a pension to Indiana.
Well pastry to college and
there's a blueprint. Pop water,
high school. I'm good. I get
a college education. I'm good.
I get drafted. In effect,
he made $150,000 flat
and then he made taxes.
That's a punk ass. Yeah. What
do you think you made, um,
with its sponsors and shit cause
you belt or you can do this policy.
Let's say me $250,000 on top of that
all to all told a hundred grand.
Wow. That's about it. Huh?
He's a world champion.
He's a double champion. Yeah.
Yeah. He's a world champion.
Light heavyweight and heavyweight over
there. That's a weird thing, right?
That world champion thing.
It's almost like no one should be able
to just remember they tried to do that
shit with fader.
They tried to give him the Wilma.
They gave him the go wham world,
the Wham a championship. I was that.
They invented a Wilma
and everybody was like,
why did you call it hey were you when
you were watching cro cop or last night I
thought, are they a new cro cop paid? Wow.
That run through your mind is coke ups.
First I belts I went,
I put two can do set up cro,
cop fade or I watch this shit or hate
and the shit if they both sit and that's,
that's where I'm at with those guys.
Right.
Like if they still want
to do a coke cro cop,
Avi competitor wants to do the baby.
You still want to talk about a fighting?
Well it'd be hard.
I would really want to talk to some.
Joey EOL was great cause
I knew Joey in a new URL.
Like when Joey and Eol we're together
and Joey was like translating back and
forth. That was great. But I would
have to really know someone real well.
Who spoke? Russian friends. Any
Russian spies? Callen Columbia dead.
Carolyn's got some connections meet by.
We got to go to the beach and pick up a
bottle with a message and they say fate
or his favorite place. There's red
lobster and his favorite clothing stores.
Abercrombie,
which I find fascinating.
That smell and plus them pretty faces
on the lookout recovery. Not For me.
I go to the law. What do you look
for? Starbucks down the street.
Starbucks.
Starbucks gun to your head.
You're going to one store. Nordstrom's.
Dan, what about Bloomingdale's?
No Bra.
They're nice too.
Conspiratorial jeans. I went in
there to buy my wife some jeans.
I'm like, God dammit. These motherfuckers
are 400 cheap. What are your sense?
Has higher quality clothing
shop good
before you leave this podcast, you're
less of a human. No, it's okay. It's okay.
I don't want to talk to you guys. Hate me
for it. You know what I want. I want one.
One example at why we should believe
the earth is flat. That's what I want.
You son of a bitch.
You want it so bad and I am high drunk.
You guys want that to as long as
it's a joke and it's funny, I'm cold,
it gets angry. It's not fun.
I'm not married to that.
I'm not married to it
convinced me that it's flat.
There's no way I could do that. God
really? There's not one example.
It takes about a year and a half and
like wanting to have this too much.
Very hard. They locked urination so
strong. You look at your sons cartoons.
It's all space. I look at all my
shit, all the shit my son likes,
his everything is,
they're taking space.
Still doing research on this
currently in space space.
Want to direct everyone
to Hashtag spaces fake.
I've been doing research and space being
fake. Is that real? That's a real site.
Hashtag spaces fake is something
I'm investigating for my next hour
for legitimately looking deep into
like what space do you dumb motherfucker.
It's the same thing. You got it
all wrong. You got it all wrong.
This is not very organized.
Know what I'm saying is you
couldn't have it all wrong. Nobody.
Anybody that thinks the earth is flat,
they totally don't believe what
we're taught about what's above us.
So to bake in the sun,
they mean all the
information we're getting.
You're lying about that shit that,
it's not that it doesn't exist.
Of course it exists. We see of course,
but space is fake. Sounds ridiculous.
Like there's, there's, I'm not
looking at it and it's it. It's fake.
That's ridiculous.
That's not what it means.
It means that all the information we
got to buy, all the lights in the sky,
something alive. They're
lying. They're line too.
There's a reason that I tell you,
but you guys would don't want to hear it.
Hold on. So I don't want to
talk to give us the cliff notes.
The cliff notes are man,
ah,
have you studied any kind of a,
he doesn't need to be. Let's hear.
Just so few of us.
The goal has always been for the
most powerful emperors is a one world
government. Always wanted a one world
government. All of the Roman emperors,
they try to figure out, they tried to do
different combinations. How about him?
And they would fall. And they were a new
emperor would come and go, you know what?
I'm going to fucking rule domination.
I'm not going to let my
soldiers get married that way.
We'll have a stronger army.
They have different philosophies.
Everyone believed different shit, but
they all wanted a one world government.
There's no way to have a fucking
Walmart with government it.
Nobody's into that shit.
Not even other rules from small countries
or like one world government that's
going to put me out of a job.
Fuck your one world government.
People don't know shit about politics.
Don't want a one world government.
There's no way you're going to sell the
one world government. It's impossible.
The only way,
the only way to make a one
world government work is
to have the people embrace
it. They have to want it
because nobody wants it.
So the trick is to make, to make
people want it, to embrace it.
There's only one way I got to pee.
There's only Miss Alice. I noticed.
I don't know. The only way, and the known
this forever, the Vatican knew this,
the Vatican, the pope water to
rule the world. They all knew it,
but they couldn't do it. They all
knew it, but they knew one way,
but there's no how they're
going to put it on man.
The only way is if there was some extra
terrestrial threat from up above us,
that would be the only way to have
everyone embrace the one world government.
They all knew that for years. That's
the plan. They can never make that.
They didn't have the technology 500
years ago. The Vatican knew about it,
they wanted it, and you go to
the Vatican, you see paintings,
that paintings of like,
have you met those with aliens in them
and back when I used to believe in Ufos,
but before I figured out that um,
Ufo is where are they want
us to believe in Ufos.
They're preparing us for a fake alien
invasion. That's always been the plan.
A one world government, the only way
to do it is to get us to embrace it.
And the way to embrace it
is from an alien attack.
Ronald Reagan talked about
it many times at the UN CFR.
He talked about it because one it make,
he looked at all the, the leaders of the,
of the nature of the world and said,
what did it make our lives easier
if we just had some, you know,
some kind of extra terrestrial
threat. He said, that shit,
he said that in front
of the UN wouldn't aw,
like he's trying to get everybody into
then too. I don't think he ever said that,
but no, no. He said that many times. It's
an video. Ronald Reagan, Ronald Reagan
was vice president. He was talking about,
and there's many videos of him saying,
we are what lies before us.
He's in front of the nation doing it.
State of the Union address,
saying what lies before us.
Is the opportunity to forge a new
world, order a world, an order?
Because he's talking about
like, isn't that means that
the spaces fate? Yes. No, no,
no, no, no. When people ask
me, why would they fake space?
It's always been about a fake alien
attack. You can't have a fake alien.
Never apologize. Never to kind of
a fake alien attack without space.
I've never heard of politics. He got that
space first. So they always, you know,
who promoted space more
than anybody who want Nazis,
Nazis before the Nazis, you know, Mayans,
the VAT, again, they have all the biggest,
uh, they have all the astronomers.
They're all Jesuit, Vatican, all of them,
all the ones that are giving us
this information about space.
They all come from the Vatican.
The Vatican has the most beautiful hotels
come here and know what the name of
the most powerful, you know what it's
name is the most powerful telescope.
The Bat again, and you know what name it
is. I've done the research on Youtube.
Hi Nancy.
This do you want to chill?
Is the most bellow power telescope
in the world? It's in the Vatican.
But do you know what's Lucifer that
falls Lucifer's Dick and balls.
I've never seen this fucking
talent scouts, real legit dude. Uh,
I think the biggest ones in Chile,
I think they have to be in high altitude
paddock. Yeah. I don't think it's enough.
And so when people ask me why
would they fake all this shit?
But I don't think that's the biggest thing
is just a crazy theory. I'm trying to,
I'm just, it certainly, we're
talking to these Ellis, these
funny theory, but Eddie,
these new chilay,
very large array telescopes that
they're creating are fucking gigantic.
And they take over enormous
pieces of land. Listen,
I was with Google those very large,
it's called no,
it's called the very
large telescope telescope.
I watched the documentary
with you at your house.
It was like 2001 and I think in five
years they're gonna be putting a
documentary about them putting together
the very large telescope in Chile and
they're talking about by the year
2005 we're going to have this,
we're going to have three telescopes
are linked with a computer to make us,
we're going to see further into space
than ever before. None of that shit came.
What are you talking about? Came, is that
up? Is a very, very large array up yet.
Nope. Large telescope. Um,
but I know they have the,
they have them in Hawaii.
We said weird.
Isn't it weird that every space
documentary, all the series,
I had them all, Jo, Adam, all,
we watch them all the time.
I tried to remember all this shit about
a neutron star and a super hyper Nova.
I was ballsy and Joe were balls deep in
space and then every now and then we'd
watch this documentary after documentary.
Morgan Freeman ain't got the universe.
We call that shit. I
DVR it, all that shit.
Anything that said space was fucking ball.
I thought it was better than people and
shit cause I knew so much about space
and every now and then I'd watch all
that shit and wonder and wonder what,
this is all cartoons. Eddie won, but
this is a cartoon. And then I go, okay,
whatever, whatever. And then I keep
watching all DVDs on space or I'll see GI.
There's nothing real and everyone
watches that. They believe it.
The narration is all programming
what's above us and what we're on.
We're being lied to. Once you
go flat, you never go back.
Listen, if you look a campaign,
listen was about everything.
It's not about,
it's not about who is the one thing.
This is the one thing I want to say.
Okay.
It's like it's not that we believe
something ridiculous and you don't,
you don't believe it. We're
gullible. We're gullible. We,
we believe some weird shit about the
flatter. We believe some weird shit.
You don't believe it. You're
smart. It's not about that.
It's about we actually don't know what
we're on and we always say that we don't
know, but based on all the shit
that we got by the mainstream,
we don't believe that.
Here's what I do believe that it's not
that we believe something crazy and you
don't because you smell it.
What is narrow sense?
It get a totally different tone we looked
at as you from now and we don't pay
any of that. Yeah, but you use, you use
that microphone. Use a cell phone. Right?
It's science. Hold on. I believe
at that time I believe in it. Okay.
Why do you believe in that study?
I don't need to read something to verify,
but you better benefit consignments.
You benefit from. It's not every day.
I know. I love this. To cut this off,
it's 10 o'clock.
Come see me in Vancouver at the vogue
theater and in Salt Lake City at wiseguys
march one and two. I love science. I
love science. I don't want to fight.
I want to laugh about it. I'm an idiot.
I believe in flat earth. I'm crazy.
That's all you need to know. Pasadena
Ice House fight, companion show shit.
Wednesday night, 10:00 PM
Hauler, boy, Miami Improv.
I only got March 16th, 2017 in
Washington DC. March. I'm in Miami.
Prov march.
Brand new Miami and the stories don't
listen to me. And I'm in Washington,
D C and D. Dot. K. Dot. God love
you guys. Bye everybody. Uh,
Eddie Bravo.
Anything. Uh, I just dropped a
new music video. Smoke serpent.
They're all gone. It's on youtube.
It's cut to what dreams may come.
Check it out by everybody.